Hallo Wolfgang.
Also, bist du jetzt entschieden? Bundestagswahl. Was hat dich davon abgehalten?
Weil ich dieses Polit-Entertainment-Theater mir nicht angucken möchte. Außerdem ist ja mein Herz jetzt eh nicht so nah bei diesen Kandidaten, die da vorgeschlagen sind. Und ich, ja, ich ertrage das eigentlich nicht. Ich kann mir das nicht angucken. Ich habe ein einziges Mal, glaube ich, ein Duell gesehen. Und das war das Allererste, das es in Deutschland gab. Und da waren ja auch entsprechend noch die Quoten hoch. 15 Millionen Menschen haben sich das damals angesehen. Und jetzt heißt es, waren es nur 5 Millionen. Das sind ja nicht viele.
Das glaube ich auch. Also Lindner scheint auch echte Barrieren zu haben. Manchmal lassen ja Leute so durchschimmern. Also Paul Ziemiak ist ja einer, der genau weiß, dass er jetzt genau Blödsinn erzählen muss bis zum Wahltag. Das ist bei Christian Lindner ein bisschen anders. Und in deren Sicht ist das schon so. Wir haben jetzt hier Clips geguckt zum Thema Finanzen und Inflation und EZB und Geld und Bitcoin und so. Das ist so, als würde ich mir bei YouTube jetzt Clips raussuchen, in der er irgendeinen Heil-Faster erzählt, dass man jetzt ganz viel Fleisch essen sollte, weil da so viel B12 drin ist, Vitamin B12. Und das kriegt man ja sonst gar nicht hin und Kohlehydrate sind ja ganz schlecht und so. Ja, also klar, es geht dann auch in die andere Richtung. Aber es ist so auf dieser Ebene, wo alle mithilfe ihres Smartphones und entsprechenden Social Media Apps noch mal suchen, welchen Platz in der Welt sie jetzt eigentlich einnehmen können, wo sie sich wohlfühlen und so, wo man irgendwie aufgehoben ist. Also da hat ja. Also kann ich empfehlen, in Redaktionsschluss habe ich am Ende mit Dirk Becker gesprochen, der das noch mal so aufdröselte. Wie man von der Tageszeitung als dem Gebet am Morgen, wie Hegel das so geschrieben, dann kam zu ja, sagen wir Social Media und versuchen uns einfach nur, Gott ist ja tot, aber trotzdem auf dieser Schiene zu bleiben, da uns durchwurschteln und irgendwie versuchen, den Sinn zu finden. Bleiben wir mal ein bisschen beim Thema, werden aber handgreiflicher, denn jetzt geht es um die Sachen, die uns wirklich alle betreffen. Bitcoin muss man nicht kaufen, wohnen muss man aber doch. Und wir haben eine Sachlage in Amerika und ich wollte ja zum Thema Mieten und Wohnen. Ich habe sehr viele Einsendungen bekommen, also dramatische Geschichten. Es gibt nicht einen, wo ich mal gehört habe, da hat der Vermieter mal Nachsicht gezeigt oder sowas. Dann stellt es sich aber heraus, es wäre noch interessanter, jetzt mal grundsätzlich die Frage zu klären, die wir die ganze Zeit hatten. Also wir haben es schon häufiger besprochen, aber hier ja eben auch. Was bedeutet jetzt diese ganze Zentralbankfinanzierung? Wer hat mir schon gesagt, dazu braucht man dann auch kluge Politik. Also man muss es irgendwie kombinieren. Nur Geld alleine reicht dann auch nicht, sondern man muss, wie es die Grünen jetzt auch immer wieder betonen, dann schon investieren in Sachen, von denen man auch was hat. Also jetzt finanzielle Schulden aufnehmen, um materielle Schulden abzubauen, bessere Infrastruktur und so weiter. Hinsichtlich der eigentlichen Thematik, die ich thematisieren wollte, nämlich ob Mietminderungen jetzt coronabedingt irgendwie, gibt es einen sehr interessanten Text bei Haufe.de, wo mal das Deutsche die Urteile zum Thema Vermieten, Mieten und Corona zusammengefasst wurden. Und auch da zeigt sich das Bild, dass die Gerichte meinten, zum Beispiel hier LG Lüneburg, keine Mietminderung, Corona und sogar die betriebliche Stilllegung durch den Staat bedeutet für dich nicht, dass das auch eine irgendwie Mietminderung bedeuten kann, sondern der Staat ist dann dafür da, das auszugleichen. Also es ist die Aufgabe des Staates, nicht des Vermieters, die finanziellen Menge, die da dann bestehen, aufzufangen. Und es gab überhaupt, soweit ich hier lese, wohl nur ein Urteil, wo mal ein Gericht entschied, ja, das gibt jetzt durchaus Grund, Mietminderungen anzumerken und auch durchzusetzen, weil ein Geschäft stillgelegt wurde. Ansonsten ist es in Deutschland so flächendeckend, dass Mieten bezahlt werden müssen. Und wenn Corona ist und der Staat sagt, dein Betrieb liegt jetzt still, ist es verboten, Umsatz und Gewinn zu machen, dann muss der Staat das ausgleichen. Und wenn der Staat das nicht macht, sondern einfach nur die Leute nicht mehr in deine Einkaufsstraße kommen, weil sie Angst haben vor Corona-Infektionen, dann gibt es überhaupt keine Möglichkeiten, von Mietzahlung runterzukommen, sondern dann ist deine Geschäftsgrundlage einfach erledigt und dann findet dein Vermieter einen neuen Mieter. Also das kann man glaube ich so kurz machen. Jetzt haben wir aber durch Corona auf der zweiten Ebene, durch dieses sehr viel mehr Geld, eine ganz interessante Sachlage, dass nämlich Immobilien genau die Schnittstelle sind zwischen Vermögenswerte, die ja eine erhebliche Inflationserfahren und grundlegender Bedarf, den jeder Mensch braucht. Also anders als bei Milch. Jeff Bezos geht jetzt nicht rum und kauft ganz viel Milch, sondern die Milch bleibt weiter sozusagen verfügbar. Auch wenn mehr Geld da ist. Das ist bei Immobilien anders.
Deswegen gibt es da auch keine Inflation.
Genau.
Da wäre noch nicht die Packung ein kleiner.
Ja, aber das Gegenteil ist, die ist eigentlich viel zu billig und man versucht, händeringend das irgendwie zu regeln, aber die Milch bleibt billig. Und jetzt gab es in Amerika einen interessanten Text, in dem das mal thematisiert wird. Und wir gucken hier an so eine Pseudonachrichtensendung von The Hill, dem Internetangebot, das sich da sehr viel um Washington kümmert und so, wo das wie folgt anmoderiert wurde. So, die großen, vor allem Blackrock, mischen sich auf dem Häusermarkt ein. Und das ist noch spezifischer als der Immobilienmarkt, denn Immobilien wissen wir ja, kann man ja eh verbriefen und so weiter. Dann hat man so große Assets, in die man irgendwie rein investiert. Jetzt geht es aber wirklich ganz konkret darum, wer kauft das einzelne freistehende Haus, das wirklich nur von Familien genutzt werden kann. Und auch da mischen die jetzt mit und kaufen groß auf. So wurde es im August thematisiert. Und da sprangen natürlich die ein oder anderen Sensoren an, der ein oder anderen Internetnutzer, weil schon klar ist, dass Immobilien und Flächen und Grund und Boden immer attraktiver, gerade hinsichtlich der Preissteigerung der letzten Jahre. Weshalb hier, und da gucken wir nur ganz kurz in so einem Podcast von den Timcast-Reiten, eine Frage kurz gestellt und direkt beantwortet wird. Also der Privatmensch, die private Organisation mit dem größten Farmland in Amerika ist Bill Gates. Und das hat ja sachlich gar nichts miteinander zu tun. Bill Gates ist kein Bauer. Und genau diese Gefahr droht ja dann beim Wohnen auch.
Und Zuckerberg kauft ja auch enorm Land auf.
Ja, also alle. Peter Thiel und so weiter. Groß in Neuseeland eingekauft. Naja, es führt jedenfalls zu folgendem Sachstand.
Und also sind die Dinge schon unerfüllbar. Die Dinge sind schon problematisch, wenn man ein Haus kaufen will. Das letzte, was wir brauchen, ist Wall Street Corporation, die in die Inventarien kauft und die Inventarien kauft.
So, das ist also eigentlich so ein YouTube-Kanal, wie du ihn rausgesucht hast. Revenger Consulting. Trotzdem sachlich erstmal korrekt. Es sind die höchsten Immobilienpreise überhaupt. In einer Sachlage, in der extrem hohe Arbeitslosigkeit und extrem strukturell schwache, die Unternehmen finden sich ja gerade erst wieder. Und das passt ja eigentlich nicht so ganz zusammen. Kann also im Grunde nur damit zu tun haben, dass einfach zu viel Geld da ist und jetzt auf Anlage und Investitionen zurück ist. Und gleichzeitig durch die politische Lage, die wir haben, stellen sich halt die ein oder anderen Fragen, wie zum Beispiel hier bei The Hill.
Können wir das JD Vance-Tweet auf dem Schild legen? BlackRock versucht eine Investitionstrategie, die es für junge Amerikaner schwerer machen wird, zu heiraten.
Ja, da sind wir natürlich all in, in der politischen Diskussion. Also sie haben sich hier irgend so einen Kommentator geholt, der sich...
Und man hat auch schon den Feind ausgemacht, also die Linke könnte da jetzt...
Die geht nicht hin, genau.
Also die Idee ist, dass also Blackrock sorgt dafür, dass diese Preise jetzt so nach oben geschnitten sind, weil die so da investieren und die jungen Menschen, die sich ja vorher alle Häuser leisten konnten, wie wir wissen, die können jetzt nicht.
Genau, wegen Blackrock können die nicht mehr kaufen. Angenommen, das stimmt so, 20 bis 50 Prozent, das ist so die Zahl aus dem Wall Street Journal. Das hieße ja bei den aktuellen Wertsteigerungen, dass Blackrock und Co. jetzt schon die Preise von 2023 bezahlen, in dem Wissen, dass sie aber selbst erst 2027 oder so wieder verkaufen und dann eben jetzt 20 bis 50 Prozent drüber bezahlen, aber dann den doppelten Preis irgendwie in 5, 6 Jahren bekommen. Würde ja auch irgendwie Sinn machen, das Geld auf jeden Fall ist ja da, da. David Sirota, der hier zugeschaltet ist, und das gucken wir nur aus humoristischen Gründen eigentlich, antwortet dann auch mal entsprechend.
Es ist ja nicht ganz falsch.
Ich glaube, was ja auch so von republikanischer Seite hart getroffen hat, ist, dass diese alte Aussage stimmte, es gewinnt die Wahl, wer am meisten Spenden einsammeln konnte. Und das war ja definitiv Joe Biden, der hatte 1, 6 Millionen Milliarden am Ende. Und bei Trump war es ein bisschen mehr als eine Milliarde. Das heißt, da war ein Riesenabstolland da. Und natürlich funktionieren diese Spenden auch als Einflussnahme. Das wissen wir ja.
Ja, also ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass sehr viele junge Menschen wissen, dass sie jetzt von Nancy Pelosi oder so keine Hilfe erwarten können, was jetzt ihren Hauskauf angeht.
Ja, denn die hat ja ganz gut vorgesorgt.
Ja, also die kassiert ja ordentlich.
Das sind ja Unsummen, die sie da macht an der Börse. Wie das überhaupt sein kann.
Ja, da ist man einfach irgendwie vogelfrei. Das ist so ein bisschen wie im Deutschen Bundestag, wo ja auch Marco Bülow gerade nochmal viel Wert drauflegt, dass man sagt, man kann eigentlich nicht wirklich wegen Korruption angezeigt werden im Bundestag, weil die Hürden zu hoch sind. Man muss nur einen Vortrag halten und dann kann man grenzenlos kassieren, egal für was man tatsächlich.
Aber bei Pelosi sprechen wir ja von zweistelligen Millionensummen. Jährlich, genau. Also dagegen ist Friedrich Merz wirklich ein armer Mann.
Wahrscheinlich, würde ich auch sagen. Er legt hier jedenfalls noch mal mit einem zweiten Argument nach, dass wir uns auch wieder ranholen an die Diskussion von eben.
Ich glaube, das ist die Sache, die viele Menschen nicht verstehen, über private Ökologie.
Ja, und das kennen wir ja von 2008, eine Bank geht los und sagt ich mache jetzt mal dieses und jenes Finanzgeschäft, holt sich dann die zehnfache Summe noch von einer anderen Bank, dann geht das Finanzgeschäft schief, man kann diese zehnfache Verschuldung nicht zurückzahlen und dann Kettenreaktionen durch die Banken hindurch, weil alle miteinander irgendwie verschuldet sind und am Ende die Kreditausfallversicherung natürlich auch nicht mehr funktionieren und am Ende muss der Staat eben reinhauen und das ist auch so ein bisschen die Ausgangslage. Also 2008, 9, 10 beginnt eben, also diese Häuser sind einfach nichts wert in dem Moment, die Leute ziehen aus, ziehen in ihre Bungalows, ziehen in ihre Autos, geben das an die Banken zurück, die Banken wissen nicht wohin und dann beginnt so der Moment, wo sich dann Investoren denken, naja, die werden ja irgendwann wieder bewohnt, so also gehen wir jetzt mal rein und kaufen, kaufen, kaufen und das könnte man ja sich dann gut vorstellen, dass es dann eben wirklich gipfelt in so einen Moment wie jetzt, dass dann BlackRock und so weiter in dieser Zinslage, die wir haben, einfach gar keine Investitionsmöglichkeiten finden, außer die, wo kein normaler Mensch einen Bogen drum rum machen kann, nämlich Wohnpreise Das ist die erste Reise. Und dann kauft man halt einfach auf. Und man muss ehrlich sagen, wenn man das einfach frei laufen ließe, würden die natürlich die ganzen Städte einfach aufkaufen. Also dann wären einfach, das haben wir auch schon Thema, die sind die Innenstädte einfach platt. Denn als Investitionsgut ist das immer alles besser als konkret genutzt. Also jede deutsche Einkaufsstraße kannst du entvölkern und sagen, wir machen das jetzt zum reinen Investitionsgut, lassen es drei Jahre leer stehen. Das gewinnt immer. Ob es jetzt noch 30 Jahre hält, ist mal eine andere Frage. Aber so drei, vier Jahre kann man sowas. Dann einfach aussitzen. Jetzt gibt es allerdings Widerspruch. vox.com widerspricht so ein bisschen dem Wall Street Journal.
Um es zu verabschieden, der Wall Street Journal Artikel enthält genau wie viel Geld und wie viele Häusern BlackRock und bestimmte Heldfonds und Pensionfonds und andere Institutionen jetzt kaufen. Es berät das zu einem Teil der Institutionen, die zwischen 2011 und 2017 gemacht wurden, nach dem Haushaltmarktkrasch von 2008 und 2009. Und es gibt auch einige Meinungen, wie diese Investitionen aktiv sind, und dass sie in der Zukunft auch noch mehr kosten werden, wie die Verlust von Eingriffen und die Anzahl von Eingriffen, um Dinge zu machen. Dann hat Vox einen Artikel aufgeführt, der sich um BlackRock bestätigt hat.
Warum die Preise in den USA in den letzten sechs Monaten so drastisch aufgelaufen sind. Das ist ein Thema, das ich nicht so ganz gut verstehen. Und natürlich irgendwie auf Sicherheit gehen. Also wir haben das ja schon erlebt. Goldpreise gehen nach oben, Silberpreise ganz verrückt oben und und und. Und dann hat man auch diese Krypto Szene. Und selbstverständlich stimmt es ja, dass man, wenn man Grund und Boden hat und ein Haus hat, eine andere Form der Absicherung hat und dass das deshalb sehr attraktiv ist. Und was ich so aus meinem Umfeld mitbekomme, irgendwelche jungen Familien, die ein Haus suchen, dass die dann da Schlange stehen, in einem Cuff bei Koblenz. Also nicht jetzt direkt im Zentrum, sondern im Cuff bei Koblenz mit 50 Menschen, die dann irgendein Haus besichtigen, das extrem renovierungsbedürftig ist und trotzdem wahnsinnig viel Geld kostet. Und das ist aber von denen angetrieben. Also das wollen die ja machen. Und da ist dann ja nicht schon Blackrock oder so mit im Spiel. Es gibt da so eine psychologische Komponente, glaube ich, auch dabei, dass momentan gerade alle sagen, ist da noch eine Garage frei, dann kaufe ich sie.
Also vor allem das, was du zuerst angesprochen hast, ist natürlich ganz wichtig. Menschen suchen jetzt echte Wohnung, also wo sie einfach einziehen können. Gleichzeitig setzen sehr viele da, konnten jetzt anderthalb Jahre lang nicht in dem Maße konsumieren wie vorher. Also der Urlaub war irgendwie 2000 Euro billiger und man ist auch nicht mehr so viel abends ausgegangen und so weiter. Und plötzlich sind so 10.000 Euro am Jahresende übrig. Und man denkt sich so, wo kann man noch investieren? Wo bringt es noch Geld? Aha, Immobilien. Und 10.000 Euro und Immobilien vertragen sich ja eigentlich schlecht, weil für 10.000 Euro kannst du ja nichts kaufen. Also gibt man das irgendeinem Vermögensverwalter, der dann wieder und so weiter. Und am Ende landet das dann doch auf dem Markt und konkurriert eben mit denjenigen, die konkret Schlange stehen. Weil dann irgendwie noch ein zweites Angebot von so einer Bank kommt und so weiter, weil 20 Leute mal 10.000 Euro reichen dann eben doch wieder, um da mitzubieten.
Ja, sehr wahrscheinlich. Und es ist ja auch sehr nachvollziehbar, warum Leute dann Eigenheim wollen. Also Handelsblatt, nicht für linksradikale Auswüchse bekannt, hat jetzt mal eine Statistik veröffentlicht, wie sich die Mieten in Deutschland veröffentlicht, entwickelt haben in der Ära Merkel.
Ganz wichtiger Zeitraum.
Beginn Merkel, Ende Merkel. In Köln plus 65 Prozent, München plus 81 Prozent, Hamburg plus 97 Prozent, Berlin plus 130 Prozent. Also verständlich, dass Leute sagen, gut, ich habe da 2005 angefangen zu arbeiten, habe da eigentlich ganz gut verdient, dann habe ich so ein bisschen Lohnentwicklung gehabt, weil ich zu den zu dem neunzigsten Prozent, dann zu den 90 Prozent, 90 bis 95 Prozent gehört, habe ich eigentlich auch ein bisschen dazu verdient. Aber die Miete ist so spektakulär nach oben gegangen, dass das überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und da sind dann Leute, die sagen, gut, ich verdiene jetzt eigentlich 20 Prozent mehr, als ich 2005 verdient habe. Und dennoch bin ich jetzt ärmer geworden durch die Mieten und die suchen natürlich jetzt auch.
Genau, und die Kalkulation ist ja super einfach und nachvollziehbar in dem Moment, wo du sagst, ich kaufe und zahle dann einen Kredit zurück, vermietest du ja an dich selbst. Also du bezahlst zwar jeden Monat, aber nach 20 Jahren oder 30, das Ding eben dir. Das ist bei Mieten eben anders. Man fragt sich, was rechtfertigt eigentlich diese Art der Mietpreisgestaltung. Und wir kombinieren jetzt alles zusammen. Also zum einen, wer treibt sich alles auf dem Häusermarkt mit rum?
Ich runne eine Datenkonsultation, die Leute mit Daten helfen, um zu finden, in welchen Städten zu investieren. Die größte Inzidenz im Home-Besicht der Investoren in den letzten 10-15 Jahren kommt nicht von großen Unternehmen, sondern von amatueren Mom- und Pop-Investoren, die nur ein paar Unternehmen haben. Das ist das, was diese Hausaufgabe stimuliert.
Ja, also Blackrock spielt auch eine Rolle. Klar, wie immer überall, aber so ein Single-Family-Haus ist halt dann doch auch für die sehr formal aufwendig, also zum Notar zu gehen und so weiter. Für jemanden, der aber 50.000 Dollar hat und nur die und die dann investieren möchte, der geht den Weg einfach mit, weil er langweilt sich ja eh drei Tage die Woche abends, also macht er das einfach als Projekt, dann sich da irgendwo rein zu investieren. Entsprechend sind auch die Verhältnisse. Also wir haben die höchsten Preise in Amerika im Immobilienmarkt, in diesem Wohnimmobilienmarkt. Gleichzeitig, wie er jetzt sagte, und das ist erstmal so von ihm die gefühlte Realität, sehr viele Menschen, die da einfach investieren wollen. Und es stimmt wahrscheinlich, wenn wir uns jetzt noch mal bei Remventure Consulting hier diese Zahlen anhören. Er geht jetzt mal die Unternehmen durch, die in diese Art der Einfamilienhäuser investieren. Über BlackRock will er gleich sprechen, aber er nimmt erstmal Invitation Homes und American Homes. Das sind zwei Unternehmen, die sind vor allem 2008 dann aufgeblüht, weil da dachten sie einfach an Investoren, ah cool, Preise liegen am Boden, jetzt kaufen wir mal ein. Und jetzt erklärt er, wie viel haben die eigentlich gekauft und es sind eben die beiden größten Unternehmen in diesem Markt geschehen.
Ein bisschen später, also aufhören. Das sind die zwei größten Einfamilien, die heute in Amerika sind. Die Portfolie dieser beiden Unternehmen beträgt ca. 0, 15% der US-Hausungskraft.
So, die beiden größten kommen zusammen auf 0, 15% Markteigentum. BlackRock liegt noch darunter. Wenn wir uns alle institutionellen Investoren zusammennehmen, erklärt das nicht, warum wir die höchsten Preise überhaupt haben. Sondern vermutlich sind wir jetzt wirklich an dem Punkt, wo das eine politische Dimension hat, weil wir strukturell einfach ein Problem damit haben in Amerika. Und du hast ja Zahlen aus Deutschland vorgelegt, da kommen wir gleich zu. Junge Familien, die Häuser wirklich brauchen, um beispielsweise auch den Nachwuchs für den Arbeitsmarkt aufzuziehen und so. Also das ganz funktionale politische Argument. Die finden, die kommen jetzt nicht in Wohnung. Also die schaffen es einfach nicht jetzt. Klar, die können jetzt mieten, aber mieten macht die in Amerika nicht glücklich. Du hast ja dann eine Quote von über 50 Prozent Eigenheimen. Das ist ja anders als in Deutschland. Und das muss jetzt kombiniert werden. Und man kann jetzt aber nicht einfach aus so einer politischen Beobachter-Richtung sagen, ja, da müssen sich mal Blackhawks und so jetzt zusammenreißen und so. Nee, da braucht es jetzt mal richtige Politik, um diese Inflation, Vermögenswerden von oben und den Bedarf von unten zusammenzubringen. Und hier wird es jetzt auch ein bisschen rentenrepublikanisch, auch in Amerika. Jeff Vahn charakterisiert hier nochmal die aktuelle politische Triebfeder und die kennen wir auch schon aus Move. Also die größte Migrationsbewegung, junge Menschen ziehen in die Städte, das ist genau wie in Deutschland. Es sind also diese Preise die letzten 15 Jahre, das betrifft vor allem U40, belastet das nicht U60.
Köln, München, Hamburg, Berlin. Und Berlin dann bei 130 Prozent.
Genau.
Also es ist so eine irre Zahl.
Wenn man in die Stadt zieht, ist man tendenziell U40 und nicht U60. Da zieht man dann eher wieder raus. Also diese Preise werden kompletto.
Man kriegt es in der Bahn mit. Ich bin ja jetzt viel Bahn gefahren und man hört ja dann, auch wenn es im Ruheabteil ist, und das hasse ich wirklich, wenn da gesprochen wird, ich ermahne auch, ich ermahne die Rentnerrepublik laufend im Ruheabteil. Ja, so bin ich. Und man hört aber dann diese Gespräche und es unterhalten sich dann Rentner untereinander oder ich sage jetzt einfach mal 60, unterhalten sich, kommen aus Berlin und sagen dann ja, ich habe ja meinen Sohn besucht, der ist jetzt da und dort. Die anderen sagen ja, meine Tochter ist jetzt weggezogen, die hat ja früher in Hamburg gelebt und es geht nur so. Und die gehen aber dann alle wieder zurück. Die eine Dame stieg aus, die musste ins Rheingau, die anderen gingen an die Mosel. Also da hat man sich dann so platziert und muss wahrscheinlich aber ein bisschen was überweisen nach Berlin, damit das da noch weiter finanziert werden kann.
Genau. So und jetzt haben wir diese Gemengelage. Die Jungen ziehen in die Stadt und die Alten leben halt weiter auf ihrem Lande. Und hier können wir einen kleinen Bogenschlag machen zu dieser Inflationskalkulation. Aus welcher Perspektive muss man es eigentlich betrachten? Bei ihm hier ist es mal ganz anschaulich. Also eine wichtige institutionelle Stimme sagt der Boomer mit 32 Jahren im Vergleich zum Millenial heute mit 32 Jahren hat 60 Prozent mehr Wohnungen für sein Geld bekommen und das sind ja 30 Jahre die ungefähr umrissen werden. Also 60 Prozent Inflation in 30 Jahren. So overall irgendwie das scheint ja schon so eine relevante Sache zu sein. So und er greift auch noch mal diese Blackrock-Thematisierung auf und ordnet sie dann ein. Also immer so ein zarter Versuch, so Verständnis irgendwie zu erheben. Würde ich jetzt muss man nicht bei Blackrock, da kann man auch mal durchregulieren, aber macht jetzt die Suppe nicht fett, also nur das Blackrock da drin hängt. Daran liegt es nicht. Ben Shapiro, für diejenigen, die ihn nicht kennen, also ganz rechtslastiger Kommentator bei YouTube, der mit Newswire oder so unendliche Reichweiten-Erfolge hatte, hat immer noch so eine Ben Shapiro Show, schreibt irgendwie so ein Buch nach dem anderen. Und er versucht jetzt nicht zaghaft.
Da hat er immer noch ein riesen Publikum, oder?
Immer noch, ja. Er versucht nicht so zaghaft, BlackRock aus dem Schuss zu nehmen, sondern mal ordentlich. Und ich würde sagen, es ist nicht ganz verkehrt. Ja, sei nicht wütend auf BlackRock, sondern diejenigen, die die Politik machen, die die Zentralbank dazu bringt, zu viel Geld in den Markt zu werfen. Das Geld wird ja in den Markt geworfen, haben wir auch schon mal so thematisiert, weil die Politik zögert. Also die EZB in Europa macht ja immer viel, weil die Politik es nicht auf die Reihe bekommt, weil es zu lange dauert. Pandemiehilfe muss eben sein und da werden 1, 5 Billionen da über Europa ausgekippt. Und ja, zwei Monate später ist dann dankenswerterweise auch Olaf Scholz mal so weit.
Nur frage ich mich, was er damit eigentlich meint. Und das ist ja ein gängiges Argument, dass er auch so bei deutschen neoliberalen Konservativen immer wieder aufkommt. Was wäre denn, wenn die Zentralbank das nicht machen würde? Denn das würde doch bedeuten, dass wir jetzt mal uns so zurückbeamen in Zeiten mit hohen Zinsen. Also das waren ja durchaus auch die 70er Jahre, 80er Jahre. Ich weiß immer noch, dann hat meine Großmuttergott, hab sie selig erzählt. Ja, damals, da hatte ich 20.000 Mark auf dem Bundesstaatsbrief verzinst mit 7 Prozent und so was. Jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen, man würde heute ein Haus kaufen auf Kredit, muss 200.000, 300.000 abzahlen, was auch immer. Und hätte da jetzt solche Zinsen wie früher, das würde bedeuten, wenn man dann 20 Jahre, 25 Jahre das Haus abzahlt, und das ist ja eine gängige Zeit, zahlt man das quasi doppelt durch die Zinsen. Und ich frage mich immer, was jetzt diese Leute, die dann sagen, ja, dieses lockere Geld, was die da machen, wenn die das nicht machen würden, und wir hätten jetzt ganz hohe Zinsen, dann ging es ja keineswegs denen, die jetzt ein Haus kaufen wollen, besser. Denn Kredite wären dann erst mal schwieriger zu bekommen. Und wenn sie sie bekämen, dann müssten sie extrem viel abstottern an Zins.
Genau. Also das ist auch eine ganz relevante Kritik, die man Ben Shapiro hier bringen müsste. Es gibt dafür erst mal keine Alternative. 2008 war dankenswert eine Krise, die, wie wir heute wissen, nicht allzu krass war. Aber man konnte schon mal einstudieren institutionell, was man 2020 zu Corona dann ganz schnell gemacht hat, weil man wusste, so schlimm wird es nicht. Also es ist für alle dann besser. Er hat ja nicht gesagt, geh zur Zentralbank und sagt, die sollen das nicht machen, sondern geh zum Kongress und fordere bessere Politik. Aber die einzige Alternative zu dem, dass die Zentralbanken jetzt einfach sagen, dann versorgen wir erst mal mit Geld, wenn der Markt ausfällt, haben wir ja bei der Hyperinflation vor 100 Jahren gehabt, als einfach der Staat sagte, na dann bezahlen wir jetzt die Löhne. Und dann hat man halt über die Löhne sozusagen, also Leute hatten unendlich viel Geld zu kaufen, aber es gab halt dann nichts mehr. Und dann musste man irgendwie mit Schubkarre und so weiter. Und das ist ja keine Alternative, die wir heute wirklich, also dann lieber, dass die EZB irgendwie Geld gibt. Und dann, und das ist aber die Forderung, die wir ja auch schon hatten, dass die Politik dann nicht irgendwas macht mit dem Geld, sondern genau unterscheidet, wo fließt es denn hin. Also dann muss einfach politisch klug gesteuert werden. In diesem Stefanikation-Sinne, dass man eben...
Nur dann müsste man die EZB auf jeden Fall ziemlich umbauen, damit sie das machen kann.
Ja, dann müsste man ihr auch mehrere Mandate geben, nämlich nicht nur Inflation, sondern auch Arbeitsmarkt und Klimaschutz und so weiter. Also das gehört dann dazu.
Dann drehen ja diese Leute, die sich hier beschweren, richtig durch.
Da sind wir in Deutschland ganz weit davon weg.
Das finden sie ja jetzt schon, dass die sich da was anmaßen, was sie gar nicht dürfen. Das ist ja im Wahlprogramm der AfD zu lesen, aber auch CDU und FDP blinken da ganz deutlich und sagen, jetzt machen die hier die grüne Politik plötzlich ohne Mandat.
Und da würde sich auch das Hufeifen schließen, weil da würden einfach die Linken sagen, aber das ist ja gar nicht demokratisch legitimiert, was da passiert. Das müssen ja die Parlamente machen. Genau, also in deren Sicht sind wir erstmal ausweglos. Wir halten trotzdem fest, also er fordert Politik, macht mal bessere Politik. Und gut, das habe ich gesagt, er gibt mehr so den Politikern die Schuld, möchte von ihnen bessere Politik. Die Zentralbanken trotzdem, das ist halt Ben Shapiro, nimmt da noch mit in den Blick und sagt auch hier, ihr verhaltet euch falsch.
Du bist an die falschen Leute angreift.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist zu kurz gesprungen. Alle deutschen Sparer, die sich wünschen, dass die EZB nicht wie ein Imperium auftritt und alle versorgt, können sich nicht vorstellen, in welcher Welt sie lebten, würde die EZB das nicht machen. Denn dann wäre es auch mit ihrem Ersparten nicht gut bestellt. Als dritten Clip von Ben Shapiro, die sozusagen für den einzelnen betroffenen Nutzer oder Haus nichtbesitzerpolitische Person, der relevante Punkt.
Und du solltest auch erklären, warum du denkst, dass der heutige Heimwohner nicht die Recht hat, weil er nur ein Teil des Börsen und eine verfliehende Preise hat.
Das ist ja ganz interessant, denn in Deutschland haben wir ja eben auch die Merkel-Jahre haben uns ja von 700 auf 1, 4 Millionen Millionäre gebracht. Und wenn wir jetzt die Hausbesitzer, die es gibt, warum sollten die nicht an BlackRock verkaufen dürfen? Also wenn wir jetzt eine politische Regulierung haben wollen, wie sieht dieses Gesetz aus, mit dem wir dann der Rentnerrepublik diese Art von Fesseln anlegen? Also sozusagen nicht von BlackRock aus regulieren, sondern vom Hausbesitzer aus. Und das klammern wir aber nachher alles zusammen mit dem Ulmer-Modell, wo das nämlich alles mal gemacht wird. Ist einfach super, super, super interessant.
Aber wir sehen auch jetzt hier, weil du das ja gerade nochmal von uns eingespielt hast, dass es ein Ungerechtigkeitsempfinden sehr stark gibt. Und dass man jetzt, glaube ich, sehr aufpassen muss, dass da nicht ein zu großes Vakuum entsteht. Beziehungsweise das Vakuum ist schon da und da springen diese Leute da gerade alle rein. Ben Shapiro oder so ein Mark Friedrich und wie sie alle heißen. Und das wäre eigentlich was, wo die linken Parteien, also SPD, Linke, Grüne mehr ein Augenmerk drauf legen sollten. Damit nicht irgendwann das wirklich so ist, dass wir in vier Jahren dann eine FDP haben, die so tut, als würde sie hier den Klassenkauf machen für die armen Leute. Denn das geht schon in so eine gewisse Richtung. Das merkt man jetzt auch bei so manchen Aussagen, dass man denkt, hat er das jetzt gerade gesagt? Und im größeren Kontext macht das natürlich dann auch wieder Sinn oder es ergibt Sinn.
Genau, also bei Jeff Wan, der ist ein bisschen runtergedimmt, nicht Ben Shapiro Niveau und so. Kann man ja hören, wenn ihr wütend seid, beschwert euch bei der Regierung. Also hier liegt auf jeden Fall Klassenkampfpotenzial begraben. So, obstöne Geldbeträge werden gedruckt. Jetzt haben wir ja schon gesagt, wir wollen uns jetzt keine Welt vorstellen, der das nicht passiert, aber kriegt man vielleicht trotzdem es in den Griff, das Matching zwischen brauchten Haus und hatten Haus zu organisieren, ohne immer über den Höchstpreis zu gehen und dann deshalb wieder Investoren und so weiter rein zu holen, die das ja gar nicht zum Wohnen brauchen, sondern eben nur weil da Geld im Spiel ist. Und dann schauen wir uns jetzt mal an, wie das in Deutschland funktioniert. Der ehemalige Hamburger Bürgermeister tritt gerade bei der Bundestagswahl an, Olaf Scholz, und ist sehr stolz darauf, dass er in Hamburg, wo ja eigentlich der Mietendeckel erfunden wurde, ist ja in Hamburg ein Senatsthema gewesen, dann wurde er aber in Berlin verwirklicht und er ist sehr stolz darauf, dass er in Hamburg nicht sein musste, da man dort das ja über kluge Politik gelöst hat. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, in Koblenz ist es außer Rand und Band. In Hamburg auch. Panorama. Hier am 24. August hat mal kurz jemanden begleitet, der sich ein Haus anschaut oder beziehungsweise als verhöhkern möchte in Hamburg. Also wirklich in der Stadt Hamburg.
Außerdem ist das Dachgeschoss unbeheizt, die Fenster einfach verglast, die Wände ungedämmt und der Keller feucht. Und für dieses stark sanierungsbedürftige Haus will der...
Ja, es sieht aus, als hättest du in Ahrweiler gestanden, als sei die Flut einmal durchgerast.
Jetzt können alle kurz überlegen, welchen Betrag könnte man für so ein Haus verlösen?
Dass es das in Hamburg gibt und wirklich ein Untergeschoss oder was das war, als seine Flut durch...
Also wir lassen uns den Hauspreis mal nennen. Müssen sich alle kurz setzen. Also nicht, dass ihr jetzt überrascht werdet, wenn ihr den Preis hört.
Und für dieses stark sanierungsbedürftige Haus will der Makler 600.000 Euro haben. Mindestens. Denn er verkauft im Geburtsverfahren, also an den, der das meiste Geld bietet. Dabei steht das Haus in Hamburg-Billwerder, einem Stadtteil, der eher ländlich und nicht sehr zentral ist. Doch auch hier kann man offenbar längst solche Preise verlangen.
Ja, also jenseits des Hauses ist nur noch Acker. Das ist am Rande von Hamburg. Das ist ganz weit weg und kostet 600.000 Euro. Obwohl völlig klar ist, dieser Preis ist ungerechtfertigt. In dem Haus wird niemals jemand wohnen. Selbst derjenige, der es zum Eigenbedarf kauft, reißt das ab und baut neu.
Ja, sonst muss man halt wahrscheinlich 300.000 Euro reinstecken, um das bewohnbar zu machen.
Also das ist ein völliger Nonsenspreis, der nur aufgerufen wird, weil er aufgerufen werden kann, weil es um das Grundstück geht. Und die 600.000 Euro sind volkswirtschaftlich verschwendetes Geld. Denn wir wollen ja dieses Grundstück irgendwelchen jungen Familien geben, und da lohnt es sich ja nicht am Anfang ihres gemeinsamen 40-jährigen Lebens auf diesem Grund und Boden ihnen erst mal 600.000 Euro Miese. Also was soll das? Es gibt aber trotzdem Interessenten.
Patrick Hegedüß wohnt in der Nähe und sucht schon seit Längerem für sich und seine Familie. Das Haus hier will er am liebsten abreißen, denn Grundstücke wie dieses gibt es kaum noch in Hamburg.
Das ist sozusagen das Sahnehäubchen hier hinten. Absolut, das ist das, wofür ich Ihnen hier gerne das Geld am Ende des Tages aus der Tasche ziehen möchte.
Das Grundstück ist fast 2000 Quadratmeter groß und Bauland in Städten wie Hamburg knapp. Auch deshalb ist Hegedüß bereit, viel Geld für ein Haus zu zahlen, das er eigentlich gar nicht will.
Man bezahlt auch nicht viel Grundstück ohne Haus, inzwischen auf so einem Kurs. Weil die Preise sind ja inzwischen sehr krank geworden.
Mit wie viel Geld kalkulieren Sie da?
Also es ist ja jetzt schon 600.000 ungefähr plus.
So, damit eine Familie in Hamburg leben kann, müssen 1, 4 Millionen mobilisiert werden. Und dann lebt überhaupt nur eine Familie auf 2.000 Quadratmeter. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, in keiner Dimension, in der man das durchdenkt. Die Stadt hat da Grund und Boden. 2.000 Quadratmeter, das reicht für 10, 20 Familien. Da muss nicht eine einzeln und dann nicht zu diesem Preis. Also es ergibt einfach keinen Sinn. Das ist keine wirtschaftlich, also volkswirtschaftlich kluge Lösung. Das macht alle wissen.
Hier in Frankfurt hat man das so gemacht. Da muss man hochbauen, ja.
Hier in Frankfurt, das Europaviertel, also früher die Bahnanlagen, die zur Messe führten oder hier in Niederrad, wo 70.000 Büroarbeitsplätze waren, die jetzt nicht mehr so viel gebraucht werden, wird komplett umgewandelt in Passivhaus-Wohnraum, siebenstöckig oder sechsstöckig. So, und dann wird da einfach gemeinschaftlich drauf gewohnt und dann kriegst du locker 20 Familien auf 2.000 Quadratmeter, ohne dass das jetzt zu irgendwelchen großen Platznöten oder so. Klar, man hat dann keinen eigenen Garten und so weiter, aber das ist, du hast dann auf jeden Fall mehreren Familien geholfen und nicht nur einer, für die es betriebswirtschaftlich gerade so ist. Ja, also das ist einfach absurd. München, ganz ähnliche Preise. Also wir sind hier auf amerikanischem Niveau. Hier eine Sendung ARD Respekt, die erst am 24. September überhaupt im Fernsehen kommt, aber Mediathek sein Dank.
Neue Mitangebote, zwei Zimmer circa 50 Quadratmeter ab 1290 Euro zuzüglich Nebenkosten. 1290, das sind 26 Euro pro Quadratmeter Kaltmiete. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Also 26 Euro Quadratmeter Miete. Das ist der Quadratmeter Kaufpreis in der Eifel teilweise. Also das passt einfach nicht mehr zusammen. Mir fällt wirklich auseinander. Er sitzt jetzt hier in München in 50 Quadratmeter.
Da muss 1300 Euro waren das jetzt.
Irgendwie so kalt.
Kalt zahlen. Also das heißt, da kommen dann noch mal 1500, 1500, 1600, 1600 drauf. Also 1600, 1700. Da kann man ja wirklich schon fast sagen, man zieht ins Hotel, oder?
Ja, das ist absurd. Er war jetzt beim OB Dieter Reiter, also in München beim Oberbürgermeister, der jetzt selbst schon mal, und wir nähern uns so langsam, den Lösungen, zumindest für die städtischen Wohnungen, eine Lösung vorgeschlagen hat.
Wir haben im letzten Jahr so viel Baugenehmigungen erteilt wie noch nie zuvor. Wir haben auch mehr Wohnungen gebaut als die vorigen Jahre, nur der Druck ist damit nicht wirklich weniger geworden, weil auch noch mehr Menschen zu uns kamen und der Bedarf an Wohnraum immer weiter steigt. Wir haben jetzt für unsere eigenen 66.000 Wohnungen, die der Stadt gehören, einfach eine eigene kommunale Mietpreisbremse erfunden.
So, eine kommunale Mietpreisbremse erfunden heißt, für uns gilt der Markt nicht mehr. Ja, der Mietspiegel sagt irgendwas, aber davon müssen wir jetzt weg. Und interessanterweise ist es nicht nur die Stadt, die jetzt für ihr eigenes Eigentum gesagt hat, wir machen eine Mietpreisbremse. 66.000 städtische Wohnungen ist ja nicht ohne, sondern auch die Stadtwerke gehen jetzt in dieses alte feudalistische Modell über.
Einige Unternehmen wollen und können auf die Politik nicht mehr warten, denn sie finden schon jetzt in Großstädten keine Fachkräfte mehr. Sie nehmen das Problem selbst in die Hand, bauen nun auf eigene Faust Betriebswohnungen. Die Stadtwerke München zum Beispiel.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass wir in München natürlich in einem enormen Wettbewerb um Fachkräfte, aber auch sämtliche andere Berufsgruppen sind. Wir haben hier eine hohe Nachfrage nach Mitarbeitern in der Stadt, was ja eigentlich gut ist, in einer prosperierenden Region auch zu sein. Aber in diesem Wettbewerb brauchen wir Angebote, die wir schaffen. Und das ist für uns unter anderem das Thema Wohnen, Mitarbeiterwohnen, günstigen Wohnraum, den es vereinfacht gesprochen zum Arbeitsvertrag mit dazu gibt.
Also das ist Mittelalter. Das ist nicht mehr moderne.
Manche Firmen haben das ja bis in die 60er, 70er Jahre betrieben. Und dann haben sie das in den 80ern so langsam aufgegeben. Und inzwischen machen sie das wieder, weil sie Fachkräfte brauchen. Also gerade so große deutsche Konzerne, die sehr darauf aus sind, möglichst reibungslos Leuten zu ermöglichen, zu kommen. Denn wenn man sagt, oh Gott, ich muss in die Stadt und da muss ich dann noch drei Monate mit meiner Familie rumirren, bis ich irgendwas gefunden habe. Was sollen die mir eigentlich da an Mehrgehalt zahlen, dass ich das rechne? Und die bieten dann genauso was an. Und was man auch hier ganz gut sehen kann, ist, dass dadurch ja generell Druck rausgenommen wird. Also das heißt, es sind ja dann weniger Nachfragen da auf dem normalen Mietmarkt. Denn es ist ja eine vollkommen falsche Lehre zu behaupten, ja wir müssen einfach nur die Baugenehmigung vereinfachen und müssen das unbürokratisch machen und dann wird ganz, ganz viel gebaut. Als sei eigentlich der Markt bzw. die Marktakteure, als seien die nicht an Knappheit interessiert. Das ist ja Quatsch. Also wenn ich ja jetzt sagen würde, Stefan, wir machen so ein tolles Investor-Modell und wir bauen jetzt mehrere Häuser, die wir vermieten, dann würden wir ja dahin gehen, wo es richtig knapp ist, wo wir wissen, ok, da wollen so viele Leute hin, da bauen wir jetzt ein bisschen. Aber wir hoffen natürlich, dass die Knappheit bleibt, damit wir hohe Mieten kassieren können. Wir wären ja vollkommen irre, wenn wir sagen, wir gehen irgendwo in den Hund zurück, wo keiner hin will. Und dort bauen wir dann, denn dann haben wir zwar irgendwas gebaut, aber keiner zieht ein und wir können keine entsprechenden Mieten beziehen. Das heißt, die Knappheit ist etwas, worauf das ganze Geschäft der Vermieter beruht. Deswegen ist es ein Irrtum zu glauben, dass Vermieter eigentlich gerne ganz ganz viele Wohnungen hätten. Nein, natürlich nicht.
Genau. Und wir hören auch gleich die Immobilienwirtschaft dazu. Aber du sagst es genau richtig. Und das ist ja auch mal ein Punkt, den man hier mal machen kann. Die deutsche Bevölkerung in Deutschland wächst ja seit 1970 nicht mehr, nennenswert. Wir sind so bei 60, 70 Millionen. Der Rest ist Zuzug, Ausländeranteil. Übrigens zum Thema 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Also 2015 war das eine Jahr, wo die deutsche Bevölkerung mal im Durchschnitt gewachsen ist. Also die Bevölkerung in Deutschland, aber nicht die deutsche Bevölkerung, sondern nur durch den Zuzug der jungen Menschen. Und trotzdem haben wir diese Art von Knappheit in den Städten. Und es hängt natürlich mit dieser Binnenmigration zusammen, wie in Amerika schon vorhin gehört, wie in MUF schon gelesen. Das ist natürlich in Deutschland auch Thema hier. ZDF Wiesow hat es mal im August aufgegriffen.
Die steigenden Mieten, sie sind vor allem Folge des Wohnungsmangels. Denn die Zahl der Haushalte hat sich in den Großstädten in den letzten 20 Jahren um mehr als 25 Prozent erhöht. Selbst in Kleinstädten bis 100.000 Einwohner um rund 15 Prozent. Ein Hauptgrund für mehr Haushalte, es wohnen immer mehr Menschen allein.
Ja, immer mehr Menschen allein, klar, es sind junge Menschen. Also die ziehen in die Städte, kommen alleine, nicht alle studieren und sind deswegen irgendwie so im WG-Mindset, sondern ziehen halt einfach in die Stadt und wollen dann nach dem Arbeitstag ihre Ruhe haben, erst mal und so. Also gibt es da Bedarf der, also die Knappheit wird alleine durch Zuzug ausgelöst.
Und vielleicht noch der Vollständigkeit halber, natürlich wohnen wir heute auf etwas mehr Fläche. Also wir haben jetzt verglichen mit den 60er Jahren mehr Fläche, das glaube ich können Familien ganz gut bestätigen, wie selten das war, dass Kinder eigene Kinderzimmer haben. Das ist heute viel verbreiteter und dadurch ist etwas mehr Fläche da. Aber diese Urbanisierungwelle ist natürlich das Entscheidende.
Genau und Urbanisierung heißt in Deutschland, wo ja nicht insgesamt die Bevölkerung wächst, immer auch De-Urbanisierung oder wie auch immer der Gegenbegriff heißt. Also die Leute kommen ja irgendwo her und entsprechend fallen dann auch die Preise auseinander. Und wenn man in Deutschland sagt, naja wir haben zu wenig Wohnung, stimmt ja nicht, wenn man einfach ganz Deutschland nimmt und einen Durchschnitt drüber zieht. Denn wir haben mehr leerstehende als zu knappe Wohnung in den Großstädten, nur eben regional nicht so verteilt, wie wir es brauchen, was zu entsprechender Preisentwicklung hier führt.
In den Städten und deren Umland ist es teurer als auf dem Land. Die Grundstücke sind rar und die Nachfrage ist groß. Am teuersten ist es in Berlin. Dort kostet ein Quadratmeter rund 1100 Euro. Am günstigsten ist es in Sachsen-Anhalt. Dort kostet der Quadratmeter nur 31 Euro.
Ja, dazwischen liegen 300 Kilometer und 1100 Euro.
1124 Euro liegen dazwischen.
Das ist einfach grandios, wie es auseinanderfällt. Das war jetzt ein Clip von 3satmacro. Noch mal zurück zur CDF. Wieso? Die Bodenpreisentwicklung in Deutschland, grandios. Hier ist der sachliche Vergleich jetzt. Man kann das historisch aufziehen, wenn man das in Prozenten ausdrückt. Also schon 31 mit 1154. Das würde in Prozenten schon nur noch humoristischen Gehalt haben. Bei der Bodenpreisentwicklung werden hier Prozentzahlen genannt.
Die Bodenpreise in den Großstädten steigen extrem, bundesweit um mehr als 2300 Prozent seit den 60ern. In München seit 1950 sogar um mehr als irre 62.000 Prozent.
62.000 Prozent, das ist natürlich immer, wie vorhin schon gesagt, während alle älteren Leute in Deutschland, die zu viel ältere Literatur gelesen haben, Angst vor Inflation haben. Und 2, 1, oh nein, das geht nicht, muss unter 2 sein. Während die Jungen, die keinen Kopf dafür haben, sich um Inflationssorgen zu machen, gleichzeitig mit solchen Problemen zu tun haben. Also hier fällt es wirklich auseinander. Und jetzt hast du ja auch schon die Merkel-Jahre. Und das finde ich ist auch ganz wichtig. Wir müssen hier, CDF Wiesow macht es nicht so eindeutig, aber wir können ja sagen, das sind jetzt mal die Merkel-Jahre beim sozialen Wohnraum. Also da, wo Politik, sozialer Wohnraum ist ja sozusagen das Letzte, wo die Politik noch geholfen hat jetzt, das vergleichen wir gleich mal, wie es früher war. Aber die Merkel-Jahre und der soziale Wohnbau wären gleichzeitig diese Preisentwicklung stattfand.
Bundesweit hat sich die Zahl der geförderten Wohnungen innerhalb von wenigen Jahren in Deutschland fast halbiert.
Ja, und die wenigen Jahre beginnen hier bei 2006 und 2, 1 Millionen.
So, da ist Merkel ein Jahr am Amt.
Minuten verschwindet in Deutschland eine Sozialwohnung vom Markt.
Und wir sind jetzt bei 1, 1. Also noch mal 15 Jahre und es wären quasi null, wenn die Entwicklung irgendwie unter Merkel so weitergeht.
Laschet würde das schaffen.
Laschet würde das schaffen. Nun, das wäre wahrscheinlich auch sein Ziel. Die Stadtbaurätin von München, Elisabeth Merck, trägt mal juristische Argumente und Instrumente vor, die man so machen könnte, um zum Beispiel Bodenpreise ein bisschen einzufangen. Wir haben uns ja heute sehr auf diese Sozialwohnung. Also wenn irgendwo thematisiert wird, geht es immer um Sozialwohnungen, weil die kann man irgendwie durchzählen und das Prinzip hat so jeder ein bisschen verstanden. Es gibt allerdings sehr viel mehr Handlungsmöglichkeiten, wie wir dann gleich in Ulm, großes Finale bei dem Thema gleich, wie wir das gleich hören.
Die Stadt verwandelt derzeit mehrere Kasernen in sozial durchmischte Quartiere, versucht zu regulieren. Die Mieten sind in München deutschlandweit Spitzenreiter, das Hauptproblem der Bodenpreis.
Wir ziehen natürlich eigentlich alle Register der Instrumente, die wir haben. Wir haben Erhaltungssatzungsgebiete 26, wo wir also Gegenteilungen einschreiten können und auch Luxussanierungen vermeiden können. Wir haben die Zweckentfremdungssatzung, wo man sagen kann, gut, wenn da was umgewandelt wird, jetzt gerade wieder in der momentanen Zeit in Gewerbe, weil das mehr einträgt, dann können wir da einen Riegel vorschieben. Aber allein mit diesen Instrumenten kann man dieses riesen Gap des Bodenpreises halt nicht einfangen. 30 Prozent geht in den Bodenpreis und der Rest ist dann die Entwicklung der Flächen. Wir sind mittlerweile bei 60, 70 Prozent Bodenpreis und 30 Prozent Rest.
Ja, und das ist schon dramatisch 60, 70 Prozent. Aber jetzt haben wir ja in Hamburg oben gehört. Der Typ kauft ein Grundstück plus noch 600.000 Euro für das alte Gebäude. Und damit ist er ja insgesamt dann schon, also Grundstück 2000 Quadratmeter in Hamburg sind wahrscheinlich nochmal 500.000 oder so. Dann ist er schon jenseits von 60, 70 Prozent, wenn er danach sein Haus überhaupt erstmal anfängt zu bauen. Und das ist aber ein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Und sie sagt aber, wir haben schon die ein oder andere juristische Möglichkeiten. Also wir dürfen Zweckentfremdungen verbieten. Wenn da Wohnhäuser waren, dann müssen das Wohnhäuser bleiben und dürfen auch nicht weniger werden. Also Teilungen sind unterbunden oder können unterbunden werden. Es kann jetzt nicht einfach jemand kommen und sagen, ich verkaufe mein eines Grundstück an zehn verschiedene Leute und kann sie dann auch nicht ab, sondern das muss dann am Stück bleiben. Ein großes Ding war ja auch der Mietendeckel, mit dem man es einfangen kann. Also in der Berliner Variante hat allerdings auch mit dem einen oder anderen Effekt zu tun gehabt.
Der Berliner Mietendeckel wurde vom Bundesverfassungsgericht kassiert. Begründung die Gesetzgebungsbefugnis liege beim Bund. Für Mieter hatte er tatsächlich auch Schattenseiten. Nach einer Studie des Deutschen Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung sanken die Mieten zwar um etwa 11 Prozent. Gleichzeitig hat sich aber die Zahl der annoncierten Mietwohnungen in Berlin mehr als halbiert. Der Deckel half also nur denen, die eine Wohnung hatten.
Also dieser Mietminderungsding, dass es dann allerdings 57 Prozent wieder Mietwohnungen gab, weil ja die Immobilienpreise trotzdem oben blieben und man sich dachte, na bevor ich jetzt, weil jemand auszieht oder so, neu vermiete für weniger Geld, lass ich es lieber zwei Jahre leer stehen und lege den ausgefallenen Mietpreis dann einfach auf den Kaufpreis drauf, den jemand bezahlt, weil die Käufer gab es ja. Leute wollten ja in Berlin leben und dann wussten, ja Miete klappt jetzt nicht mehr, also gehen wir in den Kauf oder also dann über Kredit und so weiter. Ist jetzt also auch nicht so die Lösung gewesen, allerdings wurde das ja von der Berliner Politik auch immer so als Atempause thematisiert, dass man so fünf Jahre macht. Marcel Fratscher sieht jedenfalls auch in dem weiteren Punkt, dass man ja enteignen könnte, was sie da jetzt machen, auch nicht die durchschlagende Lösung.
Der Ökonom glaubt nicht, dass das Land Berlin die Wohnungen wieder zurückkaufen sollte.
Eine Enteignung von Wohnungsbaukonzernen wie Vonovia oder Deutsche Wohnen wäre kontraproduktiv. Denn es würde dazu führen, dass der Staat für relativ wenige Wohnungen diese Konzerne relativ viel Geld geben müsste. Also sprich alle Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler müssten dafür zahlen. Aber den Nutzen hätten am Ende nur ganz, ganz wenige, nämlich die, die das Glück haben, dann in diese Wohnung einziehen zu können, zu subventionierten Mieten. Also Enteignung der Wohnungsbaukonzerne ist nicht die Lösung, sondern hier braucht es andere Konzepte, kluge Regulierung und letztlich der Schlüssel langfristig ist Bauen, Bauen, Bauen. Also das Angebot ausweichen.
Das glaube ich ja nicht ganz. Also, denn es ist ja so, natürlich profitieren jetzt erstmal die, die in den Wohnungen von Bonovia wohnen, davon, wenn das gekauft wird. Allerdings wissen wir ja, dass Mieter nicht ewig irgendwo wohnen, sondern generell sind damit einfach wieder Wohnungen vorhanden, die dem Staat gehören und die Konzerne haben keinen Zugriff mehr darauf. Das heißt, auch hier würde sich der Wohnungsmarkt entspannen, was erstmal allen zugute kommt. Und dann ist das wie immer bei irgendwelchen Subventionen oder Förderungen oder wie auch immer, dass es natürlich erstmal Leute besonders positiv trifft und andere dann nicht erreicht. Ich glaube aber, dass man auf zwei Ebenen eigentlich da argumentieren muss. Das eine ist selbstverständlich, dass damit nicht alles getan ist, dass es aber erstmal so einen Anstoß gibt, für den Staat, nicht es wieder so kommen zu lassen, dass man teuer zurückkauft. Denn man hat das ja mal billig veräußert. Das ist ja verrückt, was da bezahlt wurde. Da können wir uns ja alle ein paar Wohnungen kaufen. Da waren ja Wohnungen, die für 8.000 Euro verkauft wurden. Unglaublich. Und zwar in den Nuller Jahren. Also wir reden jetzt nicht von den 50ern oder so. Also in den Nuller Jahren hat man Wohnungen für 8 oder 15.000 Euro verkauft. Da würde man ja sofort sagen, ja, gib mir zwei, dann hab ich mal was. Also total irre. Das heißt, dass man diesen Fehler nicht macht, würde ich sagen, ist dieses Zurückkaufen richtig? Und damit auch diesen Konzernen das Geschäftsmodell hier kaputt machen, wenngleich ich auch sagen würde, dass es auf so einer anderen Ebene noch wichtig ist. Ich glaube, wir müssen diesen enteignen Begriff tatsächlich ganz positiv besetzen. Und als Gramsci-Anhänger würde ich sagen, es passiert da auch hegomonial jetzt gerade etwas, dass dieser Begriff mal wieder ausgesprochen wird. Dass sich natürlich da so Leute, man muss ja eigentlich sagen Funktionäre, wie Giffey von der SPD, da gerade so schreuen und so. Zeigt ja auch was deutlich, dass mittlerweile ja der Unionsmann in Berlin eher noch sagt, gut, wir müssen dann in einem demokratischen System auf so ein Votum auch reagieren und Giffey gleich eine rote Linie zieht. Das zeigt ja was. Also ich würde sagen, das ist eine sehr wichtige Initiative, mit der so einen Anstoß gegeben kann. Das wird nicht alle Probleme lösen. Aber eigentlich kann man da mal sehr gut zeigen, es muss nicht immer das Kapital die Macht haben.
Genau, das ist ja relativ neu, dass wir das einfach dem BGB, also dem Mietvertrag sind zwei Privatpersonen, die es miteinander regeln. Und es war ja mal anders. Mietrecht, es gibt ja auch Wohnungswesen und so. Da hat halt der Bund nach dem Krieg einfach gesagt, wir machen das jetzt mal so und so. Dann wurde ja auch zugeordnet. Das lässt sich dabei Peter Weber gut nachlesen in diesem Text, in dem er den Berliner Mietendeckel sozusagen juristisch vorbereitet, in der Juristenzeitung. Wie das so war nach dem Krieg, dass er eben nicht da mag. Und hier kriegen wir auch mal eine kurzen historische Erklärung. Marcel Fratscher hat ja eben schon gesagt, es braucht kluge Strategien. Und es gibt ja viele Möglichkeiten. Also wir haben noch nicht über Genossenschaften und so weiter gesprochen. Ganz viele Eigentumsregulierungen und so, die da gut funktionieren. Hier mal einen historischen Vergleich.
Die Genossenschaften blühen wieder auf. 1926 sind es schon über 3900. Fast dreimal so viele wie vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg. Gemeinnützige Wohnungsbaugesellschaften entstehen. 1926 tragen sie mit staatlicher Hilfe fast 60 Prozent des gesamten Wohnungsbauvolumens in Deutschland. Günstige Mietwohnungen. Zweiter Weltkrieg. In den deutschen Städten 50 Prozent der Wohnfläche in Trümmern. Rund 12 Millionen Vertriebene und Flüchtlinge kommen. 1950 fielen in der Bundesrepublik mindestens 4, 8 Millionen Wohnungen. Wieder greift der Staat ein und fördert günstige Mietwohnungen. Das neue Instrument? Sozialwohnungen. Mehr Geld, mehr Wohnungen, aber auch mehr Vorschriften. Allein 1950 entstehen so 319.000 Wohnungen. Langsam gehen die Zahlen zurück. 1988 sind es nur noch 23.000. Der Bedarf ist aus Sicht der Politik gedeckt. 2001 gibt es so gut wie keine Förderung mehr für den sozialen Wohnungsbau. Stattdessen werden Sozialwohnungen in ganz normale Wohnungen umgewandelt. Über eine Million Sozialwohnungen sind so in den letzten 10 Jahren auf dem freien Markt gelandet.
Also wir haben Genossenschaften, Wohnungswesen nach dem Krieg, bis dann irgendwann festgestellt wird, ja gut läuft, politischer Bedarf ist sozusagen nicht mehr da, jetzt zu machen, war ja auch tatsächlich so. Dann sagt der Staat, da wo wir es noch machen müssen, machen wir Sozialwohnungen. Dann stellt man vor 20 Jahren fest, bedarf es nicht mehr da, diese Urbanisierungswelle hat noch nicht begonnen und so. Und dann zieht man sich da so ganz allmählich völlig raus. Und jetzt kriegt man aber nicht wieder den Weg zurück, obwohl wir über die Preise ja gesehen haben, wir müssen aber den Weg zurückfinden. Also hier muss wieder politisch reguliert werden, gerade wenn wir von oben diesen Druck über Vermögenswertinflation haben. Und entsprechend äußert sich hier auch Jürgen Engelbert, das ist der Chef des Bundesverbands der deutschen Immobilienwirtschaft. Da wurde hier von Dreisat Mako mal zum Gespräch gebeten und seine erste Antwort hier auf die ganz allgemeine Frage ist, wirklich viel sagen.
Am Frankfurter Flughafen besuche ich einen der größten Lobbyverbände der deutschen Immobilienwirtschaft. Denn ich will wissen, was sagt die Branche zur Spekulation am Bodenmarkt? Grundstücke steigen im Wert, wenn sie Anschluss an Bus und Bahn bekommen oder etwa eine Schule in der Nähe gebaut wird. Das zahlt der Steuerzahler. Die Wertsteigerung aber behält der Grundstückseigner. Es könnten 50.000 Wohnungen mehr gebaut werden, es liegen Genehmigungen vor, es wird nicht gebaut. Vermutlich werden Investoren auf bessere Preise beim Bauland warten. Ist es nicht ein ökonomischer Fehlanreiz, mit Bauland spekulieren zu können?
Ja, wir leben nun mal in einer Marktwirtschaft. So und wir können jetzt nicht sagen, wir gehen jetzt total in einen Sozialismus zurück und dann befehlen wir, hier muss gebaut werden.
Ja, ja, total in den Sozialismus zurück, also sehr schön. Aber so ähnlich hat ja auch Wolfram Eilenberger damals, als er bei Tilo war, argumentiert, die er mit Deutsche wohnen enteignen. Da hatte er dann gleich Stalin und Mao herangezogen, wo dann Leute noch das Besteck enteignet bekamen.
Wir leben nun mal in einer Marktwirtschaft.
In einer Marktwirtschaft, der sagt wenigstens nicht noch das Wort sozial davor.
Wir leben nun mal in einer Marktwirtschaft. Genau, also das ist einfach gesetzt und klar, dieser Verband profitiert natürlich erheblich davon, er kriegt auch Mitgliederbeiträge und so. Und die schwimmen ja jetzt nun alle im Geld. Könnte man nicht trotzdem das ein oder andere wieder zurück in die öffentliche Hand legen, sei es Regulierung, sei es, dass die selber auftritt als Marktteilnehmer und so weiter, haben wir ja in München gesehen, kommunale Mietpreisbremse, zumindest bei den städtischen Eigentumern.
Verdient so viel Geld und trägt so ein schlechtes Hemd.
Das auch, das ist ja.
Ich verrate jetzt die Marke nicht, aber ich kann sagen, dass das kein Hemd ist, das ist kein.
Wir können ja heute am Flughafen unser Schnitzel essen, dann können wir ihn kurz rausklingeln. Also Engelbert zur Frage, welche Rolle könnte der Staat denn jetzt hier einnehmen?
Na ja, für preisgünstiges Bauen und Wohnen müssen wir zunächst mal dahin kommen, dass wir letztendlich auch mehr bauen können, auch mehr einfacher bauen können. Und das wird im Moment behindert durch eine extreme Überbürokratisierung in den Behörden. Sehen Sie, wir haben 16 Bundesländer, wir haben 16 unterschiedliche Bauverordnungen, die sich gegenseitig teilweise widersprechen. Das sind alles Probleme, die es unheimlich schwer machen.
Wir ändern diese Bürokratie in Deutschland sicherlich nicht von heute auf morgen. Aber was wäre denn so eine Kernforderung Ihrer Seite?
Eine Kernforderung ist dann sicherlich die Digitalisierung der Behörden. Das ist einfach, wenn ich das auch mal sehe, wenn Projekte in der öffentlichen Hand liegen, dann ist es immer sehr, sehr problematisch. Wir können zum Beispiel keine Flughäfen bauen, wir können keine Bahnhöfe bauen, wir können keine Brücken bauen, wir können keine Opern bauen. Alles, was in der öffentlichen Hand liegt, fährt eigentlich vor die Wand. Und das ist bei solchen Projektentwicklungen, bei Flächennutzungsplanen, die liegen auch alle in der öffentlichen Hand. Die kann man da natürlich nicht rausnehmen, aber da müssen wir daran arbeiten, dass das besser wird. Und da müssen wir Druck auf die Politik ausüben, die es dann wieder in die einzelnen Verwaltungen bringt.
Das heißt jetzt aber übersetzt, die Politik soll jetzt schleunigst dafür sorgen, dass diese Bodenspekulation sich eher lohnt. Und jetzt haben wir hier Baufläche, jetzt baut uns da mal bitte die ECE-Trasse hin und das Opernhaus und was weiß ich noch alles. Und wenn es dann richtig gut ist, also wenn das Netz dann bereitet ist, dann ziehen wir unsere Häuser dort hoch und sagen dann, naja, aber in dieser Gegend wollen wir ja jetzt nun auch die Gutverdienenden haben, deswegen machen wir schöne Luxuswohnungen daraus. Das ist die Argumentation.
Im Grunde fragt sie ihn, wo ist denn jetzt der Spielraum für den Staat noch einzugreifen? Er sagt, der hat gar keine, aber wir könnten gerne noch den einen oder anderen Vorschlag unterbreiten, wo wir noch so. Also er dreht das einfach rum.
Vielleicht kann man da auch noch schöne PPPs daraus machen.
Ja, sowieso. Private, wie heißt es? Ja, also das bietet sich ja sowieso immer an. Ich glaube auch, den kommt das wie gerufen, dass die ganzen Großprojekte des Staates nicht funktionieren. Der Staat ist selber schuld, das so zu machen.
Und Digitalisierung daran.
Digitalisierung.
Also das sagt ja auch Laschet immer, wenn er irgendwie Gefahr wird, die Digitalisierung vorantreiben. Man weiß halt, was sie für Abkommen haben mit Telekom und Co, wo es nicht vorangeht.
Genau, das ist so ein großes Wunschdenken, das immer noch drin ist. Aber er möchte im Grunde, dass der Staat weiterhin so inkompetent ist, wie jetzt und sich dann nicht einmischt. Jetzt mischt sich der Staat aber ein. Und hier gibt es auf kommunaler Ebene, die sind leider im Bundestagswahlkampf überhaupt, also Wohnen ist ja so kein Thema, ne? Nee. Aber auch diese kommunalen Lösungen, die wir haben, sind so wenig Thema, dass wir eigentlich die Bundestagswahl ständig überschätzen und die Kommunalwahlen, die wir haben, ständig unterschätzen. Und jetzt wird hier mal von ZDF Wiesow nach Münster geblickt, bevor dann Dreisatt Makro nach Ulm blickt. Und das ist wirklich spektakulär. Also fangen wir mal an bei Münster. Boden wird in Münster nicht mehr höchstbietend verkauft.
Oft bekommt der Bauträger das Baugrundstück, der am meisten zahlt. In Münster nicht. Gemessen an der Einwohnerzahl werden hier besonders viele, soziale Wohnungen gebaut. Grund, das Konzept der sozial gerechten Bodennutzung. Danach müssen beim Bau von Mietwohnungen auf städtischen Grundstücken 60% und bei privaten Baulandentwicklungen 30% Sozialwohnungen geschaffen werden. Außerdem entzieht die Stadt einen Teil des Baulands dem Zugriff von Investoren. Denn Baugenehmigungen gibt es nur noch, wenn die Hälfte der Fläche an die Stadt verkauft wird.
Sozialgerechte Bodennutzung. Wenn der Staat 60% Sozialwohnungen baut, wenn das privat gebaut wird, 30%. Die haben sich ja schon immer mal wieder darüber gewundert, das hat Olaf Scholz auch schon mal eingestanden in so Bürgergesprächen. Die machen jetzt mal diese Townhalls. Wir haben glaube ich auch schon Clips davon geguckt. Wenn man den Bedarf an Sozialwohnungen erhebt, und den kann man ja ermitteln über, wird eigentlich ein Wohngeldantrag bewilligt oder nicht, wären mehr als die Hälfte der deutschen Haushalte Wohngeld berechtigt. Wohngeld ist nur so ein Thema, das ist so ein bisschen tabumäßig, weil wenn das alles in Anspruch genommen wird, dann ist wirklich Danida mit dem deutschen Bundeshaushalt oder wo auch immer das herbezahlt wird. Aber diese 30 Prozent sind eigentlich zu niedrig. Und man könnte durchaus, finde ich, sagen, so wie die Grünen jetzt sagen, es gibt einfach Geld für Kinder, sie müssen nur geboren werden, das reicht aus, da müssen keine Anträge gestellt werden, könnte man ja einfach sagen, sie sind jetzt volljährig, wie sieht ihr Einkommen aus und wie wohnen sie, müssen wir hier als Staat unterstützen oder nicht? Also dass man sozusagen angebotsweise das System umbaut und sagt, wir haben als Staat auf jeden Fall was davon, wenn du ein bisschen mit dem Kopf frei wohnst, auch wenn es uns was kostet, Hauptsache, du stehst uns zur Verfügung, weil alternativ müssen wir halt wirklich 400.000 Menschen importieren, um hier den Arbeitsmarkt am Laufen zu halten.
Und der Staat kann ja da auch unternehmerisch denken, also ich hab das eben gesagt, mit Konzernen wie vielleicht BASF oder so, ich weiß es nicht, im Einzelnen, denkt ja so und sagt, wir brauchen da gute Leute und deswegen sorgen wir auch mal dafür, dass die eine gute Wohnung bekommen. Und so kann man das jetzt als Staat selbstverständlich auch machen. Und da ist das ja eigentlich von Münster hier ein ganz guter Ansatz, auch zu sagen, wenn also Bauland verkauft wird oder wenn was zu Bauland gemacht wird. Und da sind ja die Kommunen auch die, die das ausweisen. Also die Kommunen können ja auch verweigern, also haben da eine ganz große Macht, dass man dann sagt, da müssen aber 50 Prozent an die Stadt gehen und die verfügt wiederum darüber. Das ist ja eine ganz, ganz schlichte Regelung eigentlich, aber diese würde jetzt auf Bundesebene richtig was bewegen.
Genau. Und da gibt es ja auch noch die Sonderklausel, du hast ja eben schon gesagt, im Bauland verkaufen oder im Bauland umwandeln. Man kann ja im Bauland umwandeln, ohne zu verkaufen, mit der in Frankfurt ganz viel gemacht, dass man gar keinen Grund und Boden mehr erwirbt, sondern nur noch hundertjährige Nutzungsrechte über Erbpacht und so weiter. Und ich glaube, hier könnte man so weit kombinieren, dass man sagt, wir haben als Stadt einen Plan entworfen und der ist auch demokratisch legitimiert, also sozusagen zur Anschauung lagerbereit und wurde mehrheitlich für gut befunden. Und dann bewirbt man sich auf die Flächen, aber dann ist schon klar, was auf denen geschieht. Also dann kann man noch seine Rendite ausrechnen, die ist dann aber verbunden mit der Arbeit, mit der Planung und so weiter. Und das darf man nicht unterschätzen. Also so Wohnhäuser planen, so bauen, das ist alles nicht ohne, gerade jetzt wo keine Handwerker da sind und wenn sie da sind, alle im Erftal gebraucht werden und so. Also das ist ja unternehmerisch auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, das privatwirtschaftlich zu machen, aber die Zielsetzung kann man ja einfach staatlich machen. Und das ist hier in Ulm in einem Ausmaß jetzt gemacht worden, dass es einem wirklich die Füße auszieht. Wir lassen uns mal kurz vorstellen, was Ulm überhaupt für eine Stadt ist.
Wir sind in Ulm, Ulm an der Donau. Ulm hat nicht nur den höchsten Kirchturm der Welt. In Ulm gibt es mehr Arbeitsplätze als Einwohner und Einwohnerinnen. Es ist die Boomregion hier im Südwesten zwischen München und Stuttgart. Und klar, bauen und wohnen ist auch hier nicht gerade billig. Aber in Ulm dreht sich die Preispirale bei Weitem nicht so heftig wie in anderen Städten. Was läuft in Ulm besser?
Es gibt ein paar Städte. Frankfurt ist auch so eine Düsseldorf. Da gibt es mehr Arbeitsplätze als Einwohner. Da pendelt man richtig rein. Pendeln findet man scheiße. Also überlegt man sich irgendwann dann doch mal, sollte ich mir nicht und so. Auch wenn nur am Rande, aber in der Stadt mal was. Also der Binnenmigrationsdruck in die Stadt ist auf jeden Fall gegeben. Und trotzdem, obwohl es in allen der Städte, wo das so ist, so explodiert in den Preisen, ist das in Ulm wie sie sagten nicht so. Und das wurde da über ein ganz einfaches Verfahren gemacht. Man hat einfach den Markt ausgeschaltet. Also es gibt einfach keinen Verkäufer Käufer Matching mehr, sondern es steht immer die Stadt dazwischen.
Die Stadt wächst. Prognosen zufolge kommen jedes Jahr 900 Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner hinzu. Hier an den Stadträndern schafft Ulm deshalb zusätzlichen Wohnraum. In Neubaugebieten steht Zwischenkäufer und Verkäufer eines Grundstücks immer die Stadt, die den Preis reguliert. So versucht Ulm, sich vom deutschlandweiten Trend abzukoppeln.
Man muss ja gar nicht Marktpreise nehmen wie in Hamburg. Dass man einfach sagt, da ist halt so und so viel, weil es das Höchstbieterverfahren am höchsten bietet und dann ist es halt am Ende doch mal Blackrock oder so. Sondern man kann ja einfach sagen, wir haben ja Datenerhebungen. Was weiß ich, Mietspiegel. Der Streiter da in München sagt in der Sendung auch, der Mietspiegel ist für uns total unaussagekräftig, weil der nimmt ja nur die letzten vier Jahre Neuvermietung und sagt dann, das ist jetzt der Mietspiegel. Und die Oma, die seit 30 Jahren billig in München lebt, die ist da gar nicht drin in dieser Kalkulation. Die ist dann einfach raus. Und entsprechend sind die Preise dann einfach grundsätzlich auf einem hohen Niveau. Aber da kann man ja einfach sagen, wir haben ja Grund und Boden, es ist eine attraktive Stadt. Preise werden vergeben nach und dann, was weiß ich, Distanz zum Zentrum oder so was. Nächste Fußläufigkeit, irgendwie die 15 Minuten Stadt wird dann kalkuliert. Und dann heißt es halt ja, wenn du hier kaufen willst, kostet es so viel, 10 Minuten Fußweg mehr, kosten halt mehr. Also das kann man ja alles regeln. Und dann hat man in Ulm einfach eine Regelung gefunden und hat gesagt, wenn ihr verkaufen wollt, steht der Preis schon fest und der Käufer auch, dann ist es die Stadt. Also du kannst ja nicht an eine Privatperson verkaufen, sondern immer nur an die öffentliche Hand. Und kaufen kannst du dann eben auch immer nur von öffentlichen Hand. Und dann wird nicht nach Höchstbieter verfahren, sondern dann wird halt einfach gesagt, gibt es ja in der Frankfurter Umgebung auch, aus Bach und so, gesagt, wenn du kaufst, musst du es selber nutzen. Und wenn dir das aus irgendeinem Grund nicht gelingt, darfst du zehn Jahre nicht verkaufen. Also das ist dein Risiko. Wenn du hier große Familien, da gibt es so einen Fall, den ich kenne, da hat sich so eine Familie ein richtig großes Haus gebaut, wollte mit drei Generationen einziehen, dann haben sich die zerstritten, jetzt steht das einfach leer. Weil die Stadt sagt, wir können jetzt hier keine Ausnahme machen, denn das ist einfach so, ist es halt. Und dann steht dann auch mal ein Haus leer, aber dafür ist halt bei dem Rest geklärt. Ja, das kann wirklich nur zum Eigenbedarf genutzt werden. Und in Ulm ist das wahrscheinlich, einfach auf einen Typ zurückzugehen. Ulrich Solltner, der war 30 Jahre lang im Liegenschaftsamt. Und dann hat der Bürgermeister ihn angerufen und hat gesagt, hör mal zu, gehst doch in drei Jahren in deine Pension. Wohl verdient, aber ich brauch dich ja noch mal ein paar Jahre für den Job. Meine Idee ist, das so und so zu machen. Und dann hat er sich so ein Team, also wir hören jetzt jemanden, der direkt im Bürgermeisterbüro arbeitet und dieses ganze Ding hier organisiert.
Wie lautet denn das Erfolgsrezept von diesem Ulmer Modell?
Das Rezept ist eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig. Wir kaufen auf Vorratsflächen auf und entwickeln unsere Baugebiete selber, nicht nur im Wohnen, auch fürs Gewalbe. Und wenn wir die Flächen beieinander haben, gibt es einen Bebauungsplan und dann gibt es Bauplätze.
Hier entscheidet der Gemeinderat über die Bauplätze. Ist das so eine Art baupolitischer Schwabensozialismus, den Sie hier machen?
Nein, wir nehmen einfach unsere Aufgaben wahr. Nach Artikel 28 des Grundgesetzes sind die Gemeinden für alle Aufgaben zuständig. Und da gehört natürlich auch dazu, für Gewalbe und Wohnen Gebiete auszuweisen und zu realisieren. Im Zuge der Planungshoheit gibt es dann bei uns Baurecht, aber halt dann, wenn die Stadt alle Grundstücke hat, das bedeutet, dass der Gemeinderat natürlich die Verkaufspreise festsetzt, sagt, wann verkauft wird und an wen und sagt auch, in welchen Perspektiven weitere Gebiete entwickelt wurden.
Sehr schön solide argumentiert, lässt sich gar nicht auf diese Sozialismusgeschichte ein, sondern sagt, das ist eigentlich unsere Aufgabe, womit er natürlich auch sagt, wieso nehmen eigentlich diese ganzen anderen Kommunen ihre Aufgaben nicht wahr?
Ja, und das ist doch eigentlich Wahnsinn, dass wir auf der einen Seite eine Diskussion haben. In Berlin klappt nicht mal der Berliner Mietendeckel, der gar nicht so invasiv ist. Der toucht ja keine Eigentumsrechte an oder so, sondern der schöpft einfach nur Rendite ab, aber greift in Eigentumsverhältnisse gar nicht ein. Und hier in Ulm sagt der Gemeinderat, wir sind jetzt Eigentümer der ganzen Stadt. Also sobald hier ein Verkauf stattfindet, sind wir der nächste Eigentümer. Also wenn man es auf die Spitze treibt, kann man natürlich sagen, die teilen Baugrund zu wie in der DDR Trappis zugewiesen worden. Da gibt es halt eine Liste und da muss man sich bewerben. Und da ist glaube ich ganz wichtig, super wichtig, dass der Gemeinderat ein demokratisches Parlament ist, das man halt wählt, aber wenn hier Gemeinderatswahlen sind, geht es halt auch um wirklich was. Also da muss man sich überlegen, bei der nächsten Gemeinderatswahl will man jetzt dieses System weiter oder nicht. So, und dann müssen die Kräfteverhältnisse dann mal geklärt werden. Also in der Ansicht ist das so invasiv, dass man sich wundert, warum das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Berlin sagt, also das könnt ihr nicht machen, denn dafür ist der Bund zuständig, während die hier in Ulm einfach sagen, ne, das ist hier kommunales Recht, wir machen alles in Ulm.
Das wertet diese demokratischen Strukturen mal auf. Wir haben ja hier schon über diese komischen Bürgerräte gesprochen, die einfach nur so ein bisschen, ja, Ringelpiz mit anfassen sind, damit Leute ein bisschen was zu tun haben. Aber hier wird richtig eingegriffen und damit bekommen auch diese Wahlen Relevanz. Denn, seien wir mal ehrlich, die meisten Leute wählen auf kommunaler Ebene eher so nach dem Mantra, wen will ich einfach nicht mehr im Lokalplättchen sehen, dem ich morgens dann ankrönste.
Wenn man überhaupt jemanden sieht, ja.
Und dann sagt man, ne, den jetzt nicht mehr, den anderen halt. Aber das ist dann etwas, womit das extrem aufgewertet wird.
Ja, und wir haben eben hier ein Gemeinderat, der sozusagen die kluge Politik macht, die erforderlich ist, wenn ansonsten MMT stattfindet. Also wenn einfach zu viel Geld da ist. Wenn die EZB 1, 5 Billionen in den Markt pumpt, muss am änderen Ende der Gemeinderat so handeln, damit die Vermögenspreisinflation nicht durchschlägt auf das normale Leben.
Genau, auf das Existenzieren. Ich meine, wenn die Leute sagen, wie das ja auch nach Corona, jetzt nach der ersten Welle und der zweiten Welle der Fall war, ich bin so reich geworden, ich kaufe mir jetzt ganz viele Luxusuhren. Und das ist ja tatsächlich zu beobachten gewesen. Ich hatte das sehr erzählt von Düsseldorf, dass das Schaufenster halbleer sind. Dann sollen die das ja machen. Also ich finde, da muss der Staat jetzt nicht eingreifen, wenn Leute so verrückt sind und sagen, ich kaufe jetzt für 80.000 Euro eine Uhr, bitte schön.
Genau, aber hier muss man da eingreifen, denn das sind Nutzwerte und die müssen da entsprechend verteilt werden. Boris Palmer, nebenan in Tübingen, hat es auch mit schwäbischem Sozialismus versucht, allerdings ein bisschen halbherzig.
Es geht um solche unbebauten Bauplätze wie hier im Tübinger Stadtteil Lustnau. Rund 500 dieser Baulücken hat Palma 2019 in einem ersten Schritt identifiziert. Potenzial für Wohnraum für rund 2000 Menschen darin gesehen. Palma schreibt damals einen Brief mit seinen Forderungen an die Grundstücksbesitzer. Ulrich Latus ist einer von ihnen.
Das ist ein Grundstück, das ich geerbt habe von meinen Eltern, meine Eltern auch schon vom Großvater. Und jetzt wartet es darauf, bis ich es vielleicht meinen Kindern weitergebe, wenn nicht.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, der Großvater von ihm hat es den Eltern dann an ihn und er überlegt jetzt, ob es dann vielleicht seine Kinder gibt. Also die sind einfach Jahrhunderte.
Und die Kinder können aber auch erst wahrscheinlich dann in 10, 15 Jahren sagen, ob sie wirklich in Tübingen leben wollen oder ob sie nicht vielleicht längst woanders Fuß gefasst haben.
Nur weil die vor 100 Jahren mal irgendein Eigentumsrecht wahrscheinlich in so einer Saufnacht oder so, je nachdem, wie das damals war im Mittelalter, für 500 Mark oder was.
Selbst nicht benötige.
Ulrich Latus ist in Hirschau verwurzelt, ist auch Ortsvorsteher und hat die Reaktion vieler hier auf den Brief damals mitbekommen.
Eigentlich waren die Leute natürlich irgendwo entsetzt geschockt. Also sie haben ein Eigentum und irgendjemand schreibt ihnen, jetzt musst du mit deinem Eigentum was machen. Wenn du das nicht machst, dann geht das bis zur Zwangsenteignung. Also das ist eigentlich fast einmalig in der Bundesrepublik, dass man ein Grundstückseigentümer so unter Druck setzt.
Was haben wir alles für Autobahnen und so enteignet? Und was ist das für ein Theater? Und an der Reaktion sieht man ja auch, wie sicher sich eigentlich Immobilien-Eigentümer in Deutschland fühlen. Der Bürgermeister schreibt mir einen Brief und will hier irgendwas von mir, hat eine Maise und dann rotten sie sich zusammen. Also rotten im Sinne von, redet man auch mal miteinander und wehrt sich dann dagegen.
Ja, mein Beispiel ist da ja immer wieder Steuern. Also da erleben wir irgendwelche Erhöhungen, bei denen ich überhaupt gar kein Mitspracherecht habe, wo ich auch gar nicht noch mal irgendwas verhandeln kann. Also ich konnte nicht damals sagen, als die Mehrwertsteuer von 16 auf 19 Prozent ging, also das ist mir so ein bisschen viel, da müssen wir noch mal drüber reden. Nee, die bezahle ich ja dann einfach. Oder Krankenkassengebühren, was weiß ich. Also wir haben lauter solche Sachen. Aber hier sagt man so, ja, nee, also das ist ja von den Großeltern noch von vor 100 Jahren.
Das ist altes Vermögen. Das ist ja in Deutschland besonders gesichert. Naja, es gab dann trotzdem in Tübingen ein Baugebot, aber es geht eben schleppend voran, auch wegen Corona.
Insgesamt hat sich rund ein Drittel der Angeschriebenen bereiterklärt, zu bauen oder zu verkaufen. Ein Drittel hat nicht geantwortet oder um Bedenkzeit gebeten. Ein weiteres Drittel lehnte die Bebauung ab. Bei den letzten beiden Gruppen sollten eigentlich längst offizielle Anhörungen im Rathaus starten, die dann in ein Baugebot münden können, bei dessen Missachtung eben Bußgelder oder sogar die Enteignung drohen. Doch wegen Corona und einer Novelle des Baugesetzbuches hohen die Verfahren erst einmal.
Ja, also es ist on track, aber Corona verzögert es natürlich. Jetzt haben wir ja zwei Modelle. In Ulm hat niemand einen Brief bekommen, aber sobald man wirtschaftlich tätig werden möchte mit seinem Grundstück, kommt die Stadt. Und in Tübingen sagt die Stadt selbst dann, wenn es einfach nur ruht, kümmern wir uns drum und mal gucken, wie das da weitergeht. Wenn jetzt Corona ist jetzt vorbei, sind ja hoffentlich alle geimpft da. Wie auch immer. Jetzt interessieren wir uns natürlich. Was sagt der Chef des Bundesverbandes der Immobilienwirtschaft, den wir eben schon gehört haben, Jürgen Engelbert zum Ulmer Modell? Ist das ein Vorbild für Deutschland?
Herr Engelbert in Ulm entscheidet der Gemeinderat über die Bodenpreise. Vieren gilt diese Stadt als Vorzeigebeispiel. Was halten Sie denn von dem Ulmer Modell?
Also ich finde es grundsätzlich nicht schlecht. Aber das Problem dabei ist, um solche Projekte zu realisieren, braucht die Kommune auch Geld. Und in Ulm ist es halt so, die haben ein sehr, sehr hohes Bruttoinlandsprodukt von über 77.000 Euro pro Einwohner. Und das können die meisten Kommunen in Deutschland nicht vorweisen. Daher ist es mit Sicherheit kein Pilotprojekt oder kein Leuchtturmprojekt für Deutschland. Das glaube ich nicht, dass sich so etwas realisieren lässt.
Ja, und das können wir uns natürlich schon leisten. Das könnten sich die Kommunen auch leisten. Und da kann man die MMT auf kommunaler Ebene anwenden. Es war jetzt ganz interessant zu sehen, dass in den Wahlprogrammen von Linke, SPD und Grüne das Thema mal so erkannt wurde, dass es man auch versucht, über eine Schuldenentlastung oder Schuldenschnitt sowas nachzudenken. Aber da sind die eigentlich noch gar nicht mutig genug. Und ich verstehe das auch gar nicht. Warum man da nicht viel stärker das macht, dass man doch eigentlich auf dieser kommunalen Ebene so viel erreichen kann.
Also ja, vor allem das einzige Argument, was er jetzt hier gebracht hat. Die Kommune Ulm hat halt viel Geld, da zu investieren. Das ist natürlich völlig banal, denn die brauchen also die brauchen dafür kein Geld. Die brauchen nur Sicherheiten und die haben sie auf jeden Fall. Denn das Grundstück, das sie erwerben, kriegen sie immer wieder los. Und wenn sie wollen, für einen höheren Preis. Also in der Ansicht haben wir hier gar keine Finanzierungslücke.
Es tut ein bisschen so, als würden sie das kaufen, um dann zu verschenken. Das tun sie ja nicht.
Das muss nur politisch organisiert werden und es lässt sich aber politisch organisieren. Natürlich nicht in Sachsen-Anhalt, aber, und das ist ja das Tolle, da wo der Bedarf da ist, das zu organisieren, da lässt es sich auch finanzieren. Weil eben der Bedarf da ist. Also das ergibt sich sozusagen von alleine. Hier braucht es nur kluge Politik und einen Gemeinderat, der ja diesen Mut dann auch wirklich mal ergreift.
Aber stehen die denn eigentlich nicht so Bürgermeister im Austausch mit anderen Bürgermeistern? Gibt es nicht Bürgermeisterkonferenzen, sowas kann ich mir doch vorstellen. Da muss doch mal, jetzt ist das Modell ja nicht das ganz Neueste vom Neuen, muss doch mal das so durchgesickert sein. Die machen das nicht schlecht. Und ich glaube, Ulm wird ja nicht, also nicht von der Linkspartei und auch nicht von den Grünen regiert.
Ja, es ist nicht weit von Stuttgart und so.
Ich würde fast sagen, die haben die nicht sogar nur CDU-Regierung.
Keine Ahnung, so weit kenne ich mich in Ulm nicht aus. Jedenfalls ist das, das kann jeder selber mal nachschauen, ist das kein linksradikaler Hotspot.
Also da könnte man ja als Bürgermeister sicherlich auch gut vertratet sein zu anderen Bürgermeistern, wo man sagt, also wir haben das eigentlich ganz gut hier so geregelt.
Ja, also Ulm würde ich sagen, ist, wenn man sagt, wir machen es wie Ulm, würde keiner sagen wie Söder. Wir machen es nicht wie in Berlin oder so, sondern das ist einfach Ulm. Ich glaube auch, dass man da weit käme, wenn man sagte, das ist jetzt Vorbildregion. Ich finde es jedenfalls spektakulär und es zeigt mal wieder erstens, wie weit politische Handlungsmöglichkeiten gehen und zweitens, wo vor allem im Gemeinderat. Wer hätte das gedacht? Gemeinderat, denken wir doch, ist so eine Hobbyveranstaltung, wo Menschen, die es wirklich als Hobby machen müssen, denn ich glaube, so richtig durchprofessionalisiert sind die auch nicht, was Gehaltsstrukturen und so weiter angeht.
Nee, das ist immer noch auf einer freiwilligen Ebene.
Also in deren Sicht, da ist doch einiges möglich in Deutschland. In deren Sicht Vorbild Ulm. Fragt mal eure Freunde, was sie von dem Vorbild, von dem Ulmer Modell halten und wenn sie sagen, was ist das für, und dann erklärt das ihnen einfach.
Ja, ja, jetzt wird es erotisch. Wir sprechen über Onlyfans. Also wie ist das mit Onlyfans? Onlyfans ist ja diese Plattform, die eigentlich so funktioniert wie unser Salon auf Steady. Richtig. Also Steady ist wie Onlyfans, kann man sagen. Nur machen wir andere Inhalte. Wer den Salon abonniert hat, weiß das. Wir ziehen uns nicht aus, sondern wir sprechen über Gelesenes. Und bei Onlyfans könnte, also wir könnten theoretisch auch den Salon auf Onlyfans verfrachten. Onlyfans würde sich sehr freuen, denn Onlyfans möchte weiterhin Creator haben, aber nicht mehr jene, die Porno-Inhalte machen. So war zumindest die erste Meldung. Inzwischen ist man da wieder zurückgerudert. Auf Onlyfans wird vorwiegend erotischer Content angeboten. Das heißt nackt Fotos, Videos, pornografische Inhalte, soft-erotische Inhalte, was auch immer. Und jetzt sollte es so ein Pornband geben, das heißt man abonniert Onlyfans nicht als Onlyfans, wie man auch Steady nicht als Steady abonniert, sondern den einen Creator, den man sehen möchte, zahlt vier Euro oder vier Dollar neunzig und kann dann entsprechend das Exklusivmaterial sehen. Was es aber dann noch zusätzlich gibt, das ist der Unterschied jetzt zum Salon zum Beispiel, ist, dass man dann noch mal mit dem Creator interagieren kann und direkt anfragen kann, kannst du mal bitte, soll ich ein Foto machen, ich zahle dafür 500 Euro oder so. Wir werden gleich mal ganz kurz eine deutsche Creatorin hören, Bonnie Lang, wer sich dafür mehr interessiert sollte, da auch beim OMR Podcast sich das mal anhören, da war sie nämlich, glaube ich, mal zu Gast. Sie erzählt dann, dass sie keine pornografischen Inhalte macht, sondern nackt Inhalte, erotische Inhalte macht und dass sie da bis zu 500, 800 Euro für ein Foto nehmen kann, wenn sie dann auf Sonderwunsch was anfertigt.
Genau, Onlyfans ist wirklich eine spektakuläre Sache. Da wir ja im Social Media Bereich schon seit langem, eigentlich seit an Beginn, so eine Diskussion haben, darf man da, inwieweit darf man da Frauen nackt zeigen, beim Stillen, sonst irgendwie. Also wir hatten so ganz prüde amerikanische Vorstellungen, die plötzlich so in die Welt hinaus gedingst wurden und trotzdem parallel dazu immer so eine Hypersexualisierung von allem. Aber halt immer so implizit. So und dann kam Onlyfans und sagte, wir machen ein Social Network, in dem ihr alles zeigen dürft. Es muss halt nur sozusagen ausgehandelt werden. Also zum einen ja, Preisschild, das fragen sich ja eh viele, wie verdient man als Influencer gelten, aber bei Onlyfans ist das ganz einfach zu machen. Da muss man nämlich nicht super Reichweite spielen, sondern man hat einfach wie bei uns im Salon so 2000 Leute, denen das halt was wert ist und dann ergibt sich das schon und dann kann man das alles organisieren. Also man muss nicht mega Reichweite, aber es ist eben eine andere Beziehung zwischen Publikum und Konsument und die Plattform spielt noch eine besondere Rolle, denn während wir ja gerade diskutieren, dass uns Facebook und Twitter und YouTube im Stich lassen, selbst bei Präsidentenwahlen und so weiter, war bei Onlyfans immer klar, da gibt es aber dann keine Vergewaltigung und da wird niemand gezwungen und da kümmert sich auch Onlyfans als Plattform darum, dass es allen Beteiligten gut geht und wenn man da was meldet hinsichtlich guckt euch das mal an, dann haben die das sich auch wirklich mal angeschaut, sodass man auch denjenigen, die wissen, dass in den öffentlich einsehbaren Pronographien, also in den ganzen werbefinanzierten Plattformen, wie Benchpornos sind, oder irgendwelche heimlich gefilmten Sachen von Duschentoiletten und so weiter. Genau, so Überwachungskameras, irgendwas und so. Und da konnte man sich relativ sicher sein, dass man bei Onlyfans nur Sachen gezeigt bekommt, die diejenigen, die das anbieten, auch wirklich zeigen wollen, im Einverständnis mit dem, dass man dafür Geld bezahlt und die dann auch darüber finanziert werden. Und es war in der Maßgabe auch eins der wenigen, wenn nicht das einzige soziale Netzwerk, das tatsächlich seine Creator, im Sinne der Creator, bezahlt hat. Also im 1 zu 1 Verhältnis, man bietet etwas der Plattform und je nachdem, also je nach eigenem Erfolg, den man hat, um Publikum zu mobilisieren, wurde man dann dafür bezahlt. Und da wurden also recht viele Sachen, bis hin zu Rapid Holes und so bei YouTube und politische Verschwörungstheorien und so weiter. Diese ganze Drangsalierung über Engagementsteigerung, Reichweitenoptimierung und so weiter, konnten relativ gut umgangen werden. Und unter der Hinsicht war das ein bisschen schockierend dann zu hören, wie es da losging. Also was du jetzt thematisierst.
Wir hören mal in den ersten Clip rein, da ist eine Betroffene, die ja betroffen, auch ist davon, was da Onlyfans vorgeschlagen hat. So, das war jetzt jemand, die war vorher Krankenschwester, hat jetzt 200.000 Dollar dort verdient auf der Plattform, hat sich selbstständig gemacht damit und das war also jetzt eine Möglichkeit zur Selbstständigkeit, die sich vorher gar nicht geboten hatte und das hat durch Corona ja enorm zugenommen. Also diese Konzerne ist ja extrem gewachsen, es ist ja ein Familienunternehmen, Stokey heißt der Chef davon und der Vater hat nochmal Geld gegeben und so ist das dann irgendwie aufgebaut worden, also ziemlich klein, aber jetzt wird diese Plattform natürlich immer größer, relevanter und man fragt, muss Onlyfans eigentlich immer nur für Pornografie genutzt werden und man hat ja auch Werte darauf gelegt, nein, es ist ja nicht nur und es stimmt ja auch, dass es da noch ein paar andere Sparten gab wohl, aber jetzt will man, wollte man sich von dem pornografischen lösen? Wenn ich jetzt sage will, wollte man, also man ist zurückgerudert, aber das heißt glaube ich jetzt erstmal nichts, also man ist jetzt mal schlagartig zurückgerudert, weil man erstmal sagte, bis zum ersten Oktober soll das alles befreit sein von Pornoinhalten und Und jetzt hat man gesagt, nein, nein, wir haben uns da nochmal das anders überlegt. Aber jetzt ist ja dieses Damoklass-Schwert erst mal im Raum und das schwegt über den Creatern. Und jetzt hören wir hier nochmal diese Dame. Lucas Shaw ist Journalist und ist hier im Bloomberg Podcast und spricht über Onlyfans und erklärt eigentlich, was die Strategie sein könnte bei der Geschichte und erklärt auch nochmal so ein bisschen, wie das überhaupt ist mit den Leuten, die dabei und die Fans aktiv sind.
Ja, Pornografie und Therapie ist natürlich ganz witzig. Du hast ja vorhin auch schon von dem Psychologen, die dann, wie gestalten wir jetzt eigentlich so ein Verhältnis zu? Und das war ja, also Sexarbeit ist ja ausgefallen durch die Pandemie. Die Gelegenheiten wurden alle gestrichen, so wie Gastronomie allgemein und so. Und jetzt war natürlich die Frage, wie können die weiter arbeiten? Und wir haben ja auch schon gehört, dass soziale Netzwerke oder Postcasting so sehr viel Intimität bedeutet, die es ansonsten so nicht gibt, also so persönliche Beziehung. Und sei es nur durch, keine Ahnung, man kann es sich ja, wenn man sich zeitlich aufschlüsselt, Menschen, die 10 Minuten am Tag bei irgendwelchen Onlyfans Accounts sind, die bezahlen ja dann auch einzeln dafür, was weiß ich, 10 Euro im Monat. Also ist es denen auch ein bisschen was wert, ist dann schon allein dadurch so eine gehobene, bedeutungsvollere Beziehung, die man da hat. Also geht man da auch hin. Und 10 Minuten am Tag bedeutet ja schon, dass man mehr mit diesenjenigen Menschen verbringt, wenn es auch nur eine einseitig konsumierende Sicht ist, als Gespräch mit der eigenen Mutter oder so. Das ist ja mal relativ zügig, sind ja solche Beziehungen dann doch recht intensiv in so einem modernen Leben, wo man ja gar nicht so vielen Menschen über den Weg läuft den ganzen Tag und so.
Wir hören mal weiter. Schnittstellenfunktionen und Zeitregeln als oberste Schicht vor. Darunter ist dann die Schicht der Plattform-Eigentümer. Und dann gibt es aber nochmal diese Infrastrukturdienste, also Appstores, Zahlungsabwickler und und und. Und das ist alles noch darunter. Und sie sagt dann nochmal sehr deutlich, wir wollen nicht, dass Plattform-Unternehmen über ihre Inhalts- und Community-Regeln eine solche Kontrolle über den kulturellen Ausdruck ausüben, und wir wollen nicht, dass Apple über den Appstore eine solche Kontrolle darüber ausübt, wer Zugang zu Märkten hat und zu welchen Diensten und Produkten Menschen Zugang haben. Wir wollen auch nicht, dass Finanzunternehmen zu Schiedsrichtern über Sozialität, Kultur, Sexualität, Sinnstiftung und so weiter werden. Denn es ist natürlich so, wenn die die Richtlinien anpassen, entscheiden eigentlich Investoren darüber, Finanzunternehmen, Finanzdienstleister darüber, was wird jetzt gezeigt. Also das sind natürlich Aushandlungsprozesse, nur interessant ist, dass hier ganz deutlich das Geld jetzt sprechen kann und sagen kann. Also weiß ich nicht, Oralverkehr geht nicht. Das entscheiden wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, Casey Newton, hier auch schon häufig angesprochen, hat bei Karl Zwischer letztens im Podcast auch gemeint, wie wir Präsidenten werden machen, darüber entscheidet vor allem eine Shopping-Mall, also Facebook und so. Und Joshua Schopolsky hat jetzt im Tomorrow-Podcast angemerkt, ja, über die Art und Weise, welchen Sex wir konsumieren, entscheidet jetzt irgendeine Bank einfach, die einfach sagt, nö, das wickele ich nicht ab. Ich bin zwar eigentlich allgemeiner Zahlungsdienstleister und unterwerfe mich da auch so den ein oder anderen Anforderungen, aber hier entscheide ich einfach. Da mischen sich natürlich Institutionen ein. In der analogen Welt würden wir das nie so dulden, aber digital ist das irgendwie jetzt tatsächlich so eingebürgert.
Absolut. Und wir hören jetzt hier eine Dame von Belisa Balls. Das ist eine Plattform, wo Erotik von Frauen für Frauen stattfindet. Also auch so ein Onlyfans, aber im Kleinen. Und da geht es auch nochmal darum, was diese Sexworker da eigentlich für Onlyfans getan haben. In unserem Influencer Buch haben wir geschrieben, die Lage der Influencer bleibt prekär. Hier kann man es wirklich sehen, es gibt eine Abhängigkeit. Es ist eigentlich immer eine Scheinselbständigkeit, wenn wir von diesen Plattformen sprechen. Denn diese Plattformen können jederzeit sagen, ne, das Geschäftsmodell gibt es ab sofort nicht mehr.
Ja, da seid ihr auch... Also Kevin Ruse hat es ja auch so geschrieben, der YouTube-Creator ist der am meisten abhängige Beschäftigte seit der Sklaverei. Weil er einfach der Plattform ausgeliefert ist. Unabhängig, wie ihr es geschrieben habt, von der Höhe des Betrags. Also die Spree Karriere 200.000 Dollar kann man da verdienen, aber eben nur so lange wie... Das genau so funktioniert, wie es funktioniert. Sobald da Stellstrauben verändert werden, ist das alles vorbei.
Ist Schluss. Und die Frage ist, können die Creator sich da überhaupt wehren?
Es war ziemlich komisch, die Initial Media-Stories über Onlyfans zu sehen, dass sie Adopten ausgebildet haben. Wir sind sicher für jetzt, aber ich sollte mir vorstellen, dass sie irgendwann wieder diesen Veränderungen betrachten.
Ich glaube, niemand fühlt sich sicher auf Onlyfans.
Ja, save for now, das find ich gut, weil Joshua Chappalski und Onlyfans auch so als save space bezeichnet, wo man eben so Sexarbeit machen kann. Und eigentlich ist Onlyfans kein Social Network, sondern ein save space für digitale Sexarbeit. Und sobald die sagen, das ist aber nicht das, was wir machen wollen, gibt's das einfach nicht mehr. Niemand bleibt dabei, Onlyfans.
Das ist ja auch immer eine Anbindung an den Creator direkt. Das heißt, man kann ja auf der Plattform gar nicht sein. Das heißt, man kann ja, ich hab's dann jetzt mal aufgerufen, man bekommt ja nichts angezeigt in dem Sinne. Also ich kann jetzt nicht wie bei YouTube Videos suchen und dann klick ich die an und dann wird irgendwie gesagt, aber sie müssen jetzt fünf Euro zahlen, sondern man sieht einfach gar nichts. Sondern ich kann jetzt sagen, ach, ich möchte jetzt irgendwie der Creatorin, die wir gerade gehört haben, folgen. Dann suche ich die und dann kann ich da ein Abo abschließen und dann kann ich auf diese Seite irgendetwas machen.
Genau, es gibt keine öffentliche Timeline oder so, wie man das von anderen sozialen Netzwerken kennt.
Ja, was können Creators dagegen tun? Naja, diversifizieren.
Und ich weiß, dass es eine andere Plattform gibt namens Fansly, die ein großes Teil von uns auf die Weg gehen.
Das sieht wirklich positiv aus, und das Sexwerk-Positiv-Website hat viel mehr Features.
Die Adult Performance Artists Guild, die eine amerikanische Union für Sexwerker ist, hat sich über die Aufmerksamkeit der Menschen auf die anderen Plätze wechseln und ihre Sachen verbreiten.
Ich habe mit einem Lehrern gesprochen, der gesagt hat, dass Sexwerker, mit denen er in Kontakt ist, sich die Excell-Spreadsheets umdrehen, mit den Namen dieser alternativen Websites, die Bewertungen, die Privatschweite, all diese Dinge.
Und das ist, was die Deutschen jetzt auch schon verstanden haben. Also wir hören jetzt mal hier Bonnie Lang, die auf ihrem YouTube-Kanal dann ihre Fans immer unterrichtete über die Neuerungen. Und dann hat sie jetzt auch nochmal reagiert, dass der Pon-Band jetzt erst einmal aufgehoben ist, beziehungsweise nicht umgesetzt wird. Aber auch sie macht hier deutlich, wie sie da in Zukunft wohl mit umgehen will.
Weil gerade ja auch sehr, sehr viele Plattformen aus dem Boden schießen, die Onlyfans so ein bisschen nachmachen oder halt das Konzept kopieren. Selbst ich war schon im Gespräch mit einer anderen Plattform umzuschauen, um mich einfach noch nach einer zweiten Plattform umzuschauen. Man kann da nur spekulieren, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, wie sie das in Zukunft handhaben wollen. Das ist auf jeden Fall krass, weil ich glaube, jetzt haben doch viele Creator ihre Lausche aufgesperrt und schauen sich trotzdem nach etwas Neuem um, um einfach eine Sicherheit zu haben, da diese Plattform jederzeit diesen Schritt wieder gehen kann. Und wie man gesehen hat, hatte man ja nicht viel Zeit. Sie wollten das ja alles um den 1. Oktober umsetzen. Das heißt, man hätte einen ganzen Monat Zeit, seine Follower auf eine neue Plattform zu locken. Und das ist nun mal wirklich, wirklich nicht einfach. Denn wer sich mit Social Media auskennt, ich hatte das schon mal gesagt, weiß, wie schwer es ist, seine eingefleischten Abonnenten, die schon so lange dabei sind oder die auch neu dazugekommen sind, die es gerade auf die eine Plattform geschafft haben, dann auf eine andere zu lozen und auch wirklich jeden zu erreichen.
Ja, es ist die gleiche Panik, die unter den TikTokern aufkam, als Trump meinte, ich benne das mal, weil ich China nicht mag. Und dann teilte er uns auch noch mal gesagt, man kann nicht einfach eine TikToks Bekanntheit nehmen und sagen, jetzt mache ich dasselbe in YouTube. Weil das ist einfach, das ist eine unterschiedliche Mode, in der gearbeitet wird.
Und die träge Masse, du sagst es ja immer wieder, ist natürlich auch da entsprechend vorhanden. Du kannst nicht einfach einmal sagen, hier kommt mal schnell rüber, kostet dasselbe. Ihr müsst nur mal gerade noch mal da das Konto anregen. Sofort wird man wahrscheinlich 80 Prozent verloren haben.
Genau, also die Trägheit, das ist immer wieder erstaunlich. Wir hätten die ganzen Probleme nicht, wenn wir Protokolle statt Plattformen hätten. Also wenn das einfach auf technischer Ebene, ja, Micropayment und wie auch immer, wenn das einfach bezahlbar ist, egal wo man es anbietet. Stattdessen hängen halt alle von diesen Plattformen ab.
Im Doppelgänger Podcast kennst du den?
Den kenn ich. Ich hab ihn jetzt noch mal gehört.
Ja, ich höre ihn sehr, sehr gerne jetzt. Ich hab ihn jetzt so für mich entdeckt. Und zwar wird er betrieben von Philipp Klöckler und Philipp Klöckner. Ich glaube, ich hab das jetzt richtig gesagt. Also sie heißen beide Philipp und Klöckler und Klöckner, glaube ich. Jedenfalls unterhalten die sich da sehr viel über die Tech-Branche, aber immer in Bezug auf Aktien. Denn es geht viel um E-Commerce und auch sie haben sich mit Onlyfans auseinandergesetzt und gehen jetzt mal so durch. Warum hat Onlyfans das jetzt wirklich gemacht? Also die wegzustoßen ist ja erst mal ein Riesenschritt und die gehen hier auf ein paar Dinge ganz interessant ein.
Genau, da ist immer ein Problem für Adult-Webseiten, ein Payment-Funnel zu bekommen. Im Moment nutzen die, glaube ich, CC-Bill als Payment-Gateway. Habe ich als Tester in meiner Professional Capacity herausgefunden. Die wiederum werben selbst damit, dass sie für Dating, Adult-Life-Camps und sogenannte High-Risk-Websites der zu präferierende Zahlungseinbieter sind. Das Problem ist in der Regel einerseits die hohen Chargebacks, also das in den Industrien besonders wahrscheinlich ist, dass vielleicht findet der Lebenspartner die Rechnung und sagt, was ist das? Und der sagt, das habe ich nie gemacht und ich mache hier sofort ein Chargeback und dann kommt es zu einer überdurchschnittlichen, also irgendwie 2, 3, 4, 5 Prozent Chargeback Ratio, also dass der Kreditkarteninhaber sagt, ich habe das nie gemacht, gerade wenn er vielleicht auch den Payment Gateway nicht erkennt, also wenn nicht klar ist, für was das eigentlich war.
Ein Aspekt, über den ich gar nicht nachgedacht hatte, dass das offenbar auch eine Rolle spielt und dann wird es ein bisschen teurer.
Wenn ihr gemeinsame Konten hasst, musst du aufpassen, was du kaufst.
Dann wiederum entstehen extrem hohe Kosten gegenüber den Kreditkartennetzwerken. Der normale Chargeback liegt unter 0, 5 Prozent oder weit unter 0, 5 Prozent. Bei Adult, Casino und so weiter geht es halt deutlich höher. Wie gesagt, dann stehen hohe Kosten. Teilweise wird man aus dem Programm rausgeschmissen. Visa Master haben zum Beispiel vor paar Wochen MindGeek, das ist die Pornhub-Mutter, rausgeschmissen, aus ähnlichen Gründen. Also auch da ging es um Konsent und Revenge Porn. Also dass Leute ohne ihr An-Eye-Verständnis auf der Plattform geleitet sind.
Also solche Rückbuchungen sind offenbar dann teuer, fallen ins Gewicht. Ich glaube, der dritte Grund, der jetzt hier genannt wird, ist eigentlich der für mich überzeugendste. Und zwar, wenn man nach Venture Capital sucht und dann halt eine Seite mit Pornoinhalten hat.
Und die andere Story ist, glaube ich, dass man die Firma auch nicht finanzieren kann, weil kein VC, die irgendwie mit einem 10-Foot-Pool anfässt. Also das wird so wie eine heiße Kartoffel hin und her gereift. Keiner will das sagen. Also die Zahlen sind eigentlich sehr überzeugend. GMV Außenumsatz, also was die Creator einsammeln. 2, 2 Milliarden schätzt man. War es 2020? 2021 werden es 6 Milliarden werden schätzungsweise. Davon bleibt als Net Revenue übrig. Also der Innenumsatz von Onlyfans 2020 375 Millionen. 2021 dieses Jahr bis zu 1, 2 Milliarden rechnet man. Wer das durchrechnet, merkt die Take-Rate ist ungefähr 20 Prozent, die sich Onlyfans nimmt. Nicht schlecht.
Warum sind die damit nicht zufrieden? Das verstehe ich dann nicht. Erst ein Milliarden-Business und denkst, es könnte auch ein 5 Milliarden-Business sein. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, klar, man sieht dann so, Facebook macht irgendwie, also damals 10 Milliarden Umsatz im Jahr, ist aber 350 Milliarden wert. Jetzt machen sie irgendwie 60 Milliarden und sind 500-600 Milliarden wert. Klar, gibt es da immer so einen extremen Hebel, um zu denken, ich könnte eigentlich auch 100 Milliarden umsetzen, bei dem Umsatz, den ich habe.
Und du meinst jetzt, Tim Stokely sollte einfach sagen, ist doch schön.
Ich glaube, hier bei Onlyfans denkt man sich, es ist aber kein gutes Werbeumfeld, wo ich mir denke, ja, das ist Facebook auch nicht. Bei Facebook kommt man auch nicht irgendwann mal auf 500 Milliarden Umsatzwerbung oder so. Dieses berühmte Kurs-Gewinn-Verhältnis ist überhaupt nicht mehr gedeckelt, also einfach nicht mehr gerechtfertigt. Und bei Onlyfans ist das aber von Anfang an klar für alle. Hier können wir mit der Werbung nicht so und so viel Milliarden machen, während diese Hoffnung bei den anderen sozialen Netzwerken irrerweise immer noch besteht. Und man sieht ja, wie YouTube einen da auch wirklich, man muss ja nur mal ein Video mit 10.000 Views haben oder so, und dann kommt YouTube gleich auf einen zu und sagt, hier, mach mal da und da, und dann sieht man so automatisierte Videos, wie sie einem noch mal erklären, wie man das alles brand safe macht und an monetarisiert, also wann man nicht mehr monetarisiert wird und so, wie schnell man da irgendwie rausfällt. Naja, das ist ja total krass. Also YouTube ist wirklich sehr daran gelegen, dass sie jedes Video monetarisieren können. Und wenn du zeigst, dass du Erfolge hast bei YouTube, aber es nicht monetarisierbar ist, weil du irgendwelchen Quatsch machst, dann drängen die dich halt dazu, dass du es auf monetarisierungsfähiges Niveau bekommst. Also Brand Safe ist so das Zauberwort dafür. Weil die dann halt sonst nichts verdienen an diesen Videos. Du auch nicht, sagen die dann immer, aber die eben auch nicht. Weiß man ja, ne? Und das verstehe ich halt nicht, warum die nicht einfach sagen, wir haben hier ein Business, wo absolut treue Verkäufer und Käufer sich gegenüberstehen und uns eine Milliarde einbringen. Also damit sind wir zufrieden, so ne?
Da müsste wirklich Tim Stokely sagen, das ist toll, dass ich das erreicht habe und dann ist doch alles in Ordnung. Es gibt auch so Ideen, dass man sagt, vielleicht gibt es so Anti-Porno-Gruppen-Aktivisten, die sind ja in den USA zahlreicher als hier, die jetzt versuchen, da Einfluss zu nehmen auf Finanzunternehmen oder so. Ich kann mir das nicht so vorstellen, wie weit das funktioniert. Oder ob wir es eigentlich bei diesen Finanzunternehmen, bei diesen Finanzdienstleistern und so und auch bei den Venture-Capital-Leuten es mit sehr konservativen, prügen Menschen zu tun haben. Das ist denkbar. Steven Colbert hat das jedenfalls aufgegriffen, diese Überlegung und macht da natürlich eine Pointe draus. Den Piepser kann jeder ergänzen. Und wir hören nochmal ganz kurz Stock Club. Da geht es nochmal darum, so einen Bogen zu TikTok zu schlagen, was du ja schon gemacht hast gerade.
Was sagt es über diese Influence, dass sie eine Komplizierung von der Politik der Unternehmen verändern, wofür sie Geld geben oder nicht?
Es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass wir über eine Publikumpe, die TikTok, reden, dass wir immer noch über neue Regeln, neue Politikveränderungen, die zu TikTok kommen, und den Impact, den die Unternehmen haben, wenn sie auf der Stelle sind, oder im Hauptquartier in China sind. Und am Ende des Tages spricht Geld. Wenn wir über Demokratisierung reden, müssen wir eigentlich auch mal über so Finanzdienstleister, Demokratisierung reden. Das könnte ja auch auf EU-Ebene wunderbar gehen. Also man müsste ja nicht über diese ganzen privaten Finanzdienstleister agieren.
Das auch, wo es eigentlich unser öffentlich-rechtliches YouTube und die Finanzierung von solchen Sachen, die creatormäßig passieren. In China, das können wir ja im September mal anschauen, geht ja Qi, das wird ja jetzt alles immer auf Qi gemünzt. Sehr hart vor gegen Social Media, alles was Digitalisierung und Ermächtigung über staatlichen Willen hinaus und so weiter. Also die zeigen so ein bisschen, wo die Handlungsmöglichkeiten sind.
Absolut, wir sollten das auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten. Ich hab da später noch mal einen Clip zu, aber zum Abschluss noch eine Pointe von Stephen Colbert zum Onlyfans-Porn-Band.
Wir gucken nach Afghanistan. Wie schon im Fernsehpodcast angemerkt, kann man jetzt erstmal nur wenig zu sagen und Chronisten pflichtig festhalten. Das ist natürlich erstmal so eine vorrangige Aufgabe. Allerdings geht dieses Scheitern in Afghanistan natürlich wirklich einher mit einem Scheitern des Westen insgesamt. Wir wissen ja, Katar ist so ein Land, dass den Terror damit finanziert. Osama bin Laden wurde in Pakistan getötet. Das hat alles relativ wenig mit Afghanistan zu tun. Und gleichzeitig haben wir parallel so eine komische Entwicklung, dass Olympia und Fußball-WMs und so weiter nun noch in so autoritären Staaten funktioniert. Also ist die Demokratie jetzt eigentlich völlig abgemeldet, fragt man sich so ein bisschen? Also wurden wir in Afghanistan eigentlich von der Welt jetzt abgemeldet. Denn die Fußball-WM wird natürlich auch weiterhin in Katar stattfinden. Und diese ganzen Verschränkungen werden überhaupt nicht gemacht.
Als Triumph für China wird das schon gezeichnet?
China, große Rolle gleich. In der Ansicht haben wir hier so eine Gemengelage, die mal begutachtet werden muss. Allerdings, das deutsche Scheitern muss man sich wirklich mal anhören. Ich finde es auch ein bisschen crazy. Am 16. also am Tag nach dem Sturm auf Kabul hat sich unser Außenminister dann ja doch mal geäußert und Merkel auch und dieses Scheitern eingestanden. Heiko Maas hat so ein bisschen versucht kontrolliert vorzutragen. Bei Merkel hört man schon so ein bisschen die Nachdenklichkeit auch raus.
Es ist die Reaktion der Regierung, die den Tag in Berlin dann besonders macht. Erst gibt der Außenminister zu, das Kabinett war nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit.
Es gibt auch nichts zu beschönigen, wir alle, die Bundesregierung, die Nachrichtendienste, die internationale Gemeinschaft, wir haben die Lage falsch eingeschätzt. Die Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich die afghanischen Sicherheitskräfte vor den Taliban zurückgezogen haben und kapituliert haben, haben weder wir noch unsere Pater, auch nicht unsere Experten so vorausgesehen.
Danach tritt die Regierungschefin vor die Kameras und gibt zu, der Einsatz am Hindukusch und die Idee der Demokratisierung Afghans sind vollständig gescheitert.
Wir waren immerhin fast 20 Jahre jetzt in Afghanistan. In dieser Zeit ist es nicht gelungen. Und insofern muss man sagen, dass das keine erfolgreiche Bemühung war und dass man daraus Lehren ziehen muss. Ja, und seine Ziele auch kleiner fassen muss, glaube ich, bei solchen Einsätzen.
Ziele kleiner fassen ist ja schon das Eingeständnis, das Ziel war zu groß, als ob es daran lag.
Was war denn eigentlich das Ziel? Denn das ist ja ganz erstaunlich, wie das jetzt so gerade diskutiert wird. Biden sagt, es sei ja nie um Nation-Building gegangen, aber natürlich ging es genau darum. Es ging ja nicht darum, dass man in Afghanistan einmarschiert, um Osama bin Laden nur kalt zu machen. Das hätte man ja auch auf anderen Wegen hinbekommen.
Vor allem nicht in Afghanistan.
Vor allem dann nicht in Afghanistan, sondern man hat ja die Idee gehabt, man errichtet dort eine Demokratie oder etwas der Demokratie sehr Ähnliches. Hat natürlich da jetzt Leute installiert, die maximal korrupt offenbar sind. Da wurde ja wohl mit Bargeld jetzt in großen Taschen ausgereist und der Neffe des Präsidenten hat nochmal ein Selfie gepostet für Instagram und und und vom Flughafen. Also da muss man doch erst mal festhalten, dass dieses Ziel gab es und dann gibt es ja diese andere große Erzählung. Die Frauen konnten in die Schulen gehen und wir haben zum ersten Mal, dass wir Frauen unterstützt haben. Da war ja schon Roger Wilhelmsen immer jemand, der dann in der Diskussion mit Til Schweiger oder so anderen Konsorten dann sagte, ich bin seit Jahr und Tag in Afghanistan unterwegs und da gab es immer auch ein ziviles Afghanistan und es musste manchmal mit den Taliban kooperieren, um an irgendwas ranzukommen und manchmal nicht. Und es war immer ein diplomatisches Aushandeln und es war immer so, dass man dort auch starke emazipatorische Bewegungen hatten und wir haben nicht alle in Afghanistan darauf gewartet, dass der Westen jetzt kommt und die Frauenrechte bringt.
Genau, woran ist man gescheitert und welche Ziele und wie groß dürfen sie sein? Klar, Terror verhindern, also Afghanistan klingt kein Terror aus im Sinne von, dass jetzt der Terror, den wir in Europa und im Westen erlebt haben, Homegrown war. Das große Thema eigentlich gewesen, der Sicherheitsbehörden auf der anderen Seite. Heiko Maas ist wirklich eine crazy Figur, denn wir haben es in Afghanistan ja mit den am besten überwachten Land der Welt zu tun gehabt, aus allen Himmelsrichtungen und mit allen Technologien, die es so gab. Und trotzdem hat man das nicht gesehen. Und die Taliban sind dann zu Fuß in Kabul einmarschiert, wissend, dass man von oben aus dem Satellit nicht erkennt, wer da gerade Fußgänger ist. Also da ist keine Autokolonne vorgefahren oder so. Und zu den Zielen kann man ja auch wirklich sagen, dass was wir den Taliban jetzt gerade unterstellen, ist ja das, woran wir gescheitert sind, nämlich dass die jetzt Nation Building schaffen, mit ihrem Kalifat und so weiter. Während wir unsere Idee von Demokratie da irgendwie nicht hin exportieren konnten. Und das muss man sich jetzt wirklich mal in der Dimensionen vergegenwärtigen. Reinhard Ehrös von der Kinderhilfe Afghanistan, war wohl offenbar früher auch mal Soldat oder so, keine Ahnung, saß in der Phönixrunde am 25. und hat hier folgendes noch mal zusammengefasst.
Das war ein sehr teurer Einsatz.
Über eine Billion US-Dollar.
Teuerste Krieg in der Geschichte der Menschheit. Viele, viele Opfer auf Seiten des Westens auch, auch bei meinen Kameraden. 59 tote Soldaten. Und bei der afghanischen Bevölkerung, da wissen wir gar nicht, wie viel Zehntausend oder Hunderttausend da zu Tote gekommen sind. Also unter dem Aspekt Aufwand und Nutzen oder Aufwand und Ergebnis war es ein vergeblicher Einsatz.
Der teuerste Krieg.
Ich bin gerade ganz...
Eine Billion Dollar.
Länger als der Zweite Weltkrieg. Also es ist eine unglaubliche Dimension dafür, dass am Ende man einfach das Land verlassen hat. Und alle sind sich einig, dass da unverrichteter Ding ist, sozusagen. Also es ist wirklich in der Dimension so gar nicht so richtig zu begreifen. Und jetzt ist natürlich das oberste Ziel Schadensbegrenzung. Ich glaube, es geht jetzt nicht auch nur um den Wahltermin oder so, sondern man will jetzt im Großen und Ganzen diese Vergeblichkeit, mit der man hier handeln wollte. Und es ist nun mal das ultimative Handeln, kriegerisch tätig zu sein, als so hochkapazitive Länder, wie wir hier im Westen haben und als NATO-Aktion, da wirklich alle beteiligt. Annegret Kammkamp-Bauer, AKK, begrüßt hier die Soldaten am Ende der Evakuierung, also am 27. August.
Wir alle haben Ihnen und den Männern und Frauen vor Ort das vollste Vertrauen geschenkt. Und ich kann heute sagen, Sie haben gemeinsam mit den Männern und Frauen dieses Vertrauen und alle Erwartungen, die wir in Sie gesetzt haben, mehr als erfüllt.
Was ist denn das für eine Rede? Das ist ja schon eine Unverschämtheit, zu sagen, wir haben da vollstes Vertrauen. Man muss ja eigentlich hätte sie sagen müssen, haben uns nicht gekümmert, wir hatten keine Ahnung, ein Glück, dass wir sie haben, dass sie wenigstens Schadensbegrenzung machen konnten.
Und das ist nämlich der Punkt. Es war ein vernetzter Ansatz. Die Idee war eigentlich nicht, die Bundeswehr dahin zu schicken, sondern dort Entwicklungsarbeit zu machen, abgesichert über die Bundeswehr. Nun hat man nur die Bundeswehr hingeschickt, hat nie in dem Maße Entwicklungshilfe, wie das vor dem Afghanistan Krieg war, dort geleistet.
Hat Williamson auch immer gesagt, er sagt, dann reisten auch immer so deutsche Promis darunter, nur zu den Soldaten. Das andere hat die auch nie interessiert. Dann ging es immer nur um die deutschen Soldaten. Und Schweige hat ja gesagt, wir schätzen unsere deutschen Soldaten nicht. Aber man hat nie geguckt, wie kriegt man denn andere Strukturen her?
Genau, und Thomas Ruttig hat das ja mal beschrieben. Die DDR damals, und an dem System ist er ja auch groß geworden, hat noch in Deutschland afghanische Vernetzung hergestellt, bis hin zu Studiengängen, in denen man auch mal die Sprache lernt und sowas. Und dann ausgebildet eben dahin fliegt. Das hat es ja so nie gegeben. Deswegen auch die große Abhängigkeit von den Ortskräften, angefangen bei den Sprachbarrieren, die da überbrückt werden müssen. Und wir können überlegen, 20 Jahre, hätte man das vorher gewusst, dass man so lange da ist, wäre es natürlich jetzt total auf der Hand gelegen zu sagen, na klar, dann bilden wir dich zwei Jahre in der Sprache aus, und dann bist du fähig da noch zehn Jahre zu arbeiten und so. Also hätte man die Dimension vorher einfach mal so umrahmt, dann wäre da wirklich was möglich gewesen. Es ist auch insbesondere verlogen, hier nochmal insbesondere den Fokus auf die Bundeswehr zu lenken, wie sie das macht bei dieser letzten Begrüßung, weil nicht nur alle anderen gesellschaftlichen Teile von der Politik nicht organisiert da ausgefallen sind, sondern weil auch bei dem regulären Ankommen in Deutschland von den eigentlich geplant letzten Soldaten, bevor man wusste, man muss noch so eine Mega-Evakuierung machen, war da überhaupt niemand von der Politik.
Damals Ende Juni waren in Wunstorf weder die Verteidigungsministerin noch die Kanzlerin da, als nach 20 Jahren Einsatz das letzte deutsche Afghanistan-Kontingent zurückkehrte. So darf ich doch als Ihr Kommandeur für Sie feststellen, Mission accomplished. Aber die Mission war gerade nicht erfüllt. Die vielleicht gefährlichste sollte erst noch kommen, die Rettung von Menschen aus den Händen der Taliban.
Das ist ja auch ungeheuerlich, dass die da nicht da waren. Also dann denkt man doch da, wo man ja so sehr auch dafür immer war. Also Merkel hätte ja auch gerne eigentlich noch den Irak-Krieg mitgemacht. Dass man dann nicht kommt, wenn die Soldaten da sind, aber dann jederzeit natürlich den Grünen oder den Linken vorwerfen, ihr Pazifisten, ihr schätzt unsere Soldaten nicht, und die sind nicht da. Das war ja auch überhaupt, als dieses Desaster da dann begann am Flughafen in Kabul, gab es ja noch diesen Tweet, der dann gelöscht worden ist von AKK, dass sie gerade, war sie da auch irgendwo, Erftal oder sonst was, wir backen hier Pfannkuchen und verkaufen sie, um Spenden zu sammeln. Das macht die Verteidigungsministerin während Kabul ab.
Genau, und das ist beispielhaft dafür, also gerade dieses irgendwo anders beschäftigt sein und das auch noch zu zeigen oder hier dann wirklich nicht da zu sein, wenn die letzten Soldaten kommen, wenn man sich überlegt, wie das damals losging. Also die Erklärung von Gerhard Schröder, dem Bundeskanzler, bedingungslose Solidarität, Artikel 5 überhaupt das allererste Mal. Und dann zieht man da gemeinsam nach Afghanistan mit der klaren Zielsetzung zumindest damals, die Terror-Camps dazu beenden. Und dann so langsam findet man keinen, er hat keine Exit-Strategie, bleibt dann ewig vor Ort und scheitert eigentlich die ganze Zeit und will am Ende, und die Bundeswehr muss das sozusagen alles ausbaden, versucht sich so politisch rauszuschleichen aus der Situation. Einfach, wenn wir nicht kommen, kommt auch kein Fernsehteam und dann muss auch Afghanistan nie wieder thematisiert werden. So ungefähr. Dann kamen natürlich die Taliban ein bisschen überraschend und entsprechend haben wir jetzt diese Lage nach 40 Jahren Krieg in Afghanistan, für die wir dann doch, auch wenn wir nichts geschaffen haben, was wir wollten, mitverantwortlich sind.
Was die Waffen angeht, Afghanistan ist durch 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre Bürgerkrieg eines der waffenreichsten Länder der Welt. Also da gibt es mehr Waffen als irgendwo sonst in der Welt. Natürlich mit jedem Sieg gegen die afghanischen Streitkräfte sind den Taliban dann noch mehr Waffen in die Hände gefallen. Also das brauchte keine externe Unterstützung.
Ja, und das gilt natürlich vor allem auch für die Amerikaner, wie die da abgereist sind, die haben ihre Stützpunkte alle intakt gelassen. Das waren einfach rückblickend auch große Waffenexporte, die da stattfanden. Also wir haben das ganze Material dahin. Klar, die großen Autos und so haben wir wieder mit zurückgenommen, aber der ganze Rest dann eben nicht. Und jetzt haben wir das waffenreichste Land der Welt aufgegeben von uns und mit so einer Art Bürgerkrieg zwischen Taliban und IS. Und Al-Qaeda spielt wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwo eine Rolle. Also es ist wirklich gruselig. Die geopolitische Lage vor Ort wird jetzt aber wirklich interessant, denn nur weil der Westen geht, heißt ja nicht, dass jetzt die Afghanen mit sich selber da irgendwas tun müssen oder auf sich selbst gestellt sind. Hier eine kleine Kurzmeldung am 16. Also ein Tag nachdem die Taliban da zu Fuß in Kabul einmarschierten.
China hat die Taliban zu einer friedlichen Nachtübernahme aufgefordert. Man respektiere den Willen und die Entscheidung des afghanischen Volkes zu Peking. Mehr dazu von Markus Gürnel aus der Frankfurter Börse.
Man akzeptiere den Wille des afghanischen Volkes, das jetzt gerade seinen Willen bekundet.
Jaja, das ist aber ganz erstaunlich, dass man da immer wieder jetzt noch in der Presse zum Teil so drauf reagiert, dass sei das überraschend. Also das ist ja gar nicht so. Denn China plant ja mit dem Seidenstraßenprojekt ohnehin schon, dass Afghanistan da eine gewisse Rolle spielen könnte. Und die haben ja schon die ganze Zeit in den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder mit Taliban verhandelt, haben ja da den Taliban-Chef und so getroffen. Also da gibt es ja auch Bilder, historische Treffen und so weiter. Das heißt, China ist ja nie auf einen Werte-Export ausgewesen. Also wie wir jetzt überhaupt diesen Einsatz begründet haben. Wir müssen unsere westlichen Werte vertreten und den dort hinbringen. Sondern China denkt da immer nur rein wirtschaftlich und sagt, naja, gut, dann ist das jetzt gerade die Regierungsform, die das Volk will oder was auch immer oder die sich durchgesetzt hat. Und deswegen verhandeln wir mit denen genauso wie, wenn da jetzt irgendjemand anders gerade an der Macht wäre. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was man da jetzt erkennen muss und auch fragen muss, wie der Westen eigentlich generell jetzt dazu steht. Also nachdem diese Mission gescheitert ist, Irak ist ja auch gescheitert, dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen. Das ist ja jetzt auch vollkommen klar. Können wir denn jetzt noch universalistisch unsere Werte, und ich setze diese Werte jetzt mal ein Anführungszeichen, jeder kann ja da selbst rausziehen, inwieweit das rhetorisches Mittel ist oder so, aber immerhin wird ja immer dieser Wertbezug hergestellt. Können wir unsere Werte noch in irgendeiner Weise exportieren? Sind die gewollt? Oder müssen wir dann diese geopolitischen Konflikte immer abseits dieser Wertediskussion betrachten? Würde anders gefragt, heute ein Horst Köhler, wenn er Bundespräsident wäre, zurücktreten müssen, wenn er gesagt hätte jetzt, naja, wir haben ja vor allem Wirtschaftsinteressen oder auch Wirtschaftsinteressen in Afghanistan vertreten. Denn das sagte er vor einigen Jahren. Und da sagte man, das ist ein No-Go. Das kann man nicht sagen, denn wir sind ja dort für die Menschen Rechte, Frauen und so weiter.
AKK hat ja kürzlich ein unbewaffnetes Kriegsschiff ins südchinesische Meer oder den wie auch immer man das jetzt politisch korrekt annennt, geschickt. Und da ging es ja auch ganz bewusst darum, Lieferketten abzusichern. Und das fand ich erstaunlich, denn das war auf der Kölerschen, also hat es genau Augenhöhe gehabt. Und trotzdem lief es durch. Und China ist super interessant hier, denn Afghanistan zofft sich mit, also jetzt nicht mehr, mit Pakistan, Pakistan ein radikale islamisches Land, sagst du mal so ganz kurz ausgedrückt. Aber es gibt oben im Osten einen ganz kleinen, aber super langen Zipfel Afghanistans, der für die chinesische Lieferlinie da eine wirklich große Rolle spielt, von der Thomas Rothig uns auch damals schon sagte, ja, aber da ist relativ friedlich, denn da hat China Interessen. Also Afghanistan ist nicht automatisch, nur weil es Afghanistan ist und der Westen nicht da ist jetzt ein vor Bürgerkrieg zerrüttetes Land. Je nach wirtschaftlicher Lage verhält sich das da unterschiedlich.
Und China verträgt sich ganz gut mit Pakistan. Du hattest das ja auch mal hier vorgespielt, dass der Regierungschef da nicht über die Uiguren sprechen wollte, obwohl das ja eigentlich dann Glaubensbrüder im weiteren Sinne sind. Und es ist ja so, dass man sich mit Indien immer mehr verkracht und man auch nicht so weiß, was will dann Modi da eigentlich. Deswegen versucht China natürlich mit Pakistan jetzt da gewisse zarte Bande zu knüpfen.
Genau. Bevor wir auf Indien gleich kommen, noch kurz ein Clip, der so ein bisschen Bundesregierung nahe steht. Die Bundesregierung hofft auf G7, also den Westen, dass man jetzt wieder da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das alte Rezept dann doch noch mal funktioniert. Baerbock allerdings verweist dann schon auf China und Russland in der Diskussion.
Für Dienstag ist ein virtueller G7-Gipfel zu Afghanistan zwar geplant. Das reicht Baerbock aber nicht.
Wir müssen ja auch China und Russland da bei so einer Konferenz mit einladen. Russland ist beim G7-Format nicht dabei. Die Anreinerstaaten braucht man, um darüber zu klären, wie können Menschen, die jetzt Panik haben, dass die ganze Familie getötet wird, wirklich in Sicherheit gebracht werden.
Ich bin überrascht, denn Baerbock ist jetzt nicht dafür bekannt, in Dialog mit Russland zu suchen. Aber man macht das hier nochmal deutlich und sagt, naja, das ist jetzt schon oft mal so multilateral diese Welt, da können wir gar nicht mehr einfach sagen, wir G7-Leute.
Ja, also Baerbock ist ja eine ganz entscheidende Gegnerin dieser Erdgaspipeline durch die Ostsee. Und Russland sowieso eigentlich außen vor. Und jetzt sagt sie hier aber, eigentlich ist G7 mitgescheitert. Also von G7 können wir uns gerade nichts versprechen. Die würden sich vielleicht dann mal treffen. Und dann wäre das so eine typische Foto-OP. Man nimmt ja dann immer die besten Häuser, die man so findet. Und dann trifft man sich da. Und Russland muss hier mit ins Gespräch. Und China, aber nicht im G7-Format, also wo einfach Chi noch mal so einen kleinen Mini-Vortrag am Tisch zum Thema Weltoffenheit und Freie Hand hält oder so. Sondern einfach mal Butter bei die Fischer und so. Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und Indien spielt hier in den Nachrichten kurz auch eine Rolle. Allerdings sind das immer nur diese ganz kurzen Berichte, die so von aus Pakistan dann angeliefert werden, von den Leuten, die da so Zuständigkeitsbereich, drei Milliarden Menschen in Asien und so, dann mal kurz Berichte schicken dürfen.
Wut, Hass, Terror, Krieg. Afghanistan ist der Schauplatz, doch es ging immer um mehr. Viele Motive, viele Mächte, die in ganz Südasien um Einfluss ringen. Pakistans Ambitionen, etwa auch in Afghanistan, waren immer geprägt vom Dauerkonflikt mit dem Erzrivalen Indien.
Wenn Indien nicht existierte, oder wenn man mit Indien befreundet wäre, hätte man sicher eine grundlegend vernünftige und andere Politik gegenüber Afghanistan betrieben. Afghanistan wurde immer so als Bauer auf dem strategischen Schachspiel gegen Indien wahrgenommen. Und das Wichtigste war tatsächlich, in Afghanistan irgendwelche indienfreundlichen Tendenzen zu verhindern.
Die ich jedenfalls wird es unter den radikali-islamischen Taliban kaum mehr geben. Indien, das zur bisherigen Regierung in Afghanistan ein ordentliches Verhältnis hatte, scheint einer der Verlierer. Pakistanskarten sind jetzt sicher besser, aber das Spiel bleibt kompliziert.
Ja, und hier habe ich eine Information aus dem Handelsblatt, die lese ich gerade vor. Und zwar geht es da um Pakistan, China und wie die miteinander kooperieren. An das geplante Diyama-Basha-Wasserkraftwerk in der Nähe der Grenze zu Afghanistan knüpft Pakistan seit Jahren große Erwartungen. Der Staudamm am Indus, dem längsten Fluss des indischen Subkontinents, könnte mit seiner angepeilten Leistung von 4, 5 Gigawatt einen erheblichen Teil von Pakistans Strommangel beseitigen. Außerdem könnte er bei der Bewässerung von 5000 Quadratkilometern landdienlich sein, erhofft sich die Regierung in Islamabad. Doch von internationalen Geldgebern wie der Weltbank erhielt sie keine Unterstützung für das Projekt. Der Hauptgrund, der geplante Stausee, liegt in der umstrittenen Region Kashmir, die auch von Indien beansprucht wird. Vergangenes Jahr konnte Pakistans Premierminister Imran Khan dennoch den offiziellen Baubeginn verkünden. China sprang als Partner für das laut Schätzungen 14 Milliarden Dollar teure Infrastrukturprojekt ein und sicherte sich im Rahmen eines Joint Ventures 70 Prozent der Anlage. Die Proteste Indiens Verhalten ungehört.
Ja, und da muss der Westen dann wirklich überlegen, also das macht China ja schon lange, dass man die Investitionsinstitutionen nachbaut, also wirklich eins zu eins, eine IWF, eine Weltbank und so. Und jetzt wären die natürlich da tätig. Und jetzt kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, dass irgendwie China regional, also regional im Sinne von kontinental, die Institutionen nachbaut, die Europa und Amerika tragen, nur eben für doppelt und dreifach so viele Menschen. Und jetzt haben wir diese Region. Wasser spielt natürlich da sowieso eine Megarolle. Das wurde komplett ausgeblendet bisher.
Ja, ohne die Wertedebatte.
Das ist ja ganz entscheidend.
Das ist ja für diese Partner, für Pakistan und so ganz entscheidend, dass die sagen, gut, die Chinesen kümmern sich nicht darum, was wir so machen im eigenen Land. Wir sehen zu, dass wir da unser Wasserwerk bekommen. Und das ist natürlich ein Abrücken eigentlich von den vergangenen 100 Jahren amerikanischer Außenpolitik. Also mit Wutruf Wilson beginnt das eigentlich. Und das ist auch eine Frage, die man sich dann als Bündnispartner natürlich stellen muss, was das überhaupt dann noch bedeuten kann für uns. Beziehungsweise inwieweit wir dann auch sagen müssen, man ist dann noch weniger interventionistisch. Weil jetzt ja auch zugleich immer gesagt wird, die Bundeswehr muss Verantwortung übernehmen. Aber was bedeutet das denn eigentlich gerade, wenn man ja sieht, dass man es nicht mehr schafft, dieses Wertgerüst durchzusetzen?
Genau. Und wir haben natürlich auch die Gemengelage, dass wir in Deutschland jetzt insbesondere pseudomäßig auf unsere Werte zurückgeworfen worden, weil das das letzte sind, was wir haben. Und Heiko Maas dann sagt, ne, für die Taliban bezahle ich nicht. Also ich kürze auch da wieder Geld, wo wir wissen, wer wissen, wer dann einspringt, während aber Afghanen gerade das Geld besonders brauchen, da die da mit diesen Missernten zu tun haben. Also es sind ja 18 Millionen Menschen vom Hunger bedroht. Merz war bei Ilna, Friedrich Merz, und hat hier auch noch mal China ganz kurz mit reingebracht ins Gespräch.
Ich würde übrigens gerne auch mal die Frage beantwortet wissen, was machen eigentlich Russland und China? Wie verhalten sich diese beiden Länder eigentlich? Die beiden Botschaften sind ja nicht geräumt worden, sondern im Gegenteil, sie sind aufgestockt worden. Also wir stehen hier vor einer wirklich, und Robert Habeck hat das, wie ich finde, richtig gesagt, wir stehen vor einer ganzen Neujustierung der Deutschen, auch der europäischen Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik. Und wenn ich Europa sage, dann sollten wir endlich aufhören, mit diesem Gerede über die europäische Armee. Wir sind ja noch nicht einmal in der Lage, eine europäische Außenpolitik konzeptionell zu entwerfen. So schweige denn operativ. Da stehen eine ganze Reihe von Fragen im Raum, die heute auch aus diesen aktuellen Ereignissen heraus gar nicht so schnell beantwortet werden können.
Das braucht es auch.
Ich glaube aber, er sonnt sich einfach in der Zäsur. Für ihn geht es gar nicht so ums Detail.
Er will einfach mal Historiker sein.
Er macht im Grunde das, was Cholatur gemacht hat, nur genau umgedreht. Er nüchelt immer irgendwas vor sich hin und lässt dann so Signalworte fallen. Nur bei Cholatur waren halt auch die Sätze dazwischen, so unverständlich sie waren, dann doch immer von Bedeutung.
Und du hast ja einen Vortrag von Cholatur gehört, der jetzt nochmal veröffentlicht ist. Bei YouTube findet man den?
Die Uni Duisburg-Essen hatte ihn 2009 als Mercator Gastprofessor. Man hat jetzt im Zuge der Afghanistan-Diskussion das Video einfach nochmal hochgeladen. Und man guckt das dann so und denkt 2009, aber es ist ja wirklich nichts passiert zwischen 2009 und 2021, außer dass wir gesagt haben, wir brauchen Afghanistan als Abschiebeland und müssen deswegen dort bleiben, um irgendwie so zu tun als und so. Und das ist ja eigentlich gescheitert die letzten zehn Jahre, dass wir nur so eine Pseudo-Sicht auf, wir können dahin abschieben, es ist sicher dort. Aber eigentlich ist ja seit 2005, 2007, seit Margot Kehsman sagt, in Afghanistan hat sich nichts fundamental geändert, außer dass die Bevölkerung explodiert ist. Also im Sinne von Wachstum.
Ich war noch Schüler, 16, 17, da war ich auf einem Vortrag von Peter Schollertour mit meiner Mutter zusammen und es waren sehr viele Leute da in Koblenz. Und da ging es gerade um den Irak, da war man jetzt ziemlich frisch noch unterwegs, in Afghanistan schon länger. Und was mir damals schon aufgehe, war, dass Schollertour immer schon sagte, ja, es geht ja da grundsätzlich um zwei Weltmächte, die sich gegenüberstehen, USA und China. Und es war dann auch so im Publikum oder auch so in der Resonanz auf die Bücher immer so, ja, ja, gut, der redet da auch noch von China und so. Aber eigentlich geht es mir jetzt doch mal hier um das Kleinklein. Was ist denn da jetzt gerade mit den Taliban oder so? Und er hat das immer auf so eine größere Ebene dann gehoben und hat dann im Nachhinein natürlich vollkommen recht behalten, dass es da so entscheidend ist. Und ich glaube, was man ihm dann immer so auch angekreidet hat, war, dass er nicht mit diesen Wertediskussionen kam, weil er sagte, naja, die haben jetzt da vom Westen halt ein Interesse. Wenn es China wächst, dann ist das so und so. Und wenn dann so Leute auch dann fragten danach aus dem Publikum, dann hat er ja auch einfach gesagt, ja, vollkommen naiv. Das kann man nicht so glauben.
Ja, diese Dimension, allein die Fläche, wenn jetzt irgendwo Militärbasen sind und da nochmal 500 und da nochmal 5000 und da nochmal 10.000 Soldaten, macht das halt wirklich keinen Unterschied. Gerade in so zerklüfteten, man lebt ja da nicht urbanisiert irgendwelchen Städten, wo alles fußläufig ist, sondern das ist ja alles. Und da kann man sich einfach nicht vorstellen, wie handlungsunfähig wir eigentlich waren die letzten Jahre, gerade weil wir auch nur Soldaten da hatten. Das war ja nicht so, also man hatte 20 Soldaten, um irgendwie einen Polizisten im Ausbildungsbetrieb da abzusichern. Und das muss man alles in diese Rechnung mit reinnehmen. Wir erholen uns hier aus diesen Nachrichten wirklich nur diese kleinen Halbsätze, die wir mal fielen. Hier mal China, da mal Indien. Roderich Kiesewetter, seines Zeichen möchte gern Außenminister, aber kriegt irgendwie auch nichts auf die Reihe. In der CDU hat hier im Gespräch in den Tagesthemen am 27. auch noch mal kurz China als Begriff fallen lassen.
Und es kann nicht in unserem Interesse sein, dass die Infrastruktur, die wir mit Milliarden aufgebaut haben, jetzt einfach in chinesische Verantwortung übergeht, sondern wir müssen hier partnerschaftlich vor Ort gehen. Und deshalb ist es so wichtig, hier gemeinsam ein Konzept zu entwickeln, das auch die Taliban akzeptieren, denn die brauchen westliches Geld. Sie brauchen auch den Rückhalt in der so zerstörten, kriegsmüden Gesellschaft. Hier ist also viel Arbeit vor allen Dingen Diplomatie und Entwicklungszusammenarbeit gefragt.
Wir können ja jetzt nicht die Infrastruktur, die gebaut wurde, in chinesische Verantwortung übergeben lassen. Aber wenn es ist, wie es ist, wir sehen jetzt, dass einfach mal Sachen sind, wie sie sind, egal wie wir darüber reden. Und trotzdem geht hier so ein Gerede weiter. Das ist auch schon so ein bisschen frustrierend. Ohmit Nouripour für die Grünen Bundestag hat hier auch noch mal kurz, und das spiel ich mal, weil ich interessant finde, dass wir ja eine Billion Dollar und sehr viel Verwaltungsarbeit da reingesteckt haben. Und jetzt kommen aber diese Taliban, von denen wir dachten, das ist so ein wilder Haufen.
Die Taliban haben 20 Jahre gewartet. Jetzt müssen sie nur noch ein, zwei Wochen warten, bis die Amerikaner draußen sind. Und sie vermeiden zurzeit Bilder, die in Washington dazu führen, dass die Diskussion neu beginnt, ob man vielleicht doch bleiben möge oder wieder reinkommt. Ich glaube, die spielen ausschließlich auf Zeit. Und es gibt ja auch eine Generation, weil den Taliban Kommandeuren, eine neue Generation, die auch Druck zum Beispiel von ISIS und anderen auch theologisch weit radikaler aufgewachsen ist als in den 90er Jahren. Ich glaube nicht, dass die jetzt moderater sind als früher. Ich glaube, die sind disziplinierter.
Ja, und die disziplinierten Taliban haben jetzt gegenüber diesen IS, der ja genau weiß, wenn jetzt wieder was passiert, also wenn jetzt einen amerikanischen Soldaten oder einen Deutschen was passiert, dann denken die vielleicht neu drüber nach, ob wir sie jetzt wirklich abziehen. In deren Sicht war dieser Anschlag mit 13 toten amerikanischen Soldaten ja wirklich augenöffnend, weil das war ja der Moment gewesen für die Amerikaner, um zu sagen, ne, das lassen wir uns nicht bieten. Dann stellte sich heraus, das war aber der IS und gar nicht die Taliban. Und irgendwie ist so meine Vermutung, ja, da wollten die IS nochmal ein Zeichen setzen, um auch die Taliban zu ärgern. Also genau das, was die Taliban nicht wollten anrichten.
Also das kann man, komme ich, mit so klaren Strukturen ganz gut verstehen, die sich dann gegenseitig bekriegen. Und man sollte auf keinen Fall in so eine Fantasie abgleiten, wo man sagt, ja, das sind irgendwie Wildgewordene, die da rumrennen, die ihre Zelte jetzt verlassen haben. Das mag irgendwie auf die Fußtruppen dann noch zutreffen. Aber die Köpfe, die dahinterstecken, haben zum Teil doch eine sehr westliche Prägung und haben da Schulen besucht und, und, und. Und haben in internationalen Metropolen gelebt. Das ist keineswegs so, dass man es da mit naiven oder rückständigen zu tun hat, in dem Sinne, wie das manchmal so gerne dargestellt wird.
Genau. Und die haben jetzt erstmal in ihrem Land dann auch wirklich eigene Probleme. Denn Nouripour greift hier schon mal voraus, es werden jetzt sehr viele Konflikte erstmal in Afghanistan ausgetragen.
Ich glaube, dass Afghanistan auf drei Bürgerkriege gleichzeitig zulaufen kann. Einmal der Bürgerkrieg der Interessenmächte, wie sie sie beschrieben haben. Einmal der energihadistische, weil ISIS zum Beispiel und die Taliban einander wirklich hassenblutig. Und einmal wird es Insolgenz geben. Wir sehen es ja jetzt schon, dass es Widerstandsgruppen gibt, gegen die Taliban kämpfen. Jede Entwicklung dieser Art wird aber ohne uns stattfinden, weil wir uns verabschiedet haben aus dem gesamten Spiel.
So, ohne uns wären dort so viele verschiedene Bürgerkriegsszenarien drohen. Das bedeutet natürlich, da sind gerade sehr viele auf der Suche nach Unterstützung und Allianzen und so weiter. Und da liegt es ja wirklich auf der Hand, wenn Indien, China, Pakistanische Mächte da als entsprechende Angebote machen, dass sich dann auch wirklich Kräfteverhältnisse verschieben. Und ich weiß nicht genau, warum der Clip nicht drin war, aber China hofft auf 3 Billionen Rohstoffe dort, wird gesagt. Also in deren Sicht gibt es da auch einiges zu gewinnen. Das wird jetzt nicht... Also es sind sehr viele Interessen.
Ja, ja, also die Rohstoffe sind wohl ganz entscheidend für China. Die haben ja ohnehin Mangel, müssen sehr viel exportieren, was das anbelangt. Und deswegen ist das für die eigentlich strategisch sehr, sehr sinnvoll, dort vertreten zu sein. Man fragt sich auch so ein bisschen, was der Westen eigentlich in den 20 Jahren da gemacht hat in Bezug auf die Rohstoffe. Also hätte man da nicht auch mal eine vernünftige Wirtschaftsinfrastruktur aufbauen können, sodass man auch da international mit dem Kapital ein bisschen mehr Druck aufbauen kann. Sehr, sehr eigenartig, dass das nicht der Fall war.
Ja, da hat man einfach Chancen liegen lassen. Jetzt wäre es ja super wünschenswert, wenn wir in der Lage wären, darüber zu diskutieren. Also auch so öffentlich. Das spielt ja auch wir eine Rolle. Wir haben jetzt gesehen, die Sicherheitsbehörden können nicht so richtig miteinander kommunizieren. Und in deren Sicht ist es, also wir gucken nochmal kurz in so einen Fernsehmoment rein, wo kommentiert wird von Stefan Stuchlik mit diesem Appell, wir bräuchten bessere Diskussionen und so weiter und so fort. Welches Bild er da bemüht und wie weit er da eigentlich ist, auch durch rentnerepublikanisches Mindset.
Die Wahrheit ist, dass wir Deutsche zur Sicherheitspolitik ein Verhältnis haben wie Teenager zur Empfängnisverhütung. Ja, schon mal gehört, sicher gut zu haben, aber reden drüber bitte nicht.
Wenn wir zur Sicherheitspolitik ein Verhältnis hätten, wie die jetzt gerade von Corona und Zukunftsangst und Abschlusssorgen und Arbeitsmarkt und was soll ich studieren usw. geplagten Jugend zur Empfängnisverhütung, die sie mir sehr im Bilde ist. Erstens, was das bedeutet, zweitens, was das mit mir zu tun hat und drittens, was ich tun kann, dann wäre das sehr wünschenswert. Und es ist hier genau so eine Darbietung für so ein rentnerepublikanisches Publikum, das nochmal in seinen Stereotypen irgendwie bestätigt werden möchte.
Von einer Generation, die nur Spaßgesellschaft war und bei der nie einer irgendeinen Auslandseinsatz haben musste, wenn er beim Militär war, sondern höchstens in der Kaserne rumgesessen hat und gehofft hat, dass die Zeit vorbei geht. Also das ist ja alles auch schon hier so Generation. Ich war, ich musste noch hin, aber wir haben da tolle Abende gehabt. Aber da hat man natürlich nicht einen Auslandseinsatz gehabt, beziehungsweise man ging fast zur Bundeswehr auch, weil man wusste, man muss nie weg und ist doch ganz gut alimentiert. Also das ist natürlich im höchsten Maße ärgerlich, so was zu behaupten. Und ja, die ganz jungen Leute denken nicht die ganze Zeit nur über die Sicherheitspolitik nach, aber die anderen ja auch nicht.
Ja, und wenn man so darüber redet, muss man sich nicht wundern, dass in der Politik über andere Themen anders gesprochen wird im Sinne von ich habe keine Kompetenz über mein Publikum was zu sagen und die Politiker haben keine Kompetenz über soldatische Arbeit oder eben das Ausland was zu sagen. Also er hat noch mal die eigene Verblendung dargestellt, in dem Willen anderen ihre Verblendung zu unterstellen. Und da beißt sich so die rentenrepublikanische, ich interessiere mich eigentlich für nichts richtig, aber ich kommentiere mal irgendwas. Katze da in den eigenen Schwanz, das ist wirklich peinlich.
Vor allen Dingen ist dieser Einsatz jetzt nicht daran gescheitert, dass wir so viele Leute haben, die einfach nur naive Pazifisten sind, sondern es ist einfach politisch gescheitert. Also es ist einfach politische Kompetenz war vergeben, wurde aber nicht entsprechend abgerufen. Und damit ist die Sache geklärt. Also es hat gar nichts mit einer gesellschaftlichen Mentalität oder so zu tun, wie ich jetzt zu diesem Einsatz in Afghanistan stehe. Interessiert ja nicht, wenn die da tätig sind. Aber das ist halt eine Frage des politischen Willens. Und man kann natürlich auch mal in Frage stellen, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll war, da hinzugehen.
Nee, stattdessen haben wir einen ganz engen Fokus in der Diskussion. Hier mal ausschnittsweise die normale Berichterstattung, die stattfindet.
Die Taliban haben die Macht in Afghanistan sehr schnell übernommen. So müssen sie regieren und das ist deutlich schwieriger. An diesem Grenzübergang zu Pakistan stauen sich die Lkw. Es gibt kein Durchkommen. Der Handel mit dem Ausland ist zusammengebrochen. Genau darin sehen Experten den einzigen Hebel, die Taliban doch zu politischen Kompromissen zu bewegen.
Die Taliban haben ein Interesse daran, eine internationale Anerkennung zu erfahren. Sie möchten nicht mehr der Paria-Staat sein, der sie in den 1990er Jahren waren. Sie werden auch Wert darauf legen, dass internationale Hilfsorganisationen weiterhin im Land aktiv sind, um eben im Gesundheits- und im Bildungsbereich ihre Projekte voranzubringen.
Die Frage ist nur, ob das ausreichen wird, um das Leben für die Menschen in Afghanistan auch unter einer Taliban-Herrschaft erträglich zu gestalten.
So, das ist so ein bisschen der Modus der Berichterstattung. Jetzt hat Biden gewonnen, kann er das Land einnen? Ich glaube, er würde die Trump-Fehler überzeugen können. Wir haben jetzt verloren gegen die Taliban, aber wer hat es die Taliban denn schaffen? Also im Sinne von, Jett, dann sollen sie doch mal zeigen, was sie können. So, als ob das jetzt die Herausforderung ist. Die Herausforderung ist natürlich, dass die Taliban jetzt selber erst mal gucken müssen, überrascht von, jetzt müssen wir regieren, wie geht regieren, keine Ahnung, Verwaltungsorganisationen, die ganzen Polizisten da irgendwie nach Hause geschickt und so. Und das war ja auch, die sind ja in die Stadt reingelaufen. So wurde es beim Spiegel im Podcast erzählt. Also sie sind in die Stadt reingelaufen, haben dann die Polizisten da irgendwie gesagt, wir sind jetzt da und haben sich dann wieder zurückgezogen. Dann kam es zur Unordnung und dann kam sie als sozusagen neue Sicherheitsmarkt, ihr könnt euch auf uns verlassen, wieder zurück. Und das kann man natürlich für einen Tag so machen und das ist bestimmt auch ein toller Stand, aber das muss jetzt ja Wochen, Monate, Jahre lang durchgehalten werden.
Sie haben doch Autoscooter gefahren.
Ja, also das Öffentliche Leben, was auch immer das heißt.
Taliban sind Autoscooter gefahren, ja.
Muss jetzt irgendwie aufrechterhalten werden. Und die Taliban suchen jetzt wirklich so händeringend nach Unterstützung, weil sie natürlich den Widerstand erfahren, nicht nur vom Ausland, wo auch immer her, sondern auch einfach im Land. Es gibt ja auch Regionen, wo jetzt einfach sich andere Milizen zusammentun und sagen, ne, wir lassen uns hier nicht von den Taliban regieren. Und das wird aber alles nicht beobachtet, sondern hier ist jetzt einfach, ja, dann sollen sie mal zeigen, die Taliban, ob sie es hinkriegen, besser als wir. Jetzt haben wir also in Afghanistan eine unklare Lage, für die wir uns gar nicht interessieren, und hier in Deutschland eigentlich ein nüchterter Soldaten.
Aus dem Bundeswehrverband heißt es, angesichts der Entwicklung in Afghanistan treiben viele Soldaten um die Frage, ob der Verlust an Menschenleben, gescheiterten Ehen und Traumatisierungen den Einsatz in Afghanistan wert gewesen seien. War es das?
Ich glaube, die Frage muss man mit mehreren Aspekten beleuchten. Der Einsatz war auf jeden Fall lohnenswert, weil aus Afghanistan keine terroristische Bedrohung für Westeuropa oder für Europa und den USA seit mehr als einem Jahrzehnt hervorgeht. Also Al-Qaeda wurde zerschlagen, Al-Qaeda wurde vertrieben und von daher war dieser militärische Einsatz sehr erfolgreich. Was den politischen Teil anbelangt, sehen wir jetzt natürlich, dass er krachend gescheitert ist. Und viele Soldatinnen sind frustriert. Sie sind frustriert mit der Art und Weise, wie mit den Ortshelferinnen umgegangen wird. Sie sind aber auch frustriert von Äußerungen, wie zum Beispiel von die des Bundesinnenministers Seehofer, dass die Bundeswehr gescheitert sei in Afghanistan. Das verdeckt die Tatsache, dass Afghanistan ein vernetzter Einsatz der Bundesregierung war. Also wenn jemand gescheitert ist, dann ist es die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und nicht nur die Bundeswehr.
Er ist natürlich jetzt Politikwissenschaftler der Bundeswehr-Universität. Das heißt aber nichts, denn dort arbeiten ganz reguläre Wissenschaftler. Und dieser Verweis auf, wir müssen jetzt besondere Beobachtungen auf die Bundeswehrsoldaten legen, ist natürlich super wichtig. Denn wir haben es da ja schon mit Radikalisierungsproblemen zu tun. Junge Männer, Waffe und so weiter, Organisationen, wie sie halt mal ist in so einer Armee. Und die kommen jetzt zurück, ernüchtert, sehen vielleicht, dass der Einsatz, unter dem sie jetzt seit zehn Jahren leiden, nachdem sie ihn zwei Jahre vor zwölf Jahren oder so gemacht haben, sich auch im Nachhinein wirklich nicht ausgezahlt hat für irgendwen.
Und diese Al-Qaeda-Geschichte, naja, gut, das hätte man auch ohne den ganzen Krieg hinbekommen. Und das machen ja eh Special Forces, das sind ja jetzt nicht die normalen Soldaten, die die Al-Qaeda...
Und das ist auch Zeithorizont 2004 oder so, ne?
Also da reden wir von ganz anderem. Und wenn wir das jetzt mal, du hast gerade gesagt, mit der Radikalisierung der Soldaten, schau dir das in Amerika an. Da hat man jetzt eine Soldatengeneration, die möglicherweise zweimal jetzt gescheitert ist. Also im Irak und jetzt Afghanistan. Und wir alle kennen diese Filme aus den 70er Jahren. Berühmtester Taxi-Driver von den Vietnam-Heimkehrern, die die Sinnlosigkeit des Unterfangens sehen und sich dann radikalisieren. Also das ist nochmal eine ganz brisante Mischung.
Ja, genau. Also in der Hinsicht ist das wirklich schlimm. Und zusätzlich zu dieser Gemengelage hier vor Ort kommt dann noch eine politische Klasse und danehm als nur mal Österreich. Sebastian Kurz hat ja gesagt, bei uns kommt kein einziger Afghaner jetzt als Flüchtling an. Gerald Knaus stellt ja nochmal da, wie weit diese Haltung, die ja auch in Deutschland echt virulent ist unter CDU-Politikern und sowas, 2015 darf sich ja nicht wiederholen. Wie weit das eigentlich das Ansinnen der Taliban stützt?
Da hat Sebastian Kurz, der Kanzler von Österreich, wieder deutlichere Worte gefunden als deutscher Politiker im Moment finden. Er hat gesagt, er will deshalb keine Afghanen ins Land lassen, und zwar überhaupt keine, weil er nicht wolle, dass die Taliban-Ideologie importiert werde. Diese Haltung ist glaube ich auch nicht ganz exklusiv österreichisch.
Also um ganz klar zu sagen, das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn man jene, die aus den kommunistischen Ländern über den Eisernen Vorhang oder über die Berliner Mauer fliehen konnten, zurückschicken will, weil man da den Kommunismus importieren würde. Diese Menschen, um die es jetzt geht, über die wir sprechen, sind ja genau die, die die Taliban hassen, die vor den Taliban flüchten. Die vergleichbare Situation wäre die Situation der Juden in Österreich nach dem Anschluss. Nicht jeder in der Stadt wollte fliehen, aber es gab Menschen, die waren in existenzieller Gefahr. Und so gesehen ist es wichtig, dass wir auch an dem Tag, wenn die Lichter ausgehen am Flughafen in Kabul, wenn die westlichen Flugzeuge nicht mehr fliegen können, dass wir dann auf diese Menschen nicht vergessen.
Ja, und das ist aber auch diese Heiko Maas-Schönheit. Macht es doch alleine. Wir finanzieren euch nichts mehr. Haltung und so. Ja, das ist dieser Vergleich auch mit den DDR-Flüchtlingen so wichtig.
Man glaubt, man straff damit dann nur die Taliban ab. Als sei das dann so damit reglementiert. Aber die anderen hungern ja.
Ja, vor allem, und damit macht man sie auch wirklich zur Spielmasse. Der eigenen Politik.
Die sind ja eh jetzt im Stich gelassen worden. Die haben da diese komische Operettenregierung gehabt. Also das ist ja nun jetzt nichts, wo man sagen kann, da hat man sich jetzt von der besten Seite gezeigt.
Wenn ihr denkt, ihr wurdet von uns im Stich gelassen, zeigen wir euch mal, wie euch die Taliban im Stich lassen. Das ist so ein ganz gekränkter Zynismus, der da bei rumkommt. Der Ausklang dieser ganzen Thematik, denn ich glaube nicht, dass uns Afghanistan hier noch in den Massenmedien groß, außer jetzt nochmal zum Jahreswechsel oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber eigentlich will man dieses, also es braucht Anlässe, sagen wir es mal so. Und die wird es jetzt wenig geben, da man sich ja um die eigentliche Gemengelage da wenig interessiert. Und diesen Sing-Sang in den Nachrichten zu hören, ist wirklich auch ein bisschen krass. Aber hier wird mal die Zeitenwende vorgeführt. Klaus Geleber moderiert zum Beispiel ganz gut zum Thema Rückzug.
Nun also der Rückzug für Strategen seit Jahrtausenden, die schwierigste aller militärischen Unternehmungen. Dieser Abzug aus Kabul gerät quasi live zur täglichen Demütigung der größten Militärallianz der Geschichte. Die Bilder sagen alle nichts, wird bleiben, was die sogenannte Weltgemeinschaft hier versucht hat. Mit Unsummen von Geld unter Einsatz und Verlust. Unzähliger Menschenleben. Die neuen Herren des Landes befehlen, raus mit euch und setzen ihre Fristen.
Also hier schon Handlungsmöglichkeiten Null. Und jetzt nochmal bezogen auf einen spezifischen Punkt, den Biden entscheiden musste.
Wer noch Beweis dafür brauchte, wie grundlegend sich Machtverhältnisse verschoben haben, der bekam ihn heute. Europa hatte gebettelt, dass US-Truppen in Kabul noch ein bisschen länger die Stellung halten. Die Taliban bestanden darauf, dass sie pünktlich verschwinden. Amerika musste sich entscheiden und entschied sich für die Taliban.
Biden musste sich entscheiden und hat sich nicht mehr die Taliban entschieden. Michael Stempfle kommentiert das hier auch entsprechend.
Deutschland hat sich bereit erklärt, an der Seite der USA in Afghanistan zu kämpfen. Und jetzt ist nicht nur ein Militäreinsatz gescheitert, sondern der Westen insgesamt.
Wenn man dann Merkel im Bundestag hört, ich hab mir auch die ganze Rede angehört, da kam nichts Klippbares bei rum. Das war einfach nur so ein, weiß auch nicht. Und da ist dieser Clip hier ganz beispielhaft. Im Grunde sagt sie hier, wir haben so lange wie möglich versucht, uns das Scheitern nicht eingestehen zu müssen.
Hätte Deutschland die Mitarbeiter von Hilfsorganisationen bereits im Frühjahr abgezogen?
Manche hätten sie sicher als vorausschauende Vorsicht gewürdigt. Andere dagegen als eine Haltung abgelehnt, mit der die Menschen in Afghanistan im Stich gelassen und ihrem Schicksal überlassen werden. Hinterher im Nachhinein präzise Analysen und Bewertungen zu machen, das ist nicht wirklich kompliziert.
Na ja, also es gab ja offenbar Infos, die Linke und Grüne hatten und die durchaus wussten, wie sich das entwickeln wird. Jetzt haben nicht alle das auf den Tag datieren können und wahrscheinlich waren auch die, die Cassandra-artig waren, etwas überrascht, wie schnell es dann ging. Aber dass das jetzt so der Fall sein würde, das war ja klar. Was hat man dann gedacht, dass da sich eine schöne Regionalregierung noch mal bildet aus Künstlerinnen und Intellektuellen oder was? Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie man dieser Ansicht nicht gewesen sein konnte.
Also August war natürlich sehr früh für viele überraschend, aber bis Weihnachten wäre das genau die Entwicklung gewesen.
Und dann hat man das jetzt noch gemacht. Die neue Regierung muss sich damit Afghanistan nicht mehr rumschlagen. Und wie du sagst, es wird nicht in den Medien mehr stattfinden. Es ist der Jahresrückblick, der das noch mal kurz auffängt. Und all diese Worte, wir dürfen die jetzt im Land nicht vergessen, kann man noch mal aussprechen. Aber die Tatsache ist natürlich, werden sie vergessen werden.
Genau, also wir haben noch so ein paar Entwicklungshelfer vor Ort. Aber im Grunde wird es keine mitbekommen.
Ja, aber auch schon vorher da waren. Also das ist das Interessante, was Willemsen ja immer wieder sagte.
Ja, genau, also da spielte die deutsche politische Sache da kaum eine Rolle. Und irgendwer muss reportieren, wenn in Städten jetzt Terroranschläge sind oder so. Im Bagnat hat man das immer wieder reportiert bekommen, weil da eben Amerikaner dann doch vor Ort waren und so. Aber jetzt in Afghanistan kann es auch ganz schnell ganz still werden. Das meinen da gar nicht mehr mitbekommen. AKK ist hier am Heudejournal und versucht gleich mal wieder so dieses, ja gut, sind wir jetzt gescheitert, gehen wir jetzt mal den nächsten Schritt, nachdem sich Biden für die Taliban entschieden hat und nicht für uns. Aber das ist wirklich, man versucht einfach so zur Tagesordnung überzugehen.
Aber die Frage, die sich über diesen Einsatz hinaus stellen wird, ist in der Tat, wie selbstständig können wir eigentlich in der NATO und als Europäer ohne die Amerikaner agieren, wenn man das für sich will? Wenn man das beantworten will, dann muss man dafür aber auch konkret den Preis bezahlen, etwa in Form von Haushaltsmitteln, in Form von Ausstattung, in Form von mehr Personal.
Ja, ganz entsetzlich, was ihr da sagt. Wir wissen, wir haben im Salon damals dieses riesen Macron-Interview besprochen, wo er sagt, was AKK da vorhat, dass das einfach wieder so eine ganz tolle Allianz mit den Amerikanern wird, das hält er für eine historische Fehlinterpretation. So hat er sich damals ausgedrückt und jetzt sagt sie irgendwie, ach so, wenn wir das jetzt wollen, dann liegt es am Geld.
Ich lese das sogar noch viel schlimmer, was sie hier sagt. Im Grunde verfällt sie ja gerade zurück in dies, ach ja, ich bin ja die Ministerin, was ist meine Aufgabe? Ach ja, dem Bundesfinanzminister besonders viel Budget fürs Verteidigungsministerium rauszuangeln. Also nutze ich jetzt mal die Gelegenheit, wo die Amerikaner uns jetzt auch noch verlassen und wir einen Krieg verloren haben, zu sagen, ja, wenn man das will, dann muss man aber am Bundestag sagen, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt mehr Geld braucht. Und ich finde, das ist jetzt nicht die Zeit, um über Bundeswehr-Budgets zu denken. Sondern jetzt braucht es wirklich mal eine Idee, kriegen wir jetzt Europa noch, wie soll man sagen, ich glaube, wirklich Verteidigung ist nicht notwendig, aber diese, wie wurde das jetzt immer genannt, weltpolitikfähig oder sowas?
Ja, die Frage ist halt, ob es interventionistisch oder nicht sein soll. Also die Grünen wollen ja dann in und wieder mehr Interventionismus, die Linken nicht, das ist ja auch der Grund, oder zumindest wird das immer vorgegaukelt, dass das der Grund sei, warum die nicht koalieren können oder so. Aber das muss man sich dann sehr genau fragen, ob das überhaupt noch funktionieren könnte. Also ich mein, Geld wurde ja nun jetzt, das haben wir ja gerade gehört, richtig ausgegeben. Wie viel? Man muss sagen, das nächste Mal müssen es zwei Billionen sein.
Roderich Kiesewetter versucht hier nochmal, Schuldige zu finden. Wir brauchen ja Schuldige.
Nun, ich sehe hier insbesondere auch den Zusammenhalt des Bündnisses als wesentlichen Punkt, denn die Amerikaner haben dies unter Trump selbst verursacht, dass die Taliban nun die Macht übernommen haben.
Trump war schuld.
Trump war schuld. Das ist natürlich totaler Unsinn.
2016 plötzlich, es lief so gut, weißt du, plötzlich zack.
Ja, doof, dass Trump nicht mehr da ist jetzt in den nächsten Jahren.
Das ist wirklich doof für die. Also Trump ist schuld, AKK möchte gerne mehr Geld für ihr, für ihre Zuständigkeit im Verteidigungsministerium. Es ist wirklich ganz runtergedampft auf die ganz kleinen deutschen Lichtchen. Roderich Kiesewetter macht hier, das gucken wir als letzten Clip, zumindest noch diesen einen Punkt. Aber wir wissen genau, never.
Entscheidend ist, dass wir jetzt aus der Krise hier lernen. Alle unsere Einsätze müssen auf den Prüfstand. Wir müssen immer auch ein Konzept für die Evakuierung von Ortskräften und unserer eigenen Soldaten haben. Und das ist mir der wichtigste Punkt, eine bestmöglich ausgestattete Bundeswehr, die auch bei Eskalationen handlungsfähig bleibt.
So, alle Einsätze müssen auf den Prüfstand. Glaubt wirklich irgendwer, dass irgendwer sich jetzt Mali mal genau anschaut oder so? Wer da was tut und was da geht?
Ich noch im September vor der Wahl wahrscheinlich.
Das ist so schlimm.
Es ist sehr schlimm und ich glaube, wir müssen, weil wir jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten haben, es spontan zu historisieren, müssen wir aber deutlich machen, hier ist die große Neue Zwanzigerentwicklung. Der Westen zieht sich zurück. China-Pakistan-Allianz wird entscheidend werden, wie sich Indien dazu verhält. Man weiß immer noch nicht, was die da eigentlich so global wirtschaftlich vorhaben. Ist sicherlich ein großes Thema. China aber hat viele Verbündete, hat ja gute Kontakte inzwischen zu Israel, was für den Westen immer ganz entscheidend natürlich ist. Für Israel auch immer wichtig war, den Kontakt zum Westen zu haben. Das geht enger zusammen. Und China ist in Brasilien extrem aktiv. Ich glaube mittlerweile sind die da mehr vertreten als der Westen, was Investitionen anbelangt. Also ganz erstaunlich. Und das ist also die Historisierung, die wir vornehmen können. Und wir können aber auch nochmal den Blick zurück machen. Und ich habe ein Gedicht mitgebracht, das du vielleicht kennst von Theodor Fontane. Geschrieben hat das 1859. Das Gedicht heißt Das Trauerspiel von Afghanistan. Dieses Gedicht bezieht sich auf den Januar 1842. Und da war es so, dass die britische Krone ja schon mal versucht hatte, Nation Building in Afghanistan zu betreiben. Und es war so, dass 12.000 Zivilisten, 690 britische und 2.840 indische Soldaten hatten den Rückzug angetreten aus Kabul. Sie ziehen sich also auch zurück wie damals. Und man wollte dann nach Jalalabad, 140 Kilometer weit gelegen und versuchte dort dann unterzukommen. Aber dieser Rückzug scheiterte noch stärker als das, was wir jetzt hier gesehen haben mit Leuten, die an Flugzeugträgern hängen und so weiter. Also dieses Gedicht jetzt von Fontane. Der Schnee leisstäubend vom Himmel fällt, ein Reiter vor Jalalabad hält. Wer da? Ein britischer Reitersmann bringe Botschaft aus Afghanistan. Afghanistan, er sprach es so matt, es umdrängt den Reiter die halbe Stadt. Sir Robert Sale, der Kommandant, hebt ihn vom Rosse mit eigener Hand. Sie führen ins steinerne Wachthaus ihn. Sie setzen ihn nieder an den Kamin. Wie wärmt ihn das Feuer, wie labt ihn das Licht, er atmet hoch auf und dankt und spricht. Wir waren 13.000 Mann, von Kabul unser Zug begann, Soldaten, Führer, Weib und Kind erstarrt, erschlagen, verraten sind. Zersprengt ist unser ganzes Heer, was lebt ihr draußen in der Nacht umher? Mir hat ein Gott die Rettung gegönnt, seht zu, ob den Rest ihr retten könnt. Sir Robert stieg auf den Festungswall, Offiziere, Soldaten folgten ihm all. Sir Robert sprach, der Schnee fällt dicht, die uns suchen, sie können uns finden nicht. Sie irren wie Blinde und sind uns so nah, so lasst sie's hören, dass wir da, stimmt an ein Lied von Heimat und Haus, vom Peter Blas in die Nacht hinaus. Da huben sie an und sie wurden's nicht müde, durch die Nacht hin klang es Lied um Lied, erst englische Lieder mit fröhlichem Klang, dann Hochlandslieder wie Klagegesang. Sie bliesen die Nacht und über den Tag, laut wie nur die Liebe rufen mag, sie bliesen, es kam die zweite Nacht, umsonst, dass ihr ruft, umsonst, dass ihr wacht. Die hören sollen, sie hören nicht mehr, vernichtet ist das Ganze her. Mit 13.000 der Zug begann, einer kam heim aus Afghanistan.
Äh ja, andere Zeiten, andere Maßstäbe. Hier wird ja betont, 59 Soldaten sind gestorben. Das ist natürlich nicht besonders viel für 20 Jahre Krieg.
Hier kommt einer, das war das Dr. William Brydon, ein junger Militärarzt. Der hatte es tatsächlich als Einziger geschafft, das zu reportieren.
Ja, in der Ansicht gab es historisch immer schon krassere Niederlagen.
Und Afghanistan ist ein für den Westen schwieriges Terra. Kann man daraus auch schließen.
Und man kann glaube ich nochmal sagen, es gibt ja diesen Spruch, in dem Ridley Scott auch Black Hawk Down beginnt, von Platon oder so. Nur die Toten haben das Ende des Krieges gesehen. Und da muss man natürlich immer sagen, ja das stimmt wahrscheinlich nur heute, wo wir Kriege nicht mehr hinsichtlich Vernichtung führen, sondern Eroberung, Command in Konga, ist es dann umso mehr, dass man sich von so einer alten Idee im Krieg, im Krieg wird dann verloren, wenn alle sterben, wechselt zu diesen Machtverhältnissen, die da irgendwie sich abspielen. Und da ist noch einiges zu lernen, gerade für deutsche Journalisten, um sich mal so Gemengelagen wirklich anzuschauen, weil das wir jetzt, nachdem es so lange vorbereitet wurde, dieses pazifische Zeitalter, das pazifische Jahrhundert, tatsächlich so einen krassen Shift erleben, wo ja Afghanistan eigentlich auch nur noch so eine Schifre ist, so ein Ereignis in so einem großen Schiff, der da stattfindet. Und wir dann so darüber reden und uns diese große Dimension so ganz nicht interessiert. Und wir dann noch Roderich Kiesewetter irgendwie so ein komisches Zeug reden hören. Das macht einen wirklich ein bisschen Sorgen, ob wir noch auf der Höhe der Zeit sind in unseren alten Ländern hier.
Ja, Joe Biden hat uns jetzt enttäuscht in seinen Reaktionen. Ich habe den Clip nicht mitgebracht, aber es ist vom selben Auftritt, den wir jetzt gleich hören werden. Am Ende dieser Rede, die hält er vor, Arbeitern von so einer Truckfabrik. Er ist da unterwegs und versucht, den jetzt klar zu machen, wie er die amerikanische Wirtschaft retten will. Da sagt er am Ende nochmal dieser Rede, es gibt das Einmalige von Amerika. Bei uns beruht das alles auf einer Idee, auf Gleichheit, Pursuit of Happiness und so. Das stimmt ja also, dass man nicht eine ethnische oder rassische Idee hat. Also eigentlich so ist es angelegt. Und das macht er dann nochmal deutlich und versucht damit auch nochmal so einen Universalismus zu begründen. Aber dieser Universalismus, dann ist außenpolitisch tatsächlich etwas, was da gescheitert ist. Aber es soll jetzt darum nicht gehen, sondern wir wollen uns jetzt mal beschäftigen mit Lieferengpässen. Das ist schon immer mal wieder hier kurz aufgetaucht in unseren Folgen. Aber jetzt ist es wirklich ganz verrückt. Also wenn man das einfach mal so hört in Zahlen. VW Stammwerk kann nach der Sommerpause nur eingeschränkt anlaufen. Haben jetzt Kurzarbeit beantragt. Audi, 10.000 Beschäftigte müssen den Sommerurlaub verlängern. Kurzarbeit beantragt. Audi konnte im ersten Halbjahr 50.000 Fahrzeuge nicht bauen. Was fehlte? Halbleiter. BMW und Daimler? Kurzarbeit immer wieder. BMW hätte dieses Jahr bis zu 90.000 Autos mehr verkaufen können. Aber die Lieferengpässe machen es nicht möglich. Jetzt haben wir den Brexit. Da hat man ja von Boris Johnson diesen Satz gehört. Britain will prosper mightily after Brexit. Und dann hat jetzt mal Paul Johnson vom Guardian mal gesagt, so McDonalds hat keine Milchshakes, Nando hat keine Hühner. Dann gibt es bei den ganzen Nahrungsmittel-Exporten große Probleme zur EU. Dann fehlen Lkw-Fahrer und zwar 90.000. Es wird nicht geerntet auf den Feldern. Da verrottet Ernte auf den Feldern. Das hat er nur mal kurz bei Twitter aufgelistet, was da eigentlich los ist. Jetzt machen wir aber erst mal so eine Klammer auf. Nämlich gehen wir zu Biden, der seine Wirtschaftspolitik eigentlich in den Fußstapfen von Donald Trump fortsetzt. Denn wir haben bei Trump immer gehört, schlimm dieser Protektionismus. Aber jetzt hören wir mal, was Biden hier den Arbeitern verkündet. Die Lieferketten, die kritischen, die jetzt durch Corona besonders kritisch geworden ist, will man also jetzt stärken und es soll mehr im eigenen Land geschehen. Und er bringt es dann nochmal ganz kurz auf den Punkt.
Frank Rieger hat immer den schönen Spruch gemacht, Just in Time Lieferung heißt eigentlich Out of Stock. Also ich hab es nicht im Lager. Und da reicht es ja wirklich, wenn so ein Schiff quer steht im Suezkanal oder Corona oder sonst irgendwas. Allein der Lockdown von Wuhan hätte ja schon einiges verursacht. Dann kam noch alles hinten dran. Und das ist wirklich bezeichnend. Die Liste, die du gerade vorgelesen hast mit der Halbleitersache, das nochmal verglichen mit angenommen. Der deutsche Staat würde die Unternehmen so im Stich lassen, wie die Mieter, die auch sagen, ich kriege gerade keine Halbleiter-Lieferungen, ich darf gerade nicht arbeiten, ich kann keinen Umsatz machen, ich kann keine Miete zahlen. Die kriegen aber sofort das Kurzarbeitergeld. Und wahrscheinlich wäre es im Sinne eines ganz harten ökonomischen Arguments im Stil von Lars Feld hier wirklich angebracht politisch zu fordern, wenn Strukturwandel passiert, dann muss man das die Unternehmen auch spüren lassen, sodass sie handeln. Und dann bräuchte es nämlich nicht solche Joe-Biden-Anmerkungen, wie mach das mal, sondern dann wären die Unternehmen selber drauf. Und das sehen wir gerade bei den Batterien. In Deutschland eine Batteriefabrik neben der anderen entsteht gerade. Also so, dass man wirklich sagt, in zwei, drei Jahren haben wir diesen Bedarf gedeckt. Es sind Millionen Autos, die hergestellt werden müssen und dann machen wir das, weil wir festgestellt haben, erstens der technologische Wandel kommt nicht. Auch wir müssen jetzt in Lithium, Ionen und so weiter gehen. Es wird keine nächste Technologie geben, auf die wir dann warten können. Und dieses Ganze, wir lassen es uns zuliefern aus Asien, klappt nicht, wenn ein Unternehmen hundert Unternehmen beliefert, weil dann einfach klar ist, dann kommt Joe Biden und sichert erstmal seine Lieferketten und dann werden erstmal alle Amerikaner versorgt, wie wir das bei den Masken und so 2020 erlebt haben. Und dass wir da so ins Hintertreffen geraten sind bei Chips.
Und es sind ja nicht diese super komplizierten 5 Nanometer, da kommen wir gleich zu diesen komplizierten Chips und den einfachen Chips und wer die eigentlich produzieren will. Also, Buy American, das ist jetzt der Slogan. Wenn das Trump gemacht hätte, hätte man gesagt übler Propäktionismus. Aber hier wird es ganz offen gesagt. Und es wird auch rückgebunden an die amerikanische Geschichte. Biden geht zurück ins Jahr 1933, da war Hoover Präsident. Und da gab es den Buy American Act.
Die meisten wissen nicht, dass es seit fast einem Jahr eine法 auf den Büchern in Amerika gibt, die die Buy America Act ist.
Also, US-Unternehmen erhalten Regierungsauftrag. Und dann gibt es diesen Buy American Act, das 55 Prozent dieser Komponenten in den Produkten, die geordert werden, aus Amerika sind. Das heißt, das sind nicht rein amerikanische Produkte, aber es geht jetzt nicht so, dass man, weiß ich nicht, ein Auto bestellt und nur noch die Reifen sind amerikanisch und der Rest kommt aus China. Biden sagt aber, das reicht ihm eigentlich nicht. Also diese 55 Prozent von 1933, gut schön, aber da muss man eigentlich noch weiter gehen.
Und heute werden wir weitergehen.
55% ist das wirklich substanziell.
Aber das ist interessant, weil er ja so drauf verwies, das spielt sich dann so ein und bedeutet heute das und das. Das heißt natürlich auch bei solchen Gesetzen immer, dass man seine Lieferkette kennen muss. Und da ist natürlich auch nicht uninteressant, dass da jetzt mal so eine Datenerhebung stattfindet.
Wir haben ja bei den Lieferketten hier bei der Diskussion gesehen, Altmaier will da eigentlich beide Augen zudrücken und will da gar nichts von wissen. Biden macht hier bezogen auf dieses protektionistische Bestreben eine andere Ankündigung. Und das hat mir natürlich als Western-Fan sehr gefallen. Ja, der neue Sheriff in town, das quält mir natürlich sehr gut. Und 55 Prozent reichen nicht. Was will Biden?
Ich finde das ja sehr gut. Irgendwann sind Länder groß genug, um sich einfach selbst zu versorgen. Und dieses ganze Globalisierungsding wurde vielleicht wirklich ein bisschen zu weit getrieben, schon allein, weil es so wenig Sinn macht, Milchpulver durch die ganze Welt zu fahren und so.
Also das sind Centbeträge, die am Ende noch gespart werden. Oder es sind irgendwelche tollen Geschäfte für irgendwelche Zwischenhändler. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so, dass wir als Konsumenten jetzt sagen können, Gott sei Dank deshalb ist das so billig. Das mag für einige wenige Produkte gelten. Und es gibt ja auch Sachen, die man einfach hier nicht bekommen kann. Irgendwelche Gewürze oder so, die kann ich jetzt nicht anbauen hier nebenan in Frankfurt. Aber das gilt natürlich für vieles nicht, ist aber eine gute Möglichkeit, um Geld zu verdienen. Und worum es ihm geht, macht er dann hier noch mal deutlich. Also resiliente Lieferketten. Und auch da will er nochmal ganz klar mit den Chips anders vorgehen.
Als 2011 oder 2012 Steve Jobs starb, haben wir alle gedacht, oh Gott, das war es jetzt mit Apple und so. Und dann hat ja Tim Cook eine der größten Unternehmensgeschichten überhaupt geschrieben. Seitdem hat das Unternehmen noch mal im Wert grandios und mehrere Faktoren gesteigert, neue Produkte auf den Markt gebracht. Und Steve Jobs galt ja immer als der Marketing-King, der ja neben sich dann immer Leute hatten, die dann eigentlich die Software entwickelten und den ganzen Kram. Und dann hat man, also das war ja so der Zeitpunkt, wo man dachte, Marketing ist alles. Also wie bei den Schuhen und so weiter. Wenn es nur geil leuchtet und so, Marketing ist alles, dann machen wir hier so ein Drop und dann kaufen das die Leute und stehen Schlange und so. Und jetzt muss man ja diese Apple-Geschichte nochmal ganz neu erzählen mit Tim Cook, dass man einfach sagt, derjenige, der es verstanden hat, Lieferketten zu organisieren. Und bei Tim Cook ging es halt wirklich darum, dass Donald Trump ihn gefragt hat, warum werden die iPhones nicht hierhergestellt? Na der hat Tim Cook gesagt, wir brauchen dafür eine Million Leute und das ist auch nicht einfach nur ein Auftrag, den wir vergeben, sondern die Lieferketten müssen richtig designt werden. Hier braucht es Skills, die Leute müssen ausgebildet werden, Arbeitszeit muss organisiert werden, die Familien, die drum umleben müssen organisiert werden, muss alles organisiert werden. Und eigentlich müsste man jetzt nochmal, nachdem man diese Steve Jobs Geschichte von Apple erzählt hat, nochmal diese Tim Cook Geschichte von Apple erzählen, wo so ganz nüchtern, ohne dieses ganze Trara und das Book Cover ist toll gestaltet und so nochmal erklärt wird, wie man sich erstens von der eigenen Design Abteilung verabschiedet. Die haben ja den, wie hieß er, ein Dingster-Bums-Chef-Designer da, der arbeitet ja nicht mehr für Apple, sondern ist jetzt ein freies Büro, also einfach ausgegliedert und dafür aber diese krasse, ganz nüchterne Organisierung globaler Lieferketten. Bis hin zu, wir halten das super geheim, was wir als nächstes Produkt haben, haben wir aber schon 5 Millionen davon auf Halde. Und dann schimpfen wir das über die Welt, ohne dass irgendwer weiß, in welchem Container eigentlich und so. Und diese krasse amerikanische Gefolgsgeschichte von Tim Cook, der letzten 10 Jahre Apple, um die geht es Joe Biden hier eigentlich. Eigentlich müsste er ihn so an seine Seite holen und sagen, das ist mein neuer Chefberater beim Thema Lieferketten oder so.
Und die Frage ist ja, ob wir dann wirklich so eine Lokalisierung oder Klokalisierung, wird das ja dann auch gerne genannt, also so ein Neologismus aus Globalisierung und Lokalisierung, ob wir das wirklich erleben jetzt, also ob diese Lieferketten da zurückgebaut werden. Also mit den Chips ist ja so eine Sache. Taiwan ist sehr wichtig für die Chip-Produktion. Und was haben die gemacht? Die haben Chips angeboten gegen Impfstoff. Woraufhin dann Japan 1, 2 Millionen AstraZeneca-Dosen bot, Washington 2, 2 Millionen Dosen.
Die Moderna-Lieferung haben wir ja gesehen.
Die haben wir ja gesehen. Und jetzt hat dann Taiwan nochmal TSMC und Foxconn beauftragt, über 10 Millionen Dosen Biontech zu verhandeln. Also die sollen das jetzt mal machen. Das ist jetzt nur noch ein Tauschgeschäft. Ganz interessant. Und dieses Just-in-time-Ding ist ja bei den Ship-Produktionen halt jetzt so eine Sache. Die Herstellung eines Mikroships, und deswegen verzögert sich das alles jetzt noch viel, viel mehr, dauert, das habe ich alles jetzt nachgelesen, in einem neuen Aufsatz, in einem neuen Artikel von Yevgeny Morozov, den er bei Le Monde Diplomatique veröffentlicht hat. Die Herstellung eines Mikroships dauert mehrere Monate. Also Mikroship bedeutet dann 1000 Arbeitsschritte und mehr. Und Corona ist auch nicht der einzige Grund für die Engpässe, sagt er, sondern es gab eine Kältewellen in Texas, da werden die meisten Mikroships in USA produziert. Wasserknappheit in Taiwan hat es auch problematisch gemacht. Fabrik brandt in Japan. Suez-Kanal-Blockade. Und dann noch die Hamsterkäufe chinesischer Firmen, weil die gesagt haben, jetzt müssen wir aber dringend ran. So sehr, dass Musk ja jetzt auch darüber nachdenkt, nicht mehr Just-in-Time zu gehen, sondern Chips zu bevorraten. Also wieder Lagehaltung zu machen. Du hast ja eben gesagt, das Zitator von Frank Krieger, Just-in-Time war wie? Ist out of stock. Out of stock? Ja, das ist ganz schön. Wo ist eigentlich das Lager, wenn man sich mal ansieht? 85 Prozent des Transports in Deutschland findet auf der Autobahn statt mit LKWs. Das sind die Lager. Das sind die fahrenden Lager. Und das ist dann Just-in-Time. Ich habe eine Zahl, die ich so verrückt fand. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich sie jetzt noch hier habe. Ja, genau. Was das eigentlich kostet. Also diese Staus, die das produziert hast, Handelsblatt mal aufgeschrieben. Gerechnet in verlorener Arbeitszeit verursachen die Staus jährlich mindestens 60 bis 100 Milliarden Euro Zusatzkosten. Und dann gibt es ja nochmal volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden, in besonders Umweltverpestung und so weiter. Und die sagen über die Autobahnparkplätze, das sind inzwischen öffentlich finanziert, der öffentlich finanzierte Ersatz für die eingesparten Lagerhallen.
Ja, bei den Mikroökonomen gab es kürzlich, also schon vor ein paar Wochen, mal so eine kurze Thematisierung von Zwischenhändlern, in dem du nämlich sagst, ich verkaufe gar nicht an den Endverbraucher, also im Sinne von du stellst irgendwelche Chips her in Taiwan und lieferst sie dann. Die taiwanisischen Chipphersteller verkaufen ja an die deutschen Zulieferer für die Autos und so weiter und die Autohersteller. Aber was ist eigentlich, wenn die an die Lieferanten verkaufen und die Lieferanten dann wieder verkaufen, wenn sie angekommen sind? Und diese Lager, mobilen Lager dazwischen, diese Zeit, die das auch kostet, wenn die nochmal für sich selber ökonomisch ausgebeutet wird. Und da ist erhebliches Potenzial drin, dass man da so eine quasi Abidrage zwischen diesen zwei Handelsorten, Verkäufer und Käufer, wie vorhin auch schon in Ulm, wenn die Stadt einfach, nur weil die Stadt das macht, als Zwischenhänder tätig zu werden, können die ja dieses politisch gewollte ökonomische Potenzial mobilisieren und dann sagen, wir machen es jetzt so und so. Und so gewinnen auch diese Transporteure immer mehr Macht, wenn sie denn tatsächlich ein Kauf und Verkauf nochmal dazwischen hängen. Also muss man Lieferketten echt nochmal richtig ernst nehmen. Das ist nicht nur die Lieferketten, sondern die Lieferkette selbst nochmal für sich eigene Wertschöpfungstöpfe da aufmacht, nur weil geliefert wird.
Ja, ob diese US-Chip-Produktion wirklich so erfolgreich sein kann, also Morozov bezweifelt das ja. Er sagt erst mal, ist ja die Produktion von US-Chips gefallen. Wenn man sich ansieht, von 1990 bis heute ist es gefallen von 37 auf 12 Prozent, diese Ship-Produktion. Und man hat auch die marginschwachen Produktionen ins Ausland verlagert. Jetzt versucht man die irgendwie wieder zurückzuholen. In China werden mehr Shipfabriken errichtet als irgendwo sonst in der Welt gerade. Es gibt 1000 offizielle Förderprogramme, 180 Milliarden Dollar hat man da reingesteckt. Man muss aber auch gerade für 350 Milliarden Dollar Ships exportieren, was natürlich auch nicht ohne ist. Jetzt investiert Amerika 52 Milliarden Dollar und dann sagt aber auch Morozov, ja das klingt erstmal viel, aber Südkorea, die investieren in den nächsten zehn Jahren 450 Milliarden Dollar. Ja, dann sieht man das. So und dazwischen ist dann noch die EU. Wir hören uns jetzt erstmal von ARD-Korrespondent Steffen Wurzel etwas an über die Shipproduktion und so weiter, wie das mit China und den USA zusammenhängt.
Nicht nur der Konflikt zwischen China und den USA ist schuld am weltweiten Computer-Chip-Mangel, auch die coronabedingten Lieferkettenprobleme setzen der Halbleiterindustrie weltweit zu. Zusätzlich sorgte ein Großbrand in einer Chipfabrik in Japan und die Wasserknappheit in Taiwan im Frühjahr dafür, dass wichtige Chipproduzenten teilweise nicht produzieren konnten. Wie sehr Geopolitik inzwischen eine Rolle spielt in der weltweiten Computer-Chip-Krise, zeigt der Fall ASML. Das niederländische Unternehmen baut Spezialmaschinen für die Hightech-Computer-Chip-Industrie. Auf Druck der US-Regierung beliefert ASML chinesische Firmen nicht mehr, zumindest nicht mit den besten und modernsten Maschinen zur Chipherstellung. Damit wird es für Chinas Halbleiterindustrie zunehmend schwieriger, vollständig unabhängig zu werden vom Rest der Welt. Am Ziel der sogenannten Chip-Autarkie hält die Staats- und Parteiführung allerdings fest, sie will China mittel- bis langfristig unabhängig machen von Herstellern aus anderen Teilen der Welt.
Was wir jetzt erleben, ist eigentlich so eine Wiederkehr des vergangenen Jahres. Da hatten wir das erst mit den Masken, dann haben wir das mit den Impfstoffen. Das ist ja auch immer noch ein Problem, das existent ist jetzt für andere Länder. Und jetzt sehen wir, dass aber bei dieser Chip-Geschichte wird das eine so große Sache werden, dass man da sich jetzt mit über Jahre beschäftigen muss, wie man das eigentlich in den Griff bekommt. Und die EU hatte auch Ambitionen. Thierry Préton hat ja da die Idee, dass man 20 Prozent der Halbleiterproduktion der Welt bis 2030 in Europa haben will. Und nun ist es ja so, dass man so Chips und Chips hat. Du hast es ja schon angesprochen, es gibt da ja ganz feine, ganz feinkliedrige Chips. Und Morozov, das ist das Gute bei Le Monde Diplomatiek, die lesen manchmal auch Artikel vor. Morozov schätzt das jetzt mal ein, was die EU davor hat.
Die meisten europäischen Unternehmen behaupten sich gut, da die Nachfrage seitens des Automobilsektors weiter anhält. Die im Fahrzeugbau verwendeten Mikroprozessoren sind allerdings nicht das neueste vom neuesten. Nachdem Europa seine Ambition aufgegeben hat, mit Apple und Samsung bei der Tablet- und Smartphoneproduktion zu konkurrieren, ist keineswegs gesichert, dass es eine stabile europäische Nachfrage nach Logicships der neuesten Generation mit den feinsten Strukturgrößen gibt. Wenn es aber in Europa keine Nachfrage gibt, stellt sich die Frage, warum die multinationalen Konzerne ihre Produktionslinien dort bauen sollten, wo sie höhere Löhne als in Asien zahlen müssten. Es ist schwer vorstellbar, dass US-Unternehmen alles daran setzen, ihre Komponenten in Dresden statt in Taipei fertigen zu lassen. Darum haben die Verlautbarungen von EU-Kommissar Breton, wie nicht anders zu erwarten, bei den europäischen Ship-Giganten keine Begeisterungsstürme ausgelöst. Breton bleibt dennoch überzeugt. Die EU hat die Mission, die Technologien zu entwickeln, die zwei Nano-Ships möglich machen, auch wenn es hier bisher noch keinen Markt dafür gibt. Das grenzt an magisches Denken.
Ich kann es ja mal versuchen, aber Morozov gibt der EU noch mal am Ende einen mit.
Der Abhängigkeit Europas, wenn es um Halbleiter geht, liegt ein viel grundsätzlicheres Problem zugrunde, das sich mit Finanzspritzen allein nicht aus der Welt schaffen lässt. Europa ist nämlich, nachdem es seine Verteidigung an das Pentagon und seine Industriestrategie an seine Autohersteller outgesourct hat, gar nicht mehr fähig, seine Elektronikproduktion strategisch zu planen. Die Wette, dass der technologische Apparat, der die europäische Wirtschaft am Laufen hält, nicht den Gesetzen des Marktes unterworfen und von den geopolitischen Herausforderungen abgekoppelt sei, hat sich als hochgradig dumm erwiesen. Denn schon lässt sich voraussagen, dass der Airbus der Halbleiter-Technologie, von dem die europäischen Technokraten schwärmen, mit Sicherheit unter chinesischer Flagge abheben wird.
Also mal gucken, bei den Batteriesachen bin ich immer schon so ein bisschen beeindruckt, wie schnell das jetzt ging. Bei der ganzen Halbleiter- und Chipproduktion in Sachsen, das ist ja auch nicht wenig, was da so passiert. In der Hinsicht ist ja genug Kapital da und das Ingenieurswesen ja eigentlich auch. Diese Chipsachen scheinen ja wirklich so ein bisschen, nicht nur mit magischem Denken, sondern auch mit magischem Handeln zu tun zu haben. Frank Rieger hatte mir das in diesem einen Gespräch, aus dem ich es da immer wieder zitiere, mal so beschrieben. Man baut eine Fabrik, in der ganz viele verschiedene Unterfabriken untergebracht sind und dann versucht man, sich diesen sieben Nanometern, fünf Nanometern zu nähern und dann hat man es irgendwann geschafft. Und dann hat man so einen Chip in der Hand und der hat tatsächlich diese Struktur, die man da braucht. Also guckt man sich genau an, wie man diese Halle gebaut hat und kopiert die genauso. Jedes Wasserrohr, das irgendwo lang fließt, wird genauso nachgebaut, weil man nicht genau weiß, warum es jetzt gelungen ist. Also versucht man einfach nur das Arbeitsprinzip, was man dann durch Testen herausgefunden hat, einfach zu duplizieren und dann hat man halt eine Fabrik. Und wenn es da brennt, dann ist das halt wirklich zerstört. Also dann muss man einfach von vorne anfangen. In der Ansicht scheint das alles total mega crazy zu sein. Aber ich glaube, dieses Argument ist doch wichtig zu sagen, es gibt verschiedene Chips, denn man muss ja nicht alles auf diesen fünf Nanometer und es muss so hochleistungsmäßig, sondern nicht immer wie beim Smartphone kommt es ja darauf an, jedes kleine Energieeinheitchen zu sparen. Und so wenn man jetzt einen Kühlschrank oder so ein Fernseher, so ein Smart TV oder ein Drucker oder sowas, da kann man durchaus auch mit 10, 20 Jahre alten Technologien kommt man da locker durch den Alltag.
Wir werden sehen, ob das mit den Chips gelingt. Aber es gibt natürlich grundsätzlichere Probleme bei den Lieferengpässen. Im OTLOTS Podcast war Mark Levenson zu Gast. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben über Containerschiffe, beziehungsweise eigentlich über den Container. Das Buch heißt The Box und der beschreibt hier jetzt mal so ganz direkt, unmittelbar, was da eigentlich mit diesen großen Containerschiffen los ist.
Do they save money?
Das war mir überhaupt nicht klar, dass die eigentlich so viel Kapazität hatten und dass die gar nicht voll wurden zum Teil.
Ja, es kommt immer drauf an. Ich glaube, da gab es auch viele Streitereien um Hoheiten, wie wir das ja dann bei Corona auch erlebt haben. Wer hat hier wohl Landerechte und so? Also das kommt da glaube ich sehr drauf an, dass Unternehmen von Ländern angehalten wurden, dann doch sozusagen die ein oder andere Hoheit über die Seewege zu erobern. Und dass man da das Amazon-Geschäft lieber erst mal wachsen und Geld verdienen machen und dann später und so fahren würde. Man sieht ja auch, inwieweit die ganzen Räder rein in Hamburg mit dem Senat und so, da immer verbandelt waren. Wer da wem kredite und so. Was da alles möglich war, Wirtschaftsförderung und so.
So ist es ja nun, dass diese Schiffe offenbar voll sind und sie sind vor allem sehr breit, diese neuen Schiffe und dann bleiben sie auch schon mal stecken. Es gibt aber noch ein Problem und das zeichnet jetzt, lieben sie einmal nach, das sich ergibt aus diesen breiten Schiffen.
Diese Megaschiffe, diese, die 20.000, 22.000, 24.000 TEUs halten, sind nicht länger als die Schiffe, die sie erzielen. Schiffe sind größer.
Das heißt, die Schiffe sind größer, sie können mehr beladen werden, aber man spart eigentlich keine Zeit, sondern im Gegenteil, man verliert sie.
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, dann teilen wir auf zwei Schiffe, ob man dann in der Summe dadurch besser fährt.
Ich glaube, es geht um die Länge. Also es geht ja um die Länge, dass man durch diese Breite des Schiffes braucht man länger mit diesem Kran zum beladen.
Ja, aber wenn du zwei Schiffe nimmst, die sich zwar schneller entladen, brauchst du halt doppelt so viel Treibstoff, wahrscheinlich, oder jedenfalls nicht eins zu zwei im Verhältnis.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja wieder eine Sache, die jetzt für den Hafen nicht interessant ist. Aber es ist generell verzögert sich. Also es wird dann dadurch langsamer. Und ich muss dem Mann glauben, weil er dieses Buch geschrieben hat, das wohl international gefeiert wurde.
Also Containerschiff ist super interessant.
Als das beste Buch über Container. Und von daher finde ich es also erstmal sehr erstaunlich, weil das sehr gut zeigt, wie fragil eigentlich diese Wege sind. Also das ist ja hier jetzt nicht darum geht, dass man sagt, ja gut, das klemmt halt da fest, das Schiff. Sondern es funktioniert alles. Und man sagt ja, aber das dauert immer da so ein paar Sekunden länger. Und da gibt es so und so viel Container. Und wenn man das mal hochrechnet und das dann hochrechnet, wie viele Schiffe so durchgeschleust werden durch diese Kanäle und durch diese Häfen, dann glaube ich, sind wir da schon ganz schön an einem Punkt, dass da sich was um zwei Tage dann am Ende verzögert. Und das bedeutet aber am Ende beim Endverbraucher sind es dann vier Wochen oder so was.
Das kann sein. Also die Globalisierung ist erst kürzlich wieder ganz nah an mich herangerückt, als ich erfahren habe, dass das Lastenrad des Nachbarn auf der Ever Given feststeckte.
Ah ja, ich kann dir sagen, dass ich mir einen Kamm wieder kaufen wollte und man sagte, der hat Lieferprobleme. Man sieht momentan überall Lieferprobleme. Deswegen machen wir mal weiter hier. WDR 5 Profit hat sich auch damit beschäftigt.
Die nach Corona dringend benötigten Aufträge sind da, sogar reichlich, aber sie können wegen Lieferengpässen nicht abgearbeitet werden. In 42 Prozent der deutschen Firmen ist genau das im Moment der Fall. Viele denken deshalb über eine Drosselung oder sogar einen Stopp der Produktion nach. Einfach, weil das nötige Material für die Weiterverarbeitung fehlt. Ob Stahl, Mikrochips, Kunststoff, Verpackungen, Holz, Aluminium, Kupfer oder spezielle Chemie-Produkte. Vieles ist gerade schwer zu bekommen und entsprechend teuer.
42 Prozent der deutschen Firmen haben da jetzt momentan Probleme. Hinzu kommt, dass es ja wieder Corona-Ausbrüche in China gibt.
Und die dann immer gleich super lockbar machen.
Wir sind ja Freunde von Zero-Covid. Also es zeigt sich wieder, diese Strategie ist nicht so gut. Und wir hören da mal auch nochmal WDR 5 Profit.
Das betrifft vor allem Importe aus Asien. Erst wurde die Produktion nach Corona nicht schnell genug wieder hochgefahren, um die plötzlich wieder anziehende weltweite Nachfrage zu bedienen. Und dann kamen die Transportprobleme dazu. Blockierter Suezkanal, weltweit deutlich weniger Passagierflüge und damit eben auch weniger Mitnahmemöglichkeit im Frachtraum. Schließlich noch coronabedingte Einschränkungen, wie die gesperrten wichtigen Schiff-Terminals in China, berichtet Jens Hildebrandt aus Peking, wo er als Ansprechpartner des DIHK für deutsche Firmen arbeitet.
Die Abfertigung in den Häfen hat nicht mehr funktioniert. Da gab es Personalmangel und einfach durch Covid-Vorschriften hat sich die Abfertigung verzögert, was sich dann auch auf die Lkw und auf den Schienenverkehr ausgewirkt hat.
Im Moment schätzt der Beträgt der Rückstau etwa drei Monate, aber auch danach dürften Container weiter Mangelware bleiben.
Wir wissen, das Weihnachtsgeschäft steht vor der Tür auf dann das chinesische Neujahr. Insofern wird es wieder eine zunehmende hohe Nachfrage aus China geben, die noch mal zusätzlichen Druck aufbauen wird auf die Logistikkette.
Das hat schon jetzt spürbare Folgen, denn was knapp ist, wird teurer. Die Frachtraten für Container haben sich verfünffacht.
China ist ja echt so eine Zickmühle. Auch so emotional, weil die wollen einfach nicht RNA-Impfstoffe importieren, sondern haben ja ihre komischen Totimpfstoffe in China, wo sie jetzt alles auch zusammen mengen und dann hoffen, dass sie damit einen höheren Wirkungsgrad haben. Also ist deren einziger Weg zu sagen, es gab einen Ausbruch, also machen wir jetzt komplett so Lockdown. Und dadurch haben sie immer diese spontan Lockdowns überall und die kommen nicht vorwärts. Wenn man sich nur die absoluten Zahlen anschaut, sieht die Ausbrüche nicht gefährlich aus, weil man auf tägliche Basis vielleicht 100 lokale Infektionen hat und 1, 4 Billionen chinesischen Menschen im Land leben. Mehr als die Hälfte der Provinzen hat Infektionen verbreitet und nur ein Fall ist genug, um die Autoritäten eine ganze Port zu schließen, weil sie eine sehr strikte 0-COVID-Strategie haben. In den letzten Tagen besuchte ich eine der wohnungslosen Bedingungen in Beijing, die auch nur wegen eines Fallen geschlossen wurde. Es gibt ungefähr 24 hohe Abenteuergebäude, also 10.000 Menschen können ihre Gebäude nicht verlassen, nur wegen eines Infektions. Es ist definitiv sehr ernst in diesem Bereich.
Es ist so verrückt, Fabian Kretschmer war das und berichtet das über China und man glaubt das gar nicht.
Das müssen wir ja noch Jahre machen jetzt oder so.
Ja, wie soll das je weitergehen? Also ich frag mich auch, wie das überhaupt dann noch mit internationalen Betrieben auf ist. Aber wir werden gleich noch mal gucken. Vielleicht ist auch jetzt alles durch Corona so leicht geworden. Dann noch mal Deutsche Welle. Konrad Busen ist da zu Gast und der schildert mal, wie er das so erlebt mit den globalen Lieferketten.
Und natürlich wissen wir alle, wenn China die Sälen hat, dann ist die ganze Welt den Fluss fangen.
Also Konrad Busen, du bist jetzt in Frankfurt mit mir.
ein Drittel der Produkte, die eine IKEA-Store in Deutschland meistens verkauft, ist nicht disponibel. Und die Mitarbeiter haben mir gesagt, dass die Dinge entweder an einem Containerschiff zwischen China und Deutschland hängen, oder wenn irgendwo in der Welt eine Faktenkarte ein Corona-Kurs hat, wird es oft sofort geschlossen, sodass es nicht verursacht werden kann.
Also, wir reden hier wirklich über die Rippeleffekte in den globalen Schaffungszahlen.
Sollte Deutschland mehr independent von all dem werden?
Nicht die China-Kurse kaufen würde die Kosten der Konsumenten hier in Deutschland viel höher sein. Und wir sollten nicht vergessen, die deutsche Wirtschaft ist eine der weltweit am meisten verbunden.
Die Exporten brauchen die globalen Schaffungszahlen und die Verkaufszahlen.
Die Coupling wird sicherlich nicht leicht sein, aber ich würde das gar nicht so absolut sehen.
Ja, vor allem spielt sich das jetzt nicht auf so einer Makroebene ab, sondern Unternehmer treffen jetzt Entscheidungen und dann muss man in zwei Jahren einfach mal gucken, wie so der Stand der Dinge ist. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt eine große politische Strategie bedarf, sondern sehr viele gucken sich jetzt gerade ihre Bilanzen so an und ziehen ein Resümee.
Kennst du das Unternehmen Blackroll? Die machen solche, du hast doch so was bestimmt. Da steht eine. Du bist ein sportlicher Mensch. Erklär, was man damit machen kann.
Damit massiert man seine Faszien, was auch immer das bedeutet.
Ja, aber es nutzen auch sehr viele Leistungssportler, um dann nach dem Training die Muskeln zu entspannen oder wie stellen wir das vor?
Es ist ein Sportgerät, auf dem man seine Muskeln noch mal drüber rollt einfach. Kann sehr angenehm sein.
Blackroll ist jedenfalls ein Unternehmen aus der Schweiz. Die beiden oder der Gründer ist Deutscher und sein Marketingchef auch. Und die waren im OMR Podcast zu Gast. Und sagen wir mal, die haben jetzt kein besonders großes Problem mit den Lieferketten, weil sie von Anfang an nicht auf Fernost gesetzt haben.
Wir versuchen immer, wenn es irgendwie möglich ist, in Deutschland zu produzieren, haben dann auch ein paar Produkte, die eben aus dem europäischen Raum kommen. Und so gut wie nichts oder so wenig wie möglich, dass wir eigentlich aus Fernost kaufen. Und das hat uns eigentlich auch einen riesen Wettbewerbsvorteil jetzt in der Corona-Zeit beschert, weil viele andere, die angewiesen waren auf die Produktion in Fernost, plötzlich Lieberschwierigkeiten hatten und wir konnten eigentlich durchweg produzieren.
Ja, und das ist aber auch ein bisschen lustig. Ja, denn du siehst aus welchen Materialen sie ist. Sie ist aus einem oder zweien, je nachdem, umso mehr Orange drinne ist, umso weicher wird sie. Also das ist keine sehr komplizierte Versorgung durch aufwändige Lieferung. Das sind auch keine Vorprodukte oder so, sondern einfach Rohstoffe.
Aber sie hätten es sehr viel günstiger machen können. Sie sagen das auch in dem Podcast, dass man also ein Drittel damit hätte sparen können. Aber erstmal hätten sie nichts gespart, denn die haben ja klein angefangen und haben wirklich so als Garagenunternehmen das fast erst mal so begonnen. Und das bedeutete fernost viel aus, weil man aus China zwar das hätte günstig bekommen können, man muss aber einen ganzen Container nehmen. Wohin damit? Und das war so der erste Schritt, das machte, ah nee, dann müssen wir irgendwie einen anderen Weg finden. Und dann hat sich das so etabliert und diese Rollen sind ja offenbar auch etwas teurer als die Konkurrenzprodukte, deshalb auch, ich kann es nicht einschätzen, hochwertig oder so. Jedenfalls hat man dann gesagt, dann zahlen wir lieber mehr. Und die haben natürlich jetzt das Lachen, weil sie schön abgesichert sind. Gehen wir jetzt mal weg von Faszienrollen zu Holz und Plastik. Auch das ist ja ein großes Problem.
Die Seele des Unternehmers weint, wenn er die Aufträge nicht abarbeiten kann, weil das Material und der Nachschub hakt.
Das heißt, man kann gar nicht sagen, woran es am meisten fehlt.
Das ist richtig so und vor allen Dingen mit unterschiedlichsten Begründungen. Also im Holzbereich nur, um ein Beispiel zu sagen, da hat seit November der Preis um 300 Prozent zugelegt. Woher kommt das? Das kommt unter anderem daher, dass große Länder, zum Beispiel wie Amerika, wie wir wissen Konjunkturprogramme aufgelegt haben zwei Billionen Dollar durch Joe Biden und die Amerikaner haben auch früher schon bei uns Holz eingekauft. Nur das Problem besteht darin, dass in Kanada, was eigentlich zu den großen Holzlieferanten zählt, massive Probleme hatte mit einer grassierenden Borkenkäferinvasion. Und zum Beispiel Waldbrände in Kalifornien und so weiter haben ein Übriges dazu getan, dass sich die Amerikaner auch auf den europäischen Märkten das Holz besorgen und um es auf den Punkt zu bringen. Die Amerikaner haben im Jahr 2019, 2020 42 Prozent mehr eingekauft als üblich. Und das und andere Dinge führen alleine schon im Holzbereich zu Preissteigerungen und eben zu Lieferschwierigkeiten, sowohl beim Handwerker einerseits, als auch zur entsprechenden Wartezeit beim Kunden andererseits.
Das war jetzt aus dem Deutschlandradio, das war Deutschlandradio Kultur, Deutschlandfunkkultur, jemand vom Handwerksverband, glaube ich. Und jetzt fragt man sich, wieso ist denn jetzt Plastik gerade auch ein Problem? Und das erklärt er jetzt und man wäre, glaube ich, so nicht drauf gekommen, wenn man nicht drinsteckt in dem Thema.
Kaufen die auch meine Lichtschalter oder warum kommen die nicht?
Ja, das ist fast anachronistisch oder merkwürdig, das auszudrücken. Plastik und ich wusste das vorher ehrlicherweise auch nicht, wird unter anderem als, sage ich mal, Abfallprodukt aus der Raffinerie der Erdöle gewonnen, wenn die gecrackt werden. Und ein wesentlicher Grund, warum die Produktion in den Raffinerien zurückgegangen ist, war und ist, dass der Flugbetrieb, wie wir wissen, nahezu zum Erliegen kam. Bedeutet, Kerosin wurde nicht mehr wie im früheren Umfang üblich raffiniert in den Raffinerien. Die Abfallprodukte konnten deswegen, so merkwürdig sich das anhört, nicht in Plastikprodukte umgewandelt werden. Und das endet dann tatsächlich, es klingt lächerlich, bis es aber nicht am mangelnden Lichtschalter, den der Häuslebesitzer oder Häuslebauer nicht mehr einbauen kann, weil die Lieferketten eben schwierig werden und der Nachwuchs nicht mehr stimmt.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Aber so hängt alles zusammen. Wieso?
Nein, wir wollen ja eigentlich Plastik und wenn wir jetzt alle eben Mobilität machen und so, dann fällt das ja immer weiter aus.
Ja, ja, jetzt haben wir dieses Decoupling-Thema, aber zugleich haben wir ja von Anfang an seit Corona immer wieder gesagt, ja, aber wir können uns ja jetzt so einfach treffen. Wir können ja jetzt von überall das machen und wir haben ja diesen Podcast auch begonnen, analog und dann mussten wir uns digital ausweichen. Jetzt bin ich ja Gott sei Dank wieder hier in Frankfurt. Wie hat sich denn das so auf der internationalen Ebene verschoben, habe ich mich gefragt oder ich wollte eigentlich wissen, gibt es da auch so ein Decoupling oder vielleicht genau das Gegenteil? Und da ist der OMR Podcast dann wirklich sehr hilfreich als Quelle. Und zwar war da beispielsweise der Venture Capital Mensch, Hendrik Brandes zu Gast, also die investieren in ganz tolle Start-ups und so weiter. Und der hat jetzt gesagt, was denn für ein Problem eigentlich heute so im globalen Markt dann besteht.
Ein Großteil der Mitarbeiter haben türkische Namen oder so, sagen wir mal, Namen, die jetzt nicht klassische deutsche Namen sind, sondern denkt, okay, das ist sehr paneuropäisch gebaut. Ist das auch so ein bisschen die Idee gewesen, in Rumänien überhaupt einen Partner zu haben?
Ja, also erst mal, ich glaube daran, wenn ich jetzt mal die Diskussion eine Ebene hochziehe, dass die klassischen Eintrittsbarrieren für disruptive, fundamentale Innovationen wie Infrastruktur und Zugang zu Daten und Informationen oder auch Zugang zu Computingpower, was auch immer, die gehen zurück. Und das führt dazu, dass der eigentliche Engpassfaktor für disruptive Innovation ist der kreative Kopf.
Das finde ich an sich eine ganz gute Überlegung. Also zu sagen, ich kann natürlich mit einem ziemlich minimalen technischen Equipment extrem viel machen. Also warum nicht in Rumänien? Warum glaubt man, ist das nur im Berliner Loft oder im Londoner Loft möglich? Und sie investieren, wo da eine rumänische Firma die unglaublich sich entwickelt hat und so. Und das sei für ihn ganz wichtig, das zu erkennen, dass sich das eigentlich dann wirklich globalisiert und nicht mehr nur auf die Zentren ausrichtet.
Ja, setzt aber voraus, dass man für diese disruptiven fundamentalen Innovationen schon sozusagen eine Infrastruktur hat, die eigentlich all das braucht, was wir hier thematisieren, Mikrochips und so weiter, überall verbaut.
Gut, da ist es, wenn es produktnah ist. Aber wenn du bei der Software zum Beispiel, würde ich sagen, brauchst du ja nicht allzu viel.
Ja, aber was man im Silicon Valley, das ist doch, also Christoph Käse, dieser Springer Cheflobbyist, der war ja mal im Silicon Valley und hat dann ein Buch darüber geschrieben, Silicon Valley und so weiter. Und seine große Erkenntnis war ja, klar, kann man immer sagen, der Einzelne, so wie auch die ganze Ideologie von Facebook und immer irgendwo sitzt einer, der hat die tolle Idee und den holen wir uns dann. Aber am Ende ist es doch dieser soziale Zusammenhang, Investoren, kluge Köpfe, Universitäten und dann alles so eng beieinander, dass die alle sich mit dem Fahrrad besuchen können. Also ist ja eine ganz große Voraussetzung für die Investoren dort, dass sie sagen, wir investieren nur, wenn ihr so nah bei uns arbeitet, dass wir mit dem Fahrrad zu euch fahren könnt.
Und Brandes geht genau davon weg und versucht auch Teams auszubilden, die überhaupt in der Lage sind, sich ein Bild davon zu machen. Man kann ja nicht einfach mal sagen, ich ruf mal in Rumänien an, welche Start-ups sind interessant, sondern da müssen ja Leute sich auskennen und er beschreibt das hier nochmal.
Die kreativen Köpfe sind nicht nur in den Hubs in London, Berlin, Paris und Stockholm. Die sind, also 85 Prozent, 90 Prozent der kreativen Köpfe Europas sitzen eben nicht in den großen Hubs, weil diese Infrastrukturnotwendigkeiten weggehen, nicht mehr so brauchen. Das hat jetzt auch nochmal befeuert durch diese ganze Remote-Trend im Rahmen von Covid. Führt das dazu, dass wir einen klaren Trend sehen der Fundamentale Innovation aus den Hubs raus. Die Hubs verlieren an Bedeutung. In die Fläche hinein.
Und das ist nicht nur gefühlt, also wir nehmen noch einen Clip dazu, um mal Zahlen sprechen lassen.
Schöne Zahl übrigens. 2010 gab es drei europäische Städte mit einem Unicorn. Diese Zahl ist 2020 40 Städte. Wenn du diese Landschaft anguckst, das ist total verteilt.
Ja, aber am Ende brauchst du da, du musst es trotzdem so organisieren, dass diese Menschen sich die ganze Zeit begegnen und so weiter. Also man kommt glaube ich von dieser raumgebundenenheit nicht ganz weg. Ich war jedenfalls beeindruckt oder auch ein bisschen fast erschüttert davon, welche Bedeutung Conferencing für Google hat. Also Google hat ja so ein spezifisches, wie Apple auch, so ein Programm. Klar, die leben jetzt davon, dass sie ihre Appstores und so weiter haben und irgendwer baut für die irgendwelche Apps, die dann halt über Apple und Google vertreten werden. Und zu den größeren Anbietern, da gibt es ja ihrerseits wieder App-Developer, die so Milliardenumsätze machen, irgendwelche Spiele und so. Und zu denen haben sie natürlich eine besondere Beziehung. Und da gibt es doch jedes Wochenende überall diese Konferenzen und da werden die dadurch die Welt gechattet und so weiter. Und ohne das ging es auch nicht. Und das kam eben wirklich zu einem abrupten Stopp, dann einfach durch Corona, wo auch die Developer, wie heißen sie die? Es gibt da so einen typischen Key-Account-Manager, die halt bei Google und Apple angestellt sind, aber dann den Kontakt halten und also diese Teamarbeit pflegen und was weiß ich, gemeinsame Werbekampagne und so weiter. Und die haben doch ganz schön zu kämpfen, die Beziehungen zu den Developern so zu halten, dass es für beide irgendwie fruchtbar ist. Also die wünschen sich sehr, dass es wieder zurückkommt in dieses Conferencing, wo man dann drei Tage zusammensitzt und hier und da und Catering und so weiter.
Aber auch nicht auf alle zu treffen. Also ich würde sagen, dass meine Kontakte eigentlich durch Corona stärker geworden sind. Jetzt nicht im privaten Umfeld, da ist manches auch weggebrochen, manches ist auch nicht so schade unter uns gesagt. Aber dass doch so Kontakte mit Leuten, mit denen man so jetzt beruflich wäre vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber zum Teil beruflich zu tun hat oder sonst wie zu tun hat, eigentlich auch zum Teil sehr stark geworden sind durch dieses Konferieren über Zoom und Co. Also klar weiß ich auch, dass dann Unterschied besteht und ganz ohne das Treffen wird. Ich habe dann eher neue Kontakte geknüpft, als der alte noch mal intensiviert. Das war jetzt eher meine Tendenz. Vielleicht bin ich aber auch einfach nur flatterhaft.
Das ist einfach ein Buch geschrieben. Das ist einfach ein Buch veröffentlicht.
Ach so, das hat dann gar nichts damit zu tun. Ich bin jedenfalls nicht die Statistik, sondern nur eine Einzelperson. Wir werden sehen. Noch mal was zur Frage der Bewegung oder der Globalisierung. Also wir haben jetzt ja gerade gesehen, die Produkte geraten ins Stocken. Aber die Migration ist ja am Laufen. Wir haben Move gelesen. Wir haben jetzt Zahlende aus Afghanistan. Da kann man auch mal hochrechnen. Du hattest das im Fernsehpodcast ja so schön vorgespielt, dass Laschet da sagte, ja, wir wollen die Ortskräfte retten und die Frauen. Und tat aber so, als seien das irgendwie so ein paar Künstlerinnen oder so ein paar Feministinnen, die gerettet werden müssen. Aber wenn man das mal wörtlich nehmen würde, die Frauen, dann sind das halt alle Afghaninnen. Und dann ist man ja sehr gespannt, was er da meint. Naja, also Migration ist das große Thema und bedeutet natürlich auch Globalisierung. Und noch mal hier Brandes von Early Bird hat so ein Projekt jetzt, dass er da Migranten sehr fördern will im Unternehmertum und bringt da auch jetzt noch mal so ein ökonomisches Argument zum Thema Migration.
50 Prozent aller Unternehmer im Silicon Valley sind Unternehmer, sind Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund. Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Mensch, der zu uns kommt, mit Migrationshintergrund ein Unternehmen gründet, ist doppelt so hoch als Menschen, die hier eingebettet und in Sicherheit aufgewachsen sind. Schon allein die Migrationsentscheidung als solche ist ja eine unglaublich beeindruckende und schwerwiegende unternehmerische Entscheidung.
Die Migrationsentscheidung als eine unternehmerische Entscheidung, gut, manche müssen einfach aus purer Not weg. Aber es gibt natürlich auch das andere. Und das fand ich nochmal sehr interessant. Also bei diesem Decoupling, Deklopalisierung, Klokalisierung muss man, glaube ich, sehr vorsichtig sein, welche Gleichzeitigkeiten da sind. Und das ist, glaube ich, beides möglich. Also es kann sein, dass wir uns was so diese harten Produktionen anbelangt dekappeln, dass wir aber auf das andere Feld gehen, also da, wo es um Arbeitskräfte geht, dass man da jetzt die Globalisierung erlebt. Denn der Arbeiter hat ja keine Ketten mehr bzw. muss sie dann trennen. Wir werden das beobachten. Zumindest international geht es weiterhin zu bei den Finanzmärkten. Und da gibt es jetzt ganz klar die These international. Du hast jetzt gerade das nochmal mit so Konferenzen und so. Das ist aber schon so Teambuilding. Aber du musst ja, wenn du ein IPO machen willst, also wenn du mit deinem Unternehmen an die Börse willst, musst du ja mit Investoren vorher sprechen. Und da hast du ja tausende Meetings. Und dann musst du eigentlich nach New York und all das. Das ging während Corona nicht. Und Tarek Müller hat auch bei OMR in einem Podcast mal von seinem IPO berichtet und hat hier was sehr Interessantes gesagt darüber, wie jetzt eigentlich die Investoren sich verhalten haben. Wo man nur noch über Zoom kommuniziert.
Was natürlich cool ist an Corona, muss man sagen, dass es halt viel einfacher fällt, internationale Investoren zu treffen. Und mein Gefühl ist auch, dass Corona schon geholfen hat, auch internationales Geld nach Deutschland zu holen oder nach Europa zu holen. Weil letztendlich machst du ja mit allen Video Calls. Wir hatten teilweise sogar Video Calls mit Leuten, die in Hamburg sind. Also du triffst halt niemand mehr. Das ist das gleiche Spiel für alle plötzlich. Und plötzlich steht dir der globale Markt offen. Das gleiche gilt aber auch für den Amerikaner. Das heißt, der Amerikaner, der in New York sitzt, der macht momentan auch ein Video Call mit seinen New Yorker Investoren.
Ja, das stimmt. Und Google versuchte da auch einiges, das aufzubrechen, indem man beispielsweise, wenn Konferenzen stattfinden, also fünf Leute sind in einem Raum und dann noch mal fünf irgendwo auf der Welt verteilt, dass alle digital an der Konferenz teilnehmen und nicht fünf einzeln und dann einmal in Raum, wo man so eine ganz andere Perspektive hat, sondern jeder hat ein Gerät vor sich und ist in der Konferenz mit einem eigenen Fenster und so weiter, sodass das da wirklich aufgehoben ist. Das sind glaube ich auch Versuche, die gelingen, nur es betrifft eben so das obere Ende der Leute, die wirklich wissen, was sie von dieser Konferenz wollen, worum es da geht. Also eine ganz zweckorientierte Programmierung.
Er schildert das dann auch da, das sind so 50-Minuten-Gespräche und die haben ihre sieben präzisen Fragen und die musst du genauso präzise beantworten, wie sie gestellt sind.
Mein Professor Stefan Kühler hat auf Sozialtheoristen noch mal so einen Text über den Verlust der Zufälligkeit geschrieben. Das darf man glaube ich nicht übersehen oder es macht ganz schön viel Aufwand, kann aber dann gelingen sozusagen es irgendwie künstlich anzubauen, so Spontanität anzubauen. Ich würde aber sagen, westliche, durchalfabetisierte und ökonomisch abgesicherte Menschen schaffen es über Videokonferenzen extrem viel Effizienz in ihr Leben reinzuholen. Schon bei Schulen hört es dann auf, finde ich. Also schon wenn man so jugendliche Teenager hat, die verlaufen sich doch dann sehr am Internet und so Schulkonferenzen, Lehrerkonferenzen, also dieser Unterricht hat gezeigt, dass es sehr schwer ist. Jetzt wirtschaftlich gesehen Produktionen und so weiter, die ganzen Ideen, die man früher hatte, Telemedizin und so weiter, dass man das auch mit Industriereportern, die man von zu Hause steuert oder so, da sind wir ja noch mega weit entfernt.
Also was geboomt hat, war ja doch so ein Onlineunterricht, also Sprachenunterricht oder sowas, das hat schon wohl ganz gut funktioniert.
Ja, Erwachsenenbildung funktioniert glaube ich sehr gut bei sowas. Klar, Volkshochschulen machen auch immer viele so Sachen, die braucht man wieder Raumgebundenheit, so Singen und sowas, aber was so Erwachsenen-Weiterbildung angeht, kommt man glaube ich sehr, sehr weit, weil man dann auch den Vorteil hat, man kann sich halt wirklich von dem Lehrer entbinden und kann einfach sagen, ich nehme das beste Video zum Thema. Das erleben wir Schüler schon in der Nachhilfe zu Hause, privat, wenn es einfach heißt, von dem eigenen Klassenlehrer, schau dir doch mal dieses Video von diesem Lehrer an. So, und dann gucken halt alle deutschlandweit irgendwie dasselbe Nachhilfe, der Video zu binomischen Formeln oder so. Und da, also so eine, die Integration ist super aufwendig, super komplex, im Sinne von, es ist so viel möglich, dass man sich glaube ich dann in fünf Jahren mal anschauen muss, was von Corona geblieben ist.
Und mitunter ist es aber einfach nur kompliziert.
Manchmal ist es nur kompliziert, manchmal ist es auch komplex, denn man muss ja immer belegen, alles was sie jetzt machen, sind ja Investitionen in, was weiß ich, schon allein das Umstrukturieren, das sind ja alles Investitionen. Und man sitzt halt immer da und denkt, naja, wir haben es ja mit Universalcomputern zu tun, es wäre ja eigentlich alles möglich. Und wir entscheiden uns jetzt aber für diesen Weg, ist das denn richtig so? Und dann kommt man halt ganz schnell in diese Kontingenz, es könnten ja auch andere Alternativen viel besser sein. Und dann kommt wieder irgendwer mit Benchmarks und dann deswegen ja auch sowas wie diese Podcast-Saal, in dem so Leute erklären, was sie hier so und so, dann versuchen alle davon zu lernen. Und ja, mal gucken. Also Containerschiffe werden weiterfahren, aber der ganze Rest steht wirklich mehr oder weniger zur Disposition. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Wir werden sehen, möchtest du noch eine Prognose abgeben für die Bundestagswahl?
Also die INSA-Umfrage hat ja jetzt erstmal die SPD vorne gesehen und die CDU bei 20 Prozent, was ein historisch niedriges Umfrageergebnis ist.
Du hattest es ja auch schon getwittert. Ich wollte es eigentlich heute bringen, aber du warst da ja auch offenbar, denken wir da gleich. Ist jetzt, also wir stellen uns beide die Frage, ist jetzt Olaf Scholz der deutsche Joe Biden? Ist das möglich, dass also einer wie Olaf Scholz, von dem man wenig erwartet, dann aber plötzlich sagt, gut, es ist der historische Augenblick, der es verlangt, dass ich jetzt Mietendeckel, Vergenossenschaftung von Wohnungen, dass ich sage, wir brauchen die Mobilitätswende, dass ich sage, okay, die Kumpels müssen früher aus der Kohle raus und wir finden da auch Förderprogramme und das tut eigentlich auch niemandem weh. Also finden wir jetzt einen, der das da macht und wen dann eint, Grüne und FDP unter sich, weil man ja Rot-Rot-Grün immer noch bekämpft, wo man auch sich fragt, warum eigentlich.
Es könnte ja durchaus sein, dass es in der SPD tatsächlich schlummert, aber sie bisher vom Schwarzen Stein der CDU einfach aufgehalten wurde. Aber dass da linke Kräfte entfesselt werden könnten, bei denen auch nach vier Jahren Regeln schafft der ein oder andere CDU-Opa sich von seinem Neffen nochmal erklären lassen, es war nicht alles schlecht, oder? Es hat sich doch wirklich was und so. In der Ansicht gibt es einige Potenziale. Auf der anderen Seite traut man dem praten SPD natürlich immer nicht so recht. Die SPD jenseits der GroKo hat man aber auch lange nicht erlebt. Das muss man halt wirklich sagen. In der Ansicht ist glaube ich wirklich alles offen. Ich traue den Umfragen nicht. Bei der Sachsen-Anhalt-Wahl wurde die AfD um 16 Prozent verschätzt in den Umfragen. Das ist natürlich eine Katastrophe dort. Deswegen, wenn es jetzt irgendwie heißt, CDU, SPD, Grüne sind alle irgendwo bei 20 Prozent, denke ich mir, ja gut, es könnte aber auch sein, dass die einen bei 25, die anderen bei 35 sind. Mal gucken, wie sich das verhält mit den weiteren Umfragen, die so kommen. Ich wünsche der CDU nur das Schlechteste.
Das muss man einfach festhalten und auch wirklich darauf drängen, dass sowohl Grüne als auch SPD alles dran setzen, dass sie nicht eine Koalition mit den Schwarzen noch mal ermöglichen, sondern die sind nämlich jetzt doppelt geschwächt dadurch, wenn sie nicht in eine Koalition kommen natürlich und auch dadurch, dass die, denn das ist eigentlich jetzt schon klar, je nachdem wie die Umfragen dann sein mögen, aber das ist schon klar, die verlieren richtig viele Leute, die da im Bundestag sitzen, die Büros haben, die die Lobbyleute empfangen und und und. Also das ist ziemlich schmerzhaft und deswegen drehen da ja auch gerade einige frei, weil sie denken, muss ich am Ende noch was Richtiges angehen?
Genau und sie erleiden gerade das, was lange ihr Trumpf war, nämlich Trägheit. Die CDU konnte sich die ganze Zeit so durchschleichen, sie kennen mich und so weiter und jetzt hat sie diesen Moment, dass es eigentlich noch ein paar Wochen sind bis zur Bundestagswahl, aber die Wahlkämpfer genau wissen, um den Eindruck, der sich jetzt bei der relevanten, für uns relevanten Wählerschicht eingestellt hat, um den gegenzuhalten.
Dann müssten wir Weihnachten wie Wahl machen.
Monate, Monate. Also für die ist quasi morgen Bundestagswahl, vor allem weil jetzt auch sehr viele schon Briefwahl machen und so weiter. Naja, die alten Wähler oscillieren halt wirklich jetzt zwischen CDU und SPD hinterher und bei Anne Wilhort ist ja kurz beschrieben dieser Moment, als sie festgestellt haben, die Wähler, nee, Baerbock wird es nicht. Also die macht irgendwas Quatsch mit ihrem Buch oder so. Hat man sich überlegt, ja, aber wer soll es denn dann machen? Und dann hat man gesehen, nee, es ist nicht schwarz-grün. So, es ist nicht schwarz. Also sprangen sie alle so von der CDU zu SPD. Und wir wissen ja, Rheinland-Pfalz hat ja, also deine Heimat hat ja insbesondere gezeigt, über 70-Jährige wählen zu 85 Prozent entweder CDU oder SPD. Und wir haben sehr viele alte Leute, die mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch ihrem Wählerauftrag nachkommen, anders als die jungen.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass die jungen nicht alle die FDP wählen. 21 Prozent sind einfach zu viel. Also dann muss man von der Zukunft wenig erwarten oder in dem Irren glauben sein, dass man zu diesen ein Prozent gehört, das so prima sich durchwurscht. Und da kann man ja mal durchrechnen. Wenn 21 Prozent die FDP wählen, dann kann man da sicher sein, da wählen 20 Prozent gegen sich selbst.
Ja, es ist Verblendung.
Wir schauen mal, aber wir behalten natürlich auch die großen anderen Themen im Blick. Und wer weiß, vielleicht wird die Bundestagswahl gar kein großes Thema in der nächsten Folge. Ich gehe sogar fast davon aus, weil wir vielleicht dann noch gar nicht so genau wissen, wie die Koalition ist. Vielleicht haben wir wirklich auch noch sehr lange Angela Merkel.
Ja, sie hat ja schon mal gesagt, so bis Jahresende, ach nee, bis Ende der Legislaturperiode. Aber es ist mindestens bis Jahresende. Also das kann mir kein anderes zählen. Gerade mal, wie es sich beim letzten Mal abging. Außer es ist jetzt so überzeugend eine 56 Prozent linke Mehrheit möglich, die dann auch wirklich gemacht wird, weil Kevin Kühner Olaf Scholz morgens einen richtigen Tonfall erwischt oder so. Aber ansonsten müssen wir das mal abwarten. Wir lesen im Salon das Facebook-Buch. Ich wollte ja eigentlich diesen Monat ein bisschen Facebook machen, aber das ganze Metawürst und so können wir ja in den Salon verschieben. Denn wir werden wahrscheinlich viel Anlass haben, um über Facebook zu reden.
Das ist ein hochinteressantes Buch von zwei Journalistinnen. Ich habe reingeguckt und ich glaube, das ist noch mal, was die Enthüllungen anbelangt, interessant. Beziehungsweise auch noch mal diesen Konzern, den wir jetzt als User so abgeschrieben haben, weil wir bei Facebook nicht mehr sind oder höchstens den Messenger benutzen, weil er praktisch ist.
Ich bin ja auch völlig außer.
Man ist bei Instagram und denkt aber dann nicht immer an Facebook, obwohl man das immer mitdenken muss und sonst ist man bei Twitter. Also es ist glaube ich sehr wichtig, nochmal dieses Facebook Konglomerat sich anzusehen. Also da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Ich werde noch ein Buch vorstellen. Und zwar hat Werner Herzog nach vielen vielen Jahren endlich wieder ein Buch geschrieben. Und zwar über einen Soldaten, einen Japaner, Onoda heißt der. Der hat 45 verpasst. Der ist da in den zweiten Weltkrieg für Japan. Und die weiteren Entwicklungen hat er aber nicht mehr mitbekommen. Und hat so 29 Jahre einsam im Wald noch Widerstand geleistet. Obwohl die Kapitulation schon längst da war. Es ist eine verrückte Geschichte. Auch wahre Begebenheit beruht das Ganze.
Also ein Drehbuch oder wie?
Onoda gab es. Werner Herzog hatte ihn getroffen, wollte immer mal einen Film draus machen. Und jetzt ist es aber ein literarisches Werk geworden. Also ich bin gespannt, kann gespannt sein und ich habe ein Interview mit der taiwanesischen Dorobäer. Die haben auch jemand im digitalen Ministerium, eine nicht-binäre Person, die aber sagt, ist sie ja vollkommen egal, mit welchem Pronomen man sie anspricht. Also wird dann im Interview auch immer als Digitalministerin angesprochen. Und ich sag mal so, sie ist das exakte Gegenteil von Dorobäer und wir wünschten, wir hätten so eine Person hier bei uns.
Ja, bei mir war ja Urlaubsmonat, deswegen habe ich alles noch in meiner Read Later Liste. Aber ich glaube, da sind paar Schätze drin. Ich bin mir sicher.
Hast du denn im Urlaub nicht gelesen? Ich dachte, man fährt in den Urlaub, um zu lesen.
Nee, ich fahre mit Kindern in den Urlaub, da lese ich ja nicht. Sehr gut. Also lesen wir Facebook. Ich glaube, ich lasse es bei einem Buch diesen Monat. Und dann stiefeln wir durch den Salon und dann ist schon Bundestagswahl. Also in deren Sicht lasst euch impfen. Ich glaube, es ist alles in Gämmen.
Das ist ja mal der kleine Stich, aber es sind nur ganz wenige, die wir hier treffen.
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Wir nehmen es mit Humor und raten das auch allen zu tun, mit ein bisschen Humor, bisschen Pragmatismus und dann nicht mehr weiter darüber nachdenken, reden, einfach weiter. Es ist doch ganz schön, wenn man sich so durch die Welt wieder bewegen kann. Genau. Und nicht immer nur Ängste haben muss. Deswegen nochmal da eine Empfehlung.
Richtig. Und auf jeden Fall mit guter Laune, die Bundestagswahl. Es gibt ganz viel Grund, diese Bundestagswahl mit guter Laune mitzumachen.
Gut.
Lasst euch nicht von Stimmung auf Twitter oder so irgendwie verderben. Sehr gut. Na dann, bis in den Salon. Nächste Woche.